[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
exciting events but it is our first
impressions that we remember best
first diploma
your first job in a big company
edible emotions from the first date the
first expensive things you bought when
you got your first paycheck and your
first Investments with freedom broker
Freedom broker look at your favorite
brands from A New Perspective
hello everybody and welcome to chess.com
and welcome to the final day of this
year's fee day world rapid championships
today we're going to find out who gets
the glory and who gets all the accolades
winning what is now considered to be an
extremely important title uh in the
world of Chess it's not just a random
rapid tournament this is the World
Championships held in very high esteem
by all the top players in the world and
talking of top players and we're going
to go through exactly what's going on in
the tournament in a minute I am
delighted to be joined by the one and
only Olympic gold medalist multi-time
British champion great commentator in
his own right the one only David Howe
David lovely to be here again with you
today
yeah uh two kind Lawrence thanks it's
great to be with you it's uh it's been a
fantastic few days this is our third day
the third day for the players now and
this is where it is crunch time uh
everything matters every single move
every single half point and as you
mentioned it's not just the titles it's
huge money prizes at stake uh this could
be potentially life-changing especially
for some of the younger players and we
could be in for a real Marathon day of
chess if there are indeed tie breaks uh
we see in front of us what's at stake
you mentioned Lawrence we do have those
World titles in the open and the women's
sections we have medals up for grabs and
also massive prizes in the open section
it is sixty thousand dollars that's not
pocket change and in the women's section
40 000 and uh yeah we will as uh you've
mentioned there Loris we will see uh
four rounds of uh chess in the open
section and three rounds in the women's
section and those possible tie breaks
could be exciting if and when they do
happen
yeah we will of course go into a bit
more detail if and when they do happen
uh David as you said titles on the line
tons and tons of prizes sixty thousand
dollars for first in the open forty
thousand in the women's section
um let's have a look at the current
standings in fact of the women's section
first of all we mentioned yesterday it's
packed at the top as we can see there
are three players on six and a half
tanjong ji who's had a very very decent
tournament thus far showing the world
really that she is a real force to be
reckoned with uh at the top Alexandra
gojkina
arguably on paper the strongest player
in the tournament uh got over 2600 feed
8 for classical chess but of course is
uh an absolutely uh Exquisite rapid
player as well and SRI Savita now this
is the player David that I don't know
too much about do you know much about
SRI Savita
I must admit Lawrence before the
tournament I knew next to zero about
Savita but I've been doing my research
I've played through all of their games
from this event and she is phenomenal
she's only 15 years old so this is a big
breakthrough event for her and she's won
some games in very nice attacking style
so she's one to watch she's in joint
first it won't be easy to keep up that
streak as she faces some of the top
seeds but uh yeah one of the stars of
the event so far
yeah absolutely
um and we won't take away of course all
of the the chasing pack there on Six
Points a bunch of players and all very
experienced the likes of hampi canuro
Valentina Nino batist Philly even the
players on five and a half are not out
of it including former women's War
Champions Alexander kristenyuk and
anjanetta stefanova so very very tight
there we can see some of the match-ups
for round nine David massive massive
match on on board one
yeah massive match tanzong Yi faces
goliachkin and uh goyatikina actually
has a score to settle tanzongi knocked
her out of the Women's World
Championship cycle uh in the candidates
tournament just a few weeks ago and on
board to abdomalik the local favorite
cheered on by the Home crowd there in
Kazakhstan does face Savita so as you
mentioned Lawrence we will catch up on
those games a bit later meanwhile maybe
we can check out the leaderboard in the
open section where we do have just one
leader at the moment it is that guy
again Magnus Carlson on seven and a half
out of nine and he's followed by three
players uh fedes Abdus and young Vincent
kheimer and there's a huge pack one
point behind from Magnus which includes
such uh Titans as Fabiana caruana Anish
giri Eric icy dubov anything could still
happen uh Carlson could still slip up
it's not going to be easy for him still
plenty of Chess to be played but he's
got to be the favorite right
well of course he's the favorite he's
he's the clear favorite he's uh ahead
that extra half Point can mean uh
everything of course he's not going to
have an easy day today a lot of guys are
going to be gunning to win
um as you said there we can see uh some
of the names on the leaderboard the guys
on six points quite a bit behind I would
say points and a half with three rounds
to go with Magnus at the top probably is
not an achievable Gap but certainly
um
if you're a point behind or just half a
point for example if you are Vincent
Kmart or Philadelphia tour of the
reigning rapid world champion you do
absolutely still have a great shot it's
just gonna all be about as per usual is
Magnus gonna take his foot off the gas
is he gonna give an opponent an
opportunity because thus far David I
don't really remember a game where he
was in serious serious trouble do you
uh no Magnus has had positions where
he's had to knuckle down and just hold
the draw and he's done that very well
but uh in general he's taking his
chances when they've come Magnus Carlsen
and he hasn't let too many points slip
away we do see the match-ups in front of
us now Magnus is up against the young
German Prodigy Vincent kaimer uh Fabiano
caruana has worked his way up the table
he's now on board too he's going to be
aiming to take down fedes and Abdul
Torah the final leader against you Yang
Yi some big names of course in these uh
matchups for round 10 but another few
big names missing Nakamura two whole
points behind Carson not even on the top
10 boards anymore that Sheila grave has
dropped down uh plenty of names we
associate with rapid chess Blitz chess
but uh they're just struggling a bit so
far and uh you mentioned there Lawrence
it is the final Sprint but it is four
games remaining today in the open
section uh three in the women's section
so there's plenty of time to catch up
behind matching
sorry yes indeed foreigners and uh
uh uh I would I got that completely
confused three in the women's four in
the open Indeed so there is still time
that is true actually Magna is going to
have to be on top form we get an
overview a bird's eye view there of the
playing or we can see the players
getting ready uh we can see Vladimir to
save playing against Fabiano caruana
Fabi uh back in the mix is a point off
the lead uh but you can never rule
Fabiano out had a great uh end of the
day yesterday beating punkrat of
subchenko and Gareth to get a solid
three out of three and that's what you
need these little runs in these rapid
tournaments or Blitz tournaments it's
it's it is a momentum based tournament
um
and uh now with white against photo save
Fabiano should be quietly confident this
is a pretty good pairing for Fabi I
would say uh what do you think David
yeah you definitely want to start the
day with white as you mentioned it's all
about going on those big streaks one
good day is often enough to propel you
up to those top places we see Fabi now
with the white pieces a moment ago we
saw Abdul satorov about to sit down he
also starts the day with white and like
you said Lawrence this is key uh Fabiano
with white he will need to win really in
order to LeapFrog some of those players
above him in the standings uh he'll need
full points and uh here as well we see
that huge Clash on board one of the
women's section Tanzania with whites
against goliachina what will her
strategy be uh she managed to beat in
some really tense playoffs uh in the
candidates tournament just a few weeks
back and
um it's never easy do you stick do you
twist it is the final day it's all about
nerves it often comes down to just uh
those little details one slip up here
taking your eye off the ball sudden
players often Panic there we see ikara
Nakamura slightly lower down the table
um aiming to fight his way back up in
the background we see our countrymen
Lawrence meet Ghazi yeah and uh yeah one
of the only English representatives in
these two tournaments and uh back to the
top boards we see Jordan van Forest
against uh Lehman very famous streamer
and uh it's looking focused looking
relaxed just as the games are about to
kick off
indeed
games about to kick off and
one man holding up the show uh does tend
to arrive late-ish prefers to
uh
be the last day and I think that has
that is for some psychological effect as
well it's almost as you know when you're
waiting for him you know there's that
kind of admission subconsciously that he
is the important player in this somehow
that you're having to wait for him he's
not having to wait for you I wonder if
that's something he's worked on or
that's something he's caught he's aware
of as a kind of psychological ploy to
already get a small psychological
advantage uh right from the off
yeah um you're right it's all about mind
games at the top level it's all about
getting under the opponent's skin and uh
Magnus not only does he arrive late his
clock has been started but he slowly
just takes his time to adjust his pieces
and uh you can see that Vincent replant
instantly he was itching he was
impatient to get this game going and we
have started it's a Queen's Gambit
declined and a Catalan by Magnus he's
taking this seriously no more 1v3 uh
he's back to his world championship
repertoire this is what he employed
against janapomnishi consistently last
year throughout the world championship
and Vincent plays a very ambitious
approach as black grabbing a pawn early
that porn on C4 might not last for too
long but Vincent will try to keep it
intact if he can and this is very
theoretical
um this is uh yeah this is Mainline
Theory very topical stuff uh at the
moment Lawrence uh are you surprised
that Magnus is going back to more
classical openings after offbeat
openings brought him so much success in
the first two days
um not particularly uh no uh you know
Magnus
he uh I think he he decides a lot of
these things I know that he does decide
I know that he does have an idea of more
or less what general opening he wants to
play before each game I think he speaks
to Peter heiner and they discussed I
don't think they go into too great a
detail because obviously it's a rapid
game and a lot can happen but they have
an idea about the general opening so it
doesn't surprise me that he's playing
something like this against Vincent
um I think he's not going to be overly
audacious today he's got that half point
lead he doesn't have to go completely
crazy so
I'm not too surprised although the
opening that I'm seeing on the board now
I I've never actually seen this position
before David I don't know if you have
yeah
um I had seen this position before up
until magnus's Bishop G5 so white has
put the bishop on G5 as we see and that
Bishop has been nudged it's been uh
asked the question by black playing H6
why it starts to go Bishop now
either it's got a retreat back to a
pretty awkward square and Magnus will
have to admit a lot of time or he's
going to have to take Black's Knight on
F6 if he does take this Knight on F6 if
it's will happily take back with his
bishop and
still Magnus is a pawn down if he goes
after this black C4 Pawn White's Central
Pawn might well drop off and
the Catalan opening it's got a great
reputation of course at all levels it
does often entail a pawn sacrifice but
it is strange to see Magnus thinking
after playing these first few moves
instantly Vincent as far as I know has
played something similar to this before
so it's slightly curious that uh Magnus
did pause but he does eventually take
this Knight and
um yeah we mentioned earlier that he
likes to arrive late very similar vein
to Kasparov and it feels like Magnus in
recent years has been developing this
kind of dynamic approach to the openings
middle games happily sacrificing pawns
there we see the exchange Knight takes
C4 is now met
think by just Bishop takes D4 and yeah
Magnus has to back up this Dynamic
opening choice with some accuracy
otherwise black is just a pawn up black
has got a very healthy position Lawrence
yeah I I simply don't get it I think
this is just a botched attempt by Magnus
in a Catalan
um I don't really
uh I don't see it okay Knight A3 played
fairly logical move trying to win the
pawn back this way but Camp black now
for example play in group Feld style
David this is something you will be very
aware of with the move Pawn to C3 the
point being that after B takes E3 maybe
now I can go Queen A5 and is this a
little bit awkward because you're
suddenly attacking three different
points in the right position and I don't
quite see a way to defend against that
actually
yeah it looks very tempting for black I
guess in this uh this position we're
analyzing Queen to B3 as possible and
after Bishop takes E5 white can flick in
the Z visions of the intermediate move
from Knight C4 uh attacking Black's
Queen attacking the black bishop and
white will come out of this with
interest uh White is far ahead in
development so there are tricks I saw a
few uh feature chats there suggesting
that Magnus is bluffing often this is
what the top players do they do pause
for a few moments not necessarily to
recollect uh their opening Theory but
just a bluff I've done this plenty of
times for myself you pretend you don't
really know what's going on and suddenly
you speed up you bash out the moves and
the opponent can't really deal with the
change in momentum and uh against
psychological warfare potentially from
Magnus Carlson if Vincent doesn't play
this move C3 maybe we can go back to the
game position then yeah there are
tempting Alternatives you could just
Castle get the king to safety you could
give a check first via A5
and uh either way it looks like white
might well be winning the pawn back on
C4
uh if he does Magnus will be happy once
again
uh interesting opening developments
first Magnus looked a bit lost then
Vincent now pondering what to do
and uh yeah I expect this one to take
maybe a slower course over the next few
moves as players uh do just uh just find
their bearings and uh yeah Lawrence
maybe we can uh take a scan at the other
chasing track of the other games
absolutely uh should we go to
I guess we should have a quick look at
Fabian against for the servers we
mentioned it in the introduction Fabiana
with the white pieces
um we had some kind of weird Queen scan
that declined where Federal save has
decided to
go for a kind of poison Pawn playing
Queen B6 Queen takes B2 giving up the
two Bishops uh he managed to get a Fabi
to lose castling rights as well but at
what cost because
this looks awfully
risky uh to play like this I mean for
example the move rugby one here just is
screaming out to be played hitting this
pawn and trying to enter trying to force
a weakness for example if black now
plays a move like P6 you can now for
example follow up with Queen C2 hitting
more of these pressure points and now
something like Rook C8 might run into
95. so
I don't know I mean playing like this in
Rapid is
something I tend to try and avoid I mean
I tend to try and avoid it in real real
chess or let's say uh classical chess
anyway because I'm not really a pawn
Grabber surely white has got a massive
initiative here
um
David
yeah you're completely right it does
look scary for black that black king
still needs a couple of moves before it
can cast loyal to safety on G8 and uh in
the meantime Fabiano surely must be in
his preparation uh if I look at the
clock times though Fabi has spent quite
a few minutes fedes has played almost
instantly up to this point so maybe he's
worked out at home beforehand that he
can get away with grabbing this pawn and
he is a maximalistev he will always
choose the most ambitious approach in
any position whether that's grabbing
pawns whether that's going for an
aggressive plan uh even at the cost of
some kind of long-term strategic
weaknesses and yeah it just shows that
both players know or at least believe
that they need to win in order to catch
up with Magnus
um you can't just take it easy you can't
just step off the pedal and uh kind of
take a calmer approach go for the draw
because Magnus has well he will just
increase his lead if that does happen
and the one thing I will say about this
position after rugby one Lawrence
there's no immediate threat
um
would be met by Queen A6 check nice so
black does have one move to try and
untangle to unravel his pieces to maybe
bishop E7 just get developed Bishop D6
uh I think you're gonna mention that
would drop a piece I believe uh
three uh Queen A6 and Bishop D3 blocking
a check and uh next move the black
Bishop on D6 would fall
so there are some tactics in the air but
Abby has played your move Rook B1 no
immediate threat but that's Queen side
pawns under serious pressure
uh yeah really exciting game this one
it's shaping up to be
yeah this this could go this is a three
result game for sure uh I did want to
quickly check in on board three as well
because the other guy uh sitting on a
seven out of nine is the current
reigning uh rapid board Champion Abdul
sartorov playing White against you Yang
Yi and
we have a
strange position that's actually come
out of a petrolf opening but I tend to
believe that you young years actually
doing quite well here with black this
bishop raining down on the White Queen
side and the problem is we often hear
about the two Bishops how great they are
yes they are great but only when they
are working and when they have got open
diagonals this is one of those blocked
let's call it semi-closed positions
and
I don't know I I
think I would take black in in a real
game here David what do you think
uh I'm inclined to agree I think it is
objectively roughly balanced white does
have ideas to open up the position he's
just played Rook to B1 maybe he'll throw
his B Pawn forward at some point don't
be surprised if white also throws his G
Pawn forward just to try and open lines
just to try and get the Bishops working
black does have one problem piece that
is the Black Knight sitting on A6 it
still takes three or four Tempe uh to
activate that Knight and also the other
Factor here I've analyzed enough with
computers to know that computers always
will take the bishop here they always
will take the space and uh sometimes
they forget that in human terms the
plans might be easier for one side I
mean while we do see why pushing forward
with B4 instantly blocked with B6 I do
think it's in the balance the uh kind of
the climax of the game will be a lot
later once both sides have fully
mobilized their Rooks uh maybe we'll see
an exchange of one set of Bishops for
example and uh it's only later that
we'll uh find out who has the Practical
Advantage whose position is easier to
play but
I'm just loving how imbalanced it is
with the bishop pair with the pawn
structure both sides have protective
past pawns later for the end game that
could be vital and uh yeah it does feel
like all of the players just happy to
maintain the tension happy to take risks
at this early stage on the final day and
uh yeah Abdul sotorov he's he really
excels in close positions where he can
just maneuver maneuver wait and then
find his moment to strike later that's
how he actually won the world rapid
title last year so many block positions
but he seemed to find his way past the
top players in the world so I'm I
wouldn't be surprised if he can conjure
up some magic here as white
we'll soon find out let's go back to the
Magnus Carlson game uh we've had some
developments there after Knight A3 we
did in fact get the move Queen A5 check
which you mentioned David uh which was
blocked by the move Queen D2 uh there
was a trade Vincent Castle
Knight recaptured this Pawn on C4 so
material is now equal uh rook d8 and now
Magnus using the king to protect the
pawn and getting out of the pin makes
perfect sense King E3 Knight D7 Rook D1
Knight 286.
uh Lawrence I I love how nonchalant you
are about playing channel three I mean I
know it's an end game I know Queens are
off the board but what a move King E3
leading from the front with the King
yeah I mean uh
what else I mean you know the king uh
does a great job protects the pawn gets
out of the pin it feels like a fairly
natural move there black doesn't really
have any pieces out to bother that King
so this looks totally standard to my
eyes
yeah I must say I love the I love the
feature chat there by I think it was
Dale uh by Dale and uh he was saying
Magnus is playing King of the Hill I
don't know if you've dabbled in that
chess variance Lawrence but King of the
Hill the whole concept of the game is
you win by Checkmate or by getting your
king to one of the four Central squares
E4 D4 E5 and D5 that's my favorite
variant of Chess maybe behind fish
around behind 960 but uh yeah Magnus
active king that's what he believes in
in the end game and a couple more moves
as you mentioned uh have been played
after Rook D1 Knight B6 and I think
Magnus has pushed forward even further
f4 on the last move so he's also
creating a little hiding place if Knight
D5 check comes in hitting that King he's
just gonna slide back and say okay I've
lost a bit of time but so have you with
your knight uh E4 potentially coming
maybe he'll Steamroller forward with
some pawns light Square Bishop one C8 is
the problem piece can't really get
active while white Knights are clamping
down White's light Square Bishop hoking
uh at some weaknesses from afar
yeah I must say the more I look at it
the more I think this is classic Magnus
this is uh this is a bread and butter
type of position uh this is how we kind
of ascended to the world's Elite just
grinding away these slightly better end
games and it does feel like black is
still the one uh with the onus uh the
burden of equalizing
I don't know who you prefer Lawrence
yeah no I absolutely agree I would take
white here all day because as you said
this bishop on C8 is a is a huge problem
piece I I simply don't know
uh how black intends to get that piece
into action I think his last move Bishop
B7 was designed to try and play the move
F6
um and cause some disharmony uh amongst
the knights but Rook ac1
prevents
a lot of those ideas because now if F6
you can just go
Knight G6 let's say and this is Checkers
met by Rook takes C4 and
it's not clear that playing F6 has
actually helped you now with black
because you created a further weakness
here so also
remember Vincent Kmart very much comes
from the Peter leco School of Chess he's
not going to create unnecessary
weaknesses he's not going to weaken his
King unnecessarily
um but this position even though the bar
as we can see is kind of dead middle
it's it's not that easy at all to to
navigate this position with black I
don't really know what his best plan is
here David what what do you suggest here
for for him
yeah I feel Black's position is very
tough at least in human terms uh I mean
it's it's tough to get excited about
Black's position it's tough to find
anything productive to do he does in the
end go for F6 as you mentioned long term
that is very weakening uh now there are
some light square holes around uh
Black's position especially on G6 E6 is
a bit more tender now that pawn there
Magnus retreats to D3 I actually quite
like this move in the Catalan uh as the
old Legends like Swedish Great Wolf
Anderson uh used to show on a daily
basis a knight on D3 is so flexible it
can jump forward to C5 later it holds
the whole position together so I like
this retreat
and I do expect Vincent to try and
alleviate uh some of the pressure by
swapping off one set of nights and I do
feel why tonight's just too strong I'm
expecting a move such as Knight takes C4
uh maybe black light Square Bishop can
re-root itself now via D7 later and then
E8 and out as you're showing there
Lawrence out on a different diagonal so
yes the move F6 comes with some
drawbacks but at least it creates some
squares he's chosen not to go for this
he's actually keeping the tension
Vincent by playing King F7 now I would
be slightly afraid of white planting a
knight on the A5 Square
um again this is typical strategy uh in
this type of Pawn structure if white
tonight ever lands on A5 then it really
clamps down on Black's position now
Black's light Squad Bishop pretty much
rooted to Its Spots it can never develop
uh at least it can never comfortably
develop because Black's B7 and pawns and
C6 pawns are always under watch from
whites pieces I would be terrified of
getting into a bind like position here
as black where you can barely move
either your Bishop will be tied down
defending the B7 Pawn or if for example
black plays a move like Rook B8 The Rook
will be tied down long term no way to
evict white tonight on A5 and uh the
bind will continue white here Magnus
could play A3 B4 slowly slowly build up
and uh it's a risk-free advantage
that's uh what he's dreaming of in the
tournament situation as well looking
very good for white right now
yeah I think you mentioned it before
classic uh Magnus
um just knows how to keep the tension uh
knows how to put that little bit of
pressure on his opponents and this is
awkward for black no getting away from
it this is not a position that Vincent
is gonna feel overly excited about
playing with black that said
again coming from the Peter lecco School
of Chess he'll understand that his
position is solid uh he's passive but
solid so he needs to find a way just to
release a little bit of the tension as
things stand and if he manages to do
that I think he's going to be okay as
you can see the bar is is is absolutely
not
going crazy for white here the question
is how do you release some of the
tension here normally you do that via
trading pieces so maybe what black can
do is play a move like Knight D5 check
King F2 can he try and trade a pair of
knights with Knight B4 uh saying okay
the A2 Pawn might actually be on free
here so this might exist but it's it's
difficult to play nonetheless and in
fact your move Rook V8 has been played
now and now I do expect Madness as you
said just to play A3 it cuts out 95
Knight before ideas and It prepares B4 I
think A3 is just going to be played most
of the time here by Magnus
yeah exactly and we should mention
there's a lot of uh talk of the
evaluation bar uh in the featured chat
today and uh yes the position might be
equal but that's with best play and
that's if black defense like a computer
and hey surprisingly Magnus doesn't play
A3 he doesn't take a timeout to cut out
Black's plan uh he doesn't prevent it at
all he just improves his Bishop slightly
that's very mysterious I've got to say
White's Bishop looks nice and pretty
sitting on this F3 square but what's it
actually doing I don't think he wants to
poke around with any checks on H5 that
could simply be blocked
I've yeah I'm surprised I'm a bit
gossmacked I've got to say uh what is
the idea there these top players they
keep us guessing as commentators they
keep their opponents guessing
um sometimes they keep the evaluation
bar the computer guessing it's uh it's
very tough to see uh what the idea is
now black can go for that idea you
mentioned Lawrence maybe now is the
moment Knight D5 Knight B4 swap off
pieces before it's too late you are
cramped and that is conventional wisdom
trade-off when you're cramped uh
meanwhile uh we
yeah meanwhile there are other uh
interesting games uh if we look around
the uh the pairings maybe we can check
out this game by Anish Geary looks
really really interesting right now uh I
mean look at this white king what's it
doing on F2 and remember you're facing
Daniel too of one of the best attackers
in the world he's basically Michael tal
reincarnated and uh I mean he's going
for the white king we saw some beautiful
checkmates from him yesterday could he
do the same again Lawrence
while I fear for Anish in this position
this is not the kind of position Anish
loves and it's exactly the sort of
position Daniel dubov loves F5 uh
kicking the bishop so the bishop really
either it can't even really come back
because D4 is hanging so you have to
take and I think Daniel's idea is
actually to push again with the F4 I
think this is His Brilliant kind of idea
the point being wow if Bishop takes F4
you lose this guy and if G takes F4 can
you now play the rambunctious
unbelievable move Pawn to e five trying
to get this queen into action here for
example if F takes E5 you've won a bunch
of Pawns but at what cost Queen H4 check
the king is forced to go to G1 and now
it's so close can oh my goodness I'm
seeing all kinds of exciting oh my
goodness this bishop takes E5 work here
David
looks good and Rook G4 check look at
this and if F takes G4 Queen takes G4 is
going to be made after Queen takes G2
next these kind of ideas suddenly exist
and when you are and this is on the
board F4 is actually on the board and
after G takes F4 is he gonna play E5 he
could of course just take here this is
also very reasonable this also looks
very difficult to play against
nonetheless whatever he does decide
oh my goodness Annie scary he's not
going to enjoy having to find some only
moves there this is this is surely all
duboff here
yeah and look at the clock Anish is
suffering struggling remember Anish giri
he as you mentioned does not like these
types of positions if you check out the
chess.com Awards of the Year some of the
best games of this year have been played
against Anish giri mamajarov sacrificed
all of his pieces to beat anishkiri in
the Champions chess tour and remember uh
Duda playing at the combination of the
air potentially an 11 move Checkmate
against Gary something about Anish
giri's style encourages players to
attack him and they are often rewarded
if they're able to get this type of
position and look at it Lawrence you
predicted the future wow incredible move
there E5 throwing all the pawns away how
many pawns is black down I'm doing a
quick count he's down three pawns he's
giving away a fourth Pawn with E5 and
he's just he's just tunnel vision right
now going for this white king I love
that variation you just showed with uh
breaking through with the Black Brook
from B4 there was also some nice Queen
sacrifices in that variation with Queen
G4 and that uh in that line but oh wow
right now
how does how does white even try to
defend every single black piece is
coming for that white king hunting it
down
I think from unless you're going to oh
sorry Lawrence no I was gonna say I
think from a practical perspective
you've got no chance here it's scary uh
simply you're six minutes down on the
clock whatever way you take on E5 here
you know if you take with the D Pawn for
example and try it this way now black
just takes on F4 probably with this Rook
something like this even this position
to defend with your king where it is
this is mate Bishop takes E5 and the
dark squares are all loose I just don't
see
uh sort of a legitimate
defense defensive try here as as white
in in a in a rapid setting right if you
gave anushkiri two hours in this
position he might be able to find
something but in a rapid setting I just
don't see it happening
yeah two minutes left and uh maybe in
that variation Queenie one was the only
defense sliding the White Queen across
uh in that variation after Rook tease at
Florence uh but as you say there's uh
there's all sorts of sacrifices uh in
the air and unless you're gonna Channel
your inner Magnus castle and start
walking your king up the board hoping
that you can survive then
um yeah disaster might ensue and I just
see the evaluation bar drop what could
the winning idea be I mean there's so
many tempting moves for black I don't
see it yet Queen G3 will block some
checks uh if necessary
oh there must be a knockout blue
I mean maybe just giving a check from
what about here's one for you that's
gonna make you rock your stocks Queen G5
check Queen G3
whoa what a movie
um it felt like there was something and
I think you found it Lawrence uh just to
show the idea to the viewers if the
White Queen or one of the pieces takes
the black queen then Rook F1 leads to
mate
literally giving away half your army if
you take on F3 Queen takes E3 is just
lights out disaster I can battle on a
few moves but it won't help uh beautiful
this is in the air and we have just seen
Gary snatch a fourth one yeah four pawns
are punish giri but the king is in
trouble
well he had to he had to uh to to to to
do something I mean he he had to take
the pawn but
huge huge trouble
for Anish giri
looks as though Vladimir fell to save as
well is in big trouble remember how we
were looking at this game a bit earlier
with the Rook on B1 and I said that
white was able or should be able to
develop a very serious initiative here
well that initiative looks fantastic
Knight E4 and the bar has gone insane
for white here can you just kick this
Knight away with F3 and say so what
because if Knight C3 Rook B3 and you
lose a piece and if you have to go back
you've wasted two whole Tempe I don't
get it what what am I missing here
David why can't I just kick that night
away
that's a very good question Lawrence I
guess F3 does slightly weaken the white
king and does black have a
counter-attack somehow there I'm
struggling to see it
um after F3 maybe Black's idea is to
take on E5 uh I'm just trying to get rid
of one night and then to jump in if you
take with a bishop now then the other
Black Knight can jump in it does get a
bit chaotic uh after takes E5 Knight C4
Knight takes E3 is uh coming I still I
mean I still believe in White's chances
those two Bishops are so strong Black's
King is a huge Target but
okay we've seen a different movement
after d takes E4 Lawrence Rook takes B6
is that a move
oh he takes B6 white can play Knight C4
with a double attack hitting the queen
hitting the bishop
and sure he's gonna see that Fabi
that how can I even survive
and the point is that after Rook takes
B6 Bishop takes C5 very importantly
you've got this Vision so group B3 this
move again
uh important uh way to hold on to the
rook and now you just end up a piece up
and he has played it he has played Rook
takes B6
that is going to end proceedings here
because the two pieces are way too
strong for the single Rook here that is
going to just end the game no way for it
to save holds because for example after
takes Knight C4 let's say the queen goes
to A6 you take on D6 with the Knight The
Rook moves you can even now flick in the
move H6 weakening all of those dark
squares creating that dark Square color
complex around the black king and you
can never survive positions here after
G6 you can even for example play G5 if
you want to you're going to play Bishop
E5 check Knight takes ec4 Knight F6 and
you just never ever survive these
positions as black so this is just
winning for Fabi
incredible I mean he's a classy man a
classy player and he spotted his
opportunity despite a bit of a slower
start he's really rising up the table
now and yeah I mean it's not a surprise
in a way you mentioned it earlier it was
so risky Black's approach uh my first
ever chess coach or one of my first
coaches used to say when the queen is so
far divorced from her King here Black's
Queen is so far away from the black king
you can never really defend that's why
fabi's attack is so dangerous as you
mentioned in that variation if white
pushes the pawn to H6 Black's King is
all alone bereft of Defenders and uh
it's not just that but of course you're
losing material as well FedEx could try
to seek some consolation in an end game
by playing Queen D3 here but even then
even if the Queens come off
um yeah white is still material up
there's two pieces far superior to the
black Rooks the black d-pawn will just
be rounded up as you're showing their
Lawrence as well
um FedEx he's got to choose between all
of these horrible variations and he
keeps the Queens on with Queen A8 but
we're just heading down a similar
variation to the one you showed that
black Bishop is just going to be gobbled
up and that will spell the beginning of
the end what a tactic uh by Fabiano we
joined it at the right moment drama
everywhere in this ninth round uh sorry
in this tenth round it's just uh yeah
all of the players now especially those
more experienced players really set in
control and uh maybe we can check back
in uh on this one later is I'm assuming
now Fabian is going to take this one
quite smoothly to Victory
yeah absolutely
um I I do want to go over to the women's
section because I'm I'm noticing out the
girl on my wall first of all we have to
take a look at board one tanjongi
against
an ending here where
uh my first instinct is that white
should be doing
quite well but at the same time I can
also see some danger here for white
um
for example if black plays a move like
Knight to E7 and now you're a bit clumsy
with white let's say you play King E3
can black play oh sorry I'm blundering a
pawn here on on F7 you can't play E5 so
this is is not
I don't know the pawns control a lot of
squares but black is very solid
yeah in that variation Lawrence uh after
King E3 black can play such a move such
as F6 just containing the position next
move like you said E5 no matter what I
can put a Pawn on B6 uh all of White's
pawns are gonna be fixed on light
squares and that's normally not a good
sign it means we'll get a good knight
versus bad Bishop scenario and that's
definitely not what time uh tanzongi
wants
it will be very one-sided black tonight
has the flexibility to maneuver around
on both sides of the board start
attacking those uh Pawn weaknesses I do
feel the tanzongi wants to play E5 check
no matter what to put some pawns on dark
squares that's normally what you want to
aim for in an end game putting pawns on
the opposite color complex to your uh to
your Bishops so for example in this
position she would most likely play E5
and E5 here
has just played that move kicking the
black king back to a worse square but
also uh just preventing that dark
squared blockade and then the white king
will start re-routing uh maybe over
towards the queen side somewhere it's
just a question of whether blacks
tonight can get active if it can't then
white is in no trouble I don't think you
can break through with white no no uh
potential creation of past pawns anymore
after blocking things up in the center
but
at least you're out of danger for
tanzong you so I don't know about you
Lawrence prediction wise I would say
this one is going to take a Karma turn
most likely a drop but uh yeah some life
left
think it's almost certainly going to be
a draw
um I will say on board too Abdul Malik
uh playing against Savita you know
Savita has been a kind of breakout star
you know we see them every year uh you
know an exceptional performance by an
underdog Savita so far as being that
just you know not a woman Grandmaster uh
just a uh you know she's rated 24 11
though so she's clearly a very serious
player this is a position she has a
concerned side up to Manic and I have to
say this looks very dangerous for Jan
sire does it not in this position here
yeah yeah you're right Lawrence if we
compare the Kings both Kings look
slightly open slightly vulnerable but
it's about how many pieces can and can
attack the opponent's king and here
Savita as black has lined up a lot of
ammunition against that White Knight on
C3 that Knight is pinned uh that Knight
is pinned in two different directions
even and on the dark squares I don't
really see any kind of safe haven for
the white king long term black could
stop pushing pawns I would be very
tempted to start trying to get the black
queen into the game as well somehow I'm
looking at this kind of A1 to h8
diagonal somehow if black can arrange
getting the queen there it's pretty much
game over but we do remember we have to
remember that white is a pawn up so if
white can get the Queens off for example
some uh semblance of safety there I do
love visually Black's position but clock
times against Savita under one minute
and uh you know material wise she still
has to see seek compensation somehow she
plays Rook F7 not a defensive move I
think she wants to swing that Rook
across to the C file very sneaky stuff a
very creative way to double up the Rooks
I like it I've got to say but it does
give white a move to try and get out of
uh out of Dodge with her Queen the White
Queen on D2 has to move sooner rather
than later it's just feeling too
uncomfortable eyed up by Black's Bishop
I think all three results are still
possible of course Abdul Malik roared on
by her home crowd uh Savita 15 years old
extremely talented and finding all these
creative ideas she did it on the first
two days as well Rook F7 very subtle
looking
uh looking very complex in that one and
meanwhile I think we've jumped back to
the Carolina game Carolina is just a
night up there and about to wrap it up
but uh Lawrence a niche against duboff
yeah yeah well let's go back because we
saw this incredible concept of E5 Queen
H4 check and Rook F4 we had all of this
in our analysis and is his King under
huge uh assault Bishop takes there for
Queen takes F4 and then she had played
Queen if I've checked and queen E4 very
logical trying to get the Queens off uh
Daniel said no thanks Queen G5 checking
F2 and now Rook F4 kicking the queen
queen H4 check now the King has to go
walkies and after Rook f8 we reach the
following position here now the bar
again is not going nuts for uh Daniel
duboff here meaning that you know
perhaps there is uh you know some way to
hold this position but again how do you
hold this position practical context
because if you play King D2 you run into
rook d8 and you lose the queen quite
simply and I just don't see how a human
player ever holds this bishop H6 is a
massive threat threatening to win the
queen
he went for Queen to C5
which
gets out of those threats
but I don't know David i i
how do you
how do you survive here
um
um I don't think you do Lawrence in
human terms it's as you say it's
practical uh play that's what dubov is
so good at also look at the clocks Anish
made that move with less than 10 seconds
left he does have this 10 second
increment but when your opponent is
throwing all these traps at you these
tricks these attacks
um it's just impossible to defend with
10 20 seconds dubov still with a healthy
two minutes on his clock I'm looking at
a bunch of checks here Bishop H6 is one
possible check Queen F4 check I believe
has just been played by dubov if the
king runs to the queen side if the king
steps across to D3 then it's gonna get
hit by all sorts of pieces The Rook
Bishops
um yeah Bishop F5 looks like a killer
Rook d8 just as you say everything here
seems to be working in Black's favor he
drops back instead and now is dubov
considering taking this Pawn on E5 with
his Bishop
um I'm not I'm so sure where the
knockout blow is but that looks very
tempting to me
I think it absolutely he's going to take
this Pawn on E5 with the bishop I think
that's his idea
um the bar the the engine hates it
yeah
it's uh I mean it's one of those
positions the margins are so fine uh if
you just make one slip then you could go
from completely winning to completely
losing and do both uh okay having
sacrificed all this material he finds a
different series of checks Lawrence
let's go back to the game uh he checks I
think from the G5 square and this looks
very very powerful I think he's found
the winning Motif the winning idea
because now again if White's King
crosses over to the D file it's going to
get uh whoa it's going to get attacked
he does do this Anish giri but the idea
was if the king had stepped back to F2
the difference this time was that Queen
G2 would have uh would have been the
killer forcing White's King Ford yet
again
yeah Bishop page six and uh I think
Bishop F5 here
yeah everything is just falling for
white at some point now Rook d8 oh yeah
it was rooked yeah it was actually
dropped there
yeah sorry go on that sorry no you're
right and now this King has has gone
walkies but
it's still it feels losing but you have
to find the win here is black right it's
not it's not just playing itself this
position you have to find some kind of
precise way now that way
I don't know
it's like a game of hide and seek
White's King is trying to run and hide
and it's just getting chased
relentlessly by Black's pieces I mean
there's so many tempting moves Bishop E6
check that's light Square Bishop can
come and rejoin the attack that's Queen
has a bunch of checks that's dark Square
Bishop can just drop back and attack
White Queen I mean
Maybe
Queen D2 looks like a move to me just
coming in behind you threatened this
this suddenly becomes uh an idea because
there's some Bishop f8 it's that looks
like the natural a natural move to me if
you don't play a check
and he goes Bush B6 check okay
and he drops his picture back to f8 I
like this okay one the one pip the one
Pitfall I was going to say is that dubov
has too many tempting moves and he's
under a minute now uh the problem is
when you have six or seven very strong
moves as black sometimes you get a bit
carried away you get a bit confused
and uh okay he gives another check Gary
he has to pick his poison here is he
gonna drop back to A4 I think he
actually once it rejoins the attack
yeah it's gonna be game over though a
move such as Queen E7 now wow or
something along these lines looks like
it pretty much ends all resistance you
just need the queen that's the final
ingredient to the attack
um all of Black's pieces yeah they're
just perfectly placed and he does play
Queen E7 threatening mate in one Queen
A3 uh that Queen along the diagonal okay
that's blocked by Gary
pushes a pawn to control some squares
I mean very least you can start cashing
in now
there we go Gary's gonna have to give up
his Queen just to survive and at the
very end there's a nasty check we'll see
this happen on the board there's going
to be a double attack uh there we go
dubov hits the white king hits the white
Bishop
material up now and an ongoing attack
Lawrence
we saw a handshake duboff beats Gary
yeah beautiful beautiful game by Daniel
Duke of one of my favorites so far of
the tournament I have to say for the
ones I've seen this concept of going F4
and E5 quickly go back there for you
guys to see it was this position here in
the opening where Gary had snatched a
Pawn on C6 it was already what was it
two pawns up here so Daniel had already
given two pawns but look at the white
king and look at the activity of the
entire black Army and then the amplifier
Lawrence F4 I'm sorry to interrupt we'll
go back through this one later but
Magnus uh Carlson against Vincent kaimer
uh this one is changing and huge
developments looks like Magnus is on the
brink of Victory
um it was very balanced for a long time
but as we predicted earlier white was
the one in the driver's seat and look at
the Black Brook now it's just passive
any king of porno game is winning for
white white is two pawns up temporarily
uh despite the like a six Pawn dropping
the white king is now coming
Magnus working his endgame magic again
we'll go through this one a bit more in
detail maybe later just to show how he
works this magic but Unstoppable now
King E5 King E6 King E7 white king just
advances
and uh it's inevitable now black is
totally stuck we see the handshake
Vincent climber put up a fight but
couldn't stamp the tide Carlson takes
another win
maybe extending his lead Lawrence
no this is a massive massive win for
Magnus uh because Fabiano did beat
Federal save we looked at that game a
little earlier uh Fabi doing Magnus a
favor there taking uh one of the closest
Rivals out of the picture and after
setsorov did not beat you yangy that was
a draw so Magnus now a full point clear
uh with three rounds to go that is a
massive margin at this late stage dubov
Abdul saturov and karawana all on seven
and a half points uh will we see Carlson
caruana next I think we will won't we I
mean that feels like the pairing that
has to be made is Fabi gonna play
spoiler somebody has to beat Magnus else
he's just gonna do what he does and run
away with this whole thing yet again
um but yeah this this was a clinic by
Magnus wasn't it uh we can have a look
at what went on perhaps a bit later when
the rest of the critical games have
finished I would say let's go to Arjun
erigasi against artemiev uh because this
is also a critical game both of these
guys on six and a half if there's a if
there's a winner in this game they join
that uh important pack on seven and a
half uh so Rook C7 check King D6 but is
this just a draw David
or yeah what am I looking at here
yeah it feels like this position should
be a draw with best play of course but
it feels like white has the better side
of a draw
um this is another carlson-esque
position I'm sure he'd find a way to uh
get some type of uh pressure on the
black position here the reason I prefer
white is because the white Rook is
simply more active than its counterpart
the black Rook sitting on a very
defensive post right now black has a lot
of weaknesses uh White could Target the
black G6 Pawn but white can Target the
B5 Pawn the black d-pawn also isolated
that being said everything protects each
other at the moment for black and Eric
icy does have one move to create counter
player and he starts with Rook to F6
hitting White's weakness the only real
weakness in the position the F two pawn
and I think in order to have any hope of
winning this game I'll tell me if we'll
have to take some risks White NOW
pushing pawns forward horns don't move
backwards so now the white G3 Pawn long
term Target and every guys he's happy to
lose a move happy to go back with the
Rook where it came from because now he
will try to go active himself on the
open e-file to me it feels like it
shouldn't be enough as you say Lawrence
this should be a draw but it is rapid
chess and it's all about ease of
position as Pizza Man 69 says that in
the future chat
yeah how do you make progress that's the
big question I'll tell you is trying now
to push forward with F5 he's trying to
isolate some of black spawns But Eric
icy is calm Defender and he chooses to
activate his King
promise if the more pawns you exchange
the closer we do get to that desired
draw and actually a draw doesn't really
favor either of these two in the
standings but I think Eric I see would
be the happier of the two in terms of
position
and um yeah very tense stuff these two
rapid specialists facing off against
each other
yeah I don't see anything but a drawer
actually here to be honest uh I think
it's just too too dry
uh you you know the Rook on E6
uh defends the the only weakness but he
goes for it with F5 he does go for it I
like this try though by artimia because
he wants to create a weakness on H5
after G6 or five Rook takes so five
and the question here is do you now go
Rook cheese sick for Rook G6 Rook G5
does that
exist
yeah that's an important question to ask
I think you can bully your opponent with
the idea of uh king of porno games which
all will favor white uh because white
has the outside past pawns Rook g64 G5
on the board
so now Eric AC has got to make the
unpleasant decision of does he take this
or does he move the Rook because he
doesn't want to go passive but at the
same time what else are you supposed to
do because this King and pawn ending
looks totally over King D6 King B4 King
E6 G6 King F6 I take take but you've got
to do some counting you're like oh
it's actually quite different
yeah yeah yeah there's so much at stake
in this game even if the uh even if this
game does send in a draw that means so
much money at stake on the line and he's
gone for the same game Lawrence
yeah we have to count now I mean how did
he make this decision with no time on
his clock uh we might even see a pawn
race King important uh Queen and
Portland game if some of the pawns
promotes
uh what are you doing here if you are or
tell me if you're just counting you're
calculating right
yeah I mean you can just play I mean you
have to take you have to go King C5 so
you're gonna get a bunch of time on the
clock here both players should have
close to a minute after this uh but King
C5 King G5 King B5 King G4 King A4 King
G3 before we might get one of those
weird endings where yeah exactly they're
both gonna run their pawns up the board
black Queen's first
but it's off Timmy of who's gonna have
the extra Pawn right
and yeah white promotes with check
remember and uh all of these ones before
so they are easier to calculate as you
say the players have built up a bit of
clock in the bank now a bit of Club a
bit of time in the bank and uh yeah like
promotes first the a pawn though is
notoriously difficult to win with uh the
apron never provides White's King with
any shelter from checks so this should
still be a draw but we've got to tighten
our seat belts here because we're in for
a long one I'll tell me it's going to
try and grind this game out if he can
what do you think chances of winning
this Lawrence against a great end game
player like Eric icy
I think his chances are actually not
that bad
because
you know it's they're playing on
increment
uh it's difficult to play accurately in
the defending side of
Queen endings
so it wouldn't surprise me at all to see
how Timmy have win this I would expect
that he wins this in the region of 25 of
the time even with the airport if it was
a B Pawn I would expect it to be more
like 50 percent
um yeah Queen D6 played
protecting the pawn on A3 allowing the
white king to actually
get free
again it should be a draw but you know
it should
should be a draw you just have to be
slightly careful where you put the black
queen where you put the black king you
don't want to allow any uh kind of
blocks which force the queen exchangers
if like for example were to play Queen
E4 here Whitewood block with Queen B4
and win the game so Eric I see he's just
trying to gain a bit of time deliver
some checks and uh counter-intuitively
uh the one thing I learned about these
end games is you should always as a
Defender put your king at the opposite
corner from uh your opponent's promotion
Square so for example your max King
should actually be hiding out on H1 or
around the vicinity there H1 G1 because
then when you deliver checks later as
black you will never get hit by a
counter check and um yeah this one
should still be a draw but you have to
be very accurate as you mentioned
Lawrence I don't like the fact that
black is placed his Queen in the corner
Queens want to be in the center of the
board but uh it's not too late the black
king as soon as it runs and hides out
there on a safe square like H1 G1 there
are always stalemate ideas as well if
your king is in the corner I've seen
Magnus Carlson use that to brilliant
effect in the wild rapid Blitz Blitz
championships before putting the king in
the corner just to defend to hold these
end games so now a huge threat for
example Queen B4 is a threat to get
those Queens off the board and uh like I
see here needs to guard against that I
would already start running I would
start going King H3 King G2 putting the
king in the corner he continues
insisting with the checks though maybe
he's singing to oh tell me if you can't
run away from the checks already maybe
it's already a draw if black finds the
accurate squares for his Queen
yeah so much at stake could be this game
yeah but it's gonna be yeah this is yeah
this this is a massive massive game for
the tournament as you said David because
if our Timmy does manage to find a way
to win
uh he joins that elusive group on seven
and a half
and he could be the one to take down
Magnus Scott and I actually think that
artemiev is one of those slightly more
Awkward opponents for Magnus
historically uh our Timmy of style is
really difficult to pinpoint he's he's
an offbeat player he's unusual
uncompromising calculates well he can
blow up against Magnus I've seen games
where he you know Magnus is one
impossible positions against Artemis but
if he's really on his game and really
concentrating
a composed Magnuson problems so I
actually want to see an Artemis of
Victory nothing against Eric Arjun I
like Arjun very much I think Arjun is
brilliant but um
Lawrence this game is going to go for on
for a long time again I see so we'll
check back in a bit later maybe we uh
can see what's happening with Mama jarov
against siddipoff a uh Blitz and Rapid
specialist from Russia mamajarov here we
see him with the white pieces it's a
crazy position I'm trying to do a quick
material account white has a queen for
blacks rook and Knight but look at that
massive pieces black has in the center
and the black king as well not entirely
safe on the edge of the board mama jorov
needs to win we're down on board 21 here
but one win two wins it will Propel you
forward uh into the top places so
um again so much at stake and remember
prices all the way down to 35th place in
the open section so these players are
playing for their livelihood especially
for a player like cedipoff a huge
opportunity for him and a manager gives
another check black king is hiding out
who would you take here Lawrence I guess
you would take the queen but it's not
simple right I mean it's the white king
I don't even know if I would take the
queen what an interesting position I
this is just a completely unusual
position I've never seen anything like
this queen A7 okay but doesn't feel like
Mama job is making too much progress
here
um and we have just seen a handshake is
that because the position has repeated
itself three times I think siddapov
called The Arbiter there he claimed a
draw by repetition and the players
aren't writing down their moves so you
do need to check these things but
managerov said no we don't even need to
check and he does acquiesce to the draw
and sorry I was mistaken this isn't ball
21 this was board nine so uh they are
already very high up in the standings uh
this is already a key match but manjarov
couldn't make any inroads he had to bail
out with the draw and he looks
disappointed right as he walks away yeah
right rightly so uh uh you know he he
does look disappointed uh you've got
white against a player you're 200 points
higher you you should try and win
but and Lawrence yes Haru Nakamura also
still going uh trying to get that win
he's been struggling so far hikara too
many draws in the tournament shaking his
head there and uh again doesn't look too
promising necessarily for Hikaru he is I
think a pawn down
you know as white so fighting for his
life Hikaru Nakamura he's got to be
itching to get into the blitz portion
now uh he I think in the rapid section
his chances of getting a medal are tiny
he needs to win all of his games but
this one
isn't looking promising and uh the clock
situation though is very tense both
sides under 30 seconds anything could
still happen uh hikara's opponent is the
very strong Serbian Grandmaster
Alexander in ditch I think it's
pronounced and uh yeah he's uh very well
known for taking scalps for surprising
strong players well it's Bishop
meanwhile supporting a pawn but black
has got it well blockaded this white a
pawn is going nowhere
yeah and a lot of Hikaru fans are going
to be asking what is what has happened
why why hasn't Hikaru managed to to
really get into gear
um well it's a it it's a tough
tournament you're playing against really
decent players every single round and
Hikaru has drawn five in a row it's
something you almost never see at rapid
and Blitz events
um and to be you know currently if he
loses is he's three points behind Magnus
he's pretty much out of the running
anyway the question is is he going to be
able to sort of
manufacturer run to to something like a
metal but in this position he's just not
he's a pawn down
um black has got many good ways to
improve bringing the king to E4 and then
to D3 and then perhaps to then start
running this Pawn down the board I isn't
isn't Hikaru just a lot worse here
um yeah I do I don't see I don't see any
bullish argument for your car review
whatsoever
yeah I agree completely Lawrence Hikaru
is fighting for the draw in this game
and
um yeah it's been a tough tournament but
this does happen sometimes you're facing
up against world-class Grandmasters
every single round and uh remember
hikara has been so successful so good
recently that everyone's scared of him
so players are often uh just trying to
neutralize him forcing these draws
especially when hikara has been black
he's been unable to uh kind of break
their defenses and I think that's led to
frustration and um yeah he's too good to
be kept down for long uh he will be back
of course in the blitz he's definitely
one of the favorites there but uh this
game Black's maneuvering around with the
Knights not really making too much
progress but as you say Lawrence at some
point eventually like tonight will find
a better circuit a better square that
Black Sea Pawn will start pushing
and uh Hikaru just has to fight against
those ideas
um I do think he's the favorite Droid
I've seen hikara save plenty of
positions like this one especially when
both sides are low on the clock he's
very good at reading the opponents
sensing what they're going to do kind of
forcing mistakes but
yeah it's hard to imagine black going
too wrong the Knight is coming around to
D4 now really really nice Square
uh yeah I mean Hikaru what can we say as
Hungary Zorro saying clap for inject
because he's playing really well in this
game and sometimes that just happens as
well all of your opponents play well
against you in one tournament there's
nothing to be done
you need a bit of luck your Corey just
hasn't had that luck this tournament
uh frustrating time for him for his fans
I wanted to see him as well take on
Magnus that would have been a Monster
Match
I think we'll see it
I think we'll see it I think we will
yeah I think look Hikaru in Blitz is
just such a monster over the board as
well not just online and I think there's
just no doubt that in the in the blitz
tournament we see that pairing it's it
has to happen
um so but this game uh I think I'm not
sure he holds here David I mean I really
love how injured is playing he's trying
to get some more pawns on the go some
more past Pawns
I don't really see why he should be
saving this
uh then again Black's Rook is very
passive right now white a pawn is a real
thorn in the side uh Knights are
notoriously bad at stopping these Corner
pawns the a h pawns and white apron will
tie down one piece so I trust in Hikaru
I've seen him uh wriggle his way out of
tougher situations as I mentioned but uh
yeah I do think injection has found a
nice way to try and press for a win at
least that's been the theme of the day
or in the Carlson game in the Geary game
and now it's all about those active
Kings Black's King on e4 looks glorious
but hikaru's last move Rook H7
takes a bit of time will he win the H5
Pawn uh I still don't think that will
lead to any winning chances for white
but if you win support and back maybe
indrich will get a bit nervous
still Anything Could Happen yeah
yeah I I don't see a way to actually
hold this Pawn
yeah maybe black hasn't no I don't see
either maybe black has to commit to
going on an attack against the white
king there we go the black king seizes
what we call the opposition uh if the
black can join the action now there are
some checkmating ideas I don't see how
that will happen though I think hikara
will happily just trade off a set of
Pawns grab that black H Pawn White
thrick temporarily offside but I don't
think it's such a big deal in this exact
scenario there we go we see Hikaru
confidently grabbing the pawn back level
material for the first time since we
joined this game a small crowd there as
well we do see some Grand Masters like
Ahmed adeli watching this game curious
about whether Hikaru can work his
endgame Magic
Let's uh what is ninja doing here the
Knight is journeying its way around to
attack the white Bishop
if Hikaru wants a draw now he can simply
snap off those two remaining black Pawns
I think you can even give up your Bishop
get rid of those two black pawns rook
and Knight versus Rook a simple draw the
Hikaru can uh can make in his sleep and
look at that smiling Hikaru expressive
as always
uh he's yeah he's not been happy with
his performance in this game but he
knows it will fizzle out towards a draw
now
we are in the closing stages I don't
think injection will try too hard if it
does get Rook uh it does get to that
Rook uh a night versus Rook end game
okay Hikaru moves his Bishop though
not going surprise
yeah
very surprising does black have a chance
now with the past C Pawn most likely
it's still a draw I don't think you can
trap the white king your one move away
from doing that uh in various variations
but
not quite in time
it looks like a draw nonetheless okay
injection does threaten the white Bishop
but now Bishop takes C5 what is the idea
three
possibly wow he plays it yes there's a
Checkmate threat on the board Rook F1
would be Checkmate but white can defend
Rook H1 suddenly wait to pawn up
Lawrence yes the white apron win the
game
well Rook F5
hitting the bishop
and if Bishop B6
what does he want to do here
is kind of bluffing here
yeah I have a funny feeling I mean
Nakamura was one Pawn down for pretty
much nothing just 10 moves ago then it
was equal now he's a pawn up yes the
white king is under some uh in some
danger but if he can neutralize the
check mating ideas why it's a pawn could
decide this game
injection really has to pull the reverse
uh reverse gear here he has to pull the
brakes before it's too late well but
night before night before I like a lot
because now Knight D3 check and Rook B1
is a is a massive threat and you're
going to block the check with with this
so is he gonna play King D1 here
yeah he's running away Nakamura and
rightly so that white king needs to
escape its jail there on C1
yeah maybe we voted off too soon
Nakamura he took a risk he uh didn't
want to force a draw immediately and
will this pay off King D1 King E2 one
more move and I think white has pretty
serious winning chances if he gets his
King off the back rank
injection
there we go 12 seconds for him his clock
ticking down
what's he gonna do I would be getting
very nervous okay Knight C6 he wants to
eliminate that white a pawn maybe that
was the key maybe that was a very clever
way um to
just guide the game to safety that's
King going back but you can see the
nerves on injitch uh he's knocking over
pieces almost with his uh moving
gestures there
are coming forward and the pawn drops
but the black king is going to be miles
away
still this must be a draw Lawrence
brilliant game by both players as
mentioned in the future of the chat
there and okay I think finally we will
be able to uh at least calm ourselves
because Knight C4 should spell the end
of either side's winning chances rookie
three check is threatened Hikaru knows
he can't really keep the material on the
board
the white king is going to get checked
by that black knight soon
wow some long games and it's just the
first round of the day
yeah super super exciting stuff Hikaru
just not able Rook H5
and last night's coming now 1992 check
and King F2
King C4 Ah that's clever because the G
Pawn is not uh what you can take it if
but if you lose a piece after Knight E4
black uh and he does take it okay M
rotation five and we're going to get a
draw
yeah we'll see that handshake any moment
now yeah
and there they go King versus King yeah
fitting way to end the game and it's
nice to see the players chat afterwards
Gary watching uh enjoying that in game
yeah frustration continues for Hikaru
too many draws but uh yeah he is still
in with a Chance of those prizes and
remember he is one of the favorites for
the blitz tomorrow Lawrence
all right there you go what a first
round uh just uh action everywhere but
it's Magnus Carlsen creating some
separation from himself in the rest of
the field a full point clear with three
rounds to go we're gonna be back in just
a minute with the next round uh we'll
have the pairings and of course a
summary of all the ongoings from this
very exciting uh first round of today
uh we're going to expect much more when
we come back in just a few minutes don't
go anywhere
life is full of exciting events but it
is our first impressions that we
remember best your first diploma
[Applause]
your first job in a big company
Unforgettable emotions from the first
date the first expensive things you
bought when you got your first paycheck
and your first Investments with freedom
broker Freedom broker look at your
favorite brands from A New Perspective
now you can use gifts from the biggest
chest stars on all your favorite
platforms
just search chess.com and your favorite
chess star on Discord Twitter WhatsApp
and more to find hundreds of gifts from
chess.com's biggest broadcast and events
nepo Donya Bobby Anna's and even me
Danny try it today
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
World rapid chess championships taking
place in alamati Kazakhstan you can see
on your screen there is still a game
going on in a critical game at that the
game are Timmy of against irrigation our
team of managing to push this a pawn all
the way down the board might now be
winning for white I mentioned to my
lovely co-host David that I thought
defending this in a rapid uh time
control is extremely tough the bar seems
to love it for white and it is critical
because Magnus Carlson has increased his
lead in the tournament a whole point
clear if artemiev manages to win this
game he joins the pack of players
chasing Magnus on seven and a half David
this looks
uh well uh this just looks toast does it
not for for black I don't see how you
ever really stop this porn queening do
you
uh well I must admit Lawrence I'm less
optimistic about White's chances and
well until this last move I think you
called it okay commentators cursed out I
was about to say if you put your King on
the right Square in the corner as black
you still have some chances to give some
checks but suddenly the game ends
abruptly if black now gives a check for
example from F4 there would be a counter
check when kings are on a block here by
white when kings are on the same
diagonal this often happens white forces
the Queen's off makes a new queen of his
own and we would have seen that pawn
promotes either way so you were right
Lawrence there I'll tell me if takes the
win
real disappointment though for everybody
who should have drawn that one a lot
earlier going into this difficult Queen
end game and getting ground down that's
potentially decisive now as you said
artemiev will have a shot at uh making
his dent in the top few places he's
gonna have a huge pairing in the next
round what a marathon that was though 75
minutes of play in just one rapid game
their nerves will be jangling and uh
it's nice to see them though at the end
of that long round still have a smile
have a laugh and analyze the game a
little bit but that does draw to an end
sir bring to an end a very very dramatic
and bloodthirsty round lots of decisive
games on the top boards Lawrence
yeah tons of decisive games on the on
the top boards uh Magnus Carlsen beating
Vincent Kmart we're going to have a look
at that game in just a second massive
win for Fabiano caruana keeps his hopes
alive uh beats feder save with the white
pieces I'm just a tour of not able to
win draws against you Yang Yi uh but he
also is on seven and a half as is
artemiev and dubov after that brilliant
uh win against Anish giri so they're in
now four players on seven and a half out
of ten Magnus Carlson on eight on a half
out of ten and it's just a question of
are one of these guys going to be able
to create a complete chaos by defeating
Magnus if Magnus does lose a game uh
suddenly the tournament is blown wide
open uh in the women's section should be
noted that there is a pile up on the top
tanjong Yi Alexandra hampi
Abdul Malik and Dinara sadrachova all on
seven out of nine not to mention a whole
bunch of players on six and a half out
of nine that is as tight as it gets note
there two Local Heroes jeans Abdu Malik
and Dinara sarva kasovu currently uh in
the lead there so the the lot of
attention for the local attention will
be there we of course will be keeping a
keen eye on that
they have only got
two more rounds left today so the
likelihood of a tie break uh playoff uh
in in the in the women's section is
extremely high very unlikely there's
massive separation in the open well it's
all about Magnus Carlson let's talk a
bit more about what he just did to
minson came and this is a classic Magnus
display David take us through this game
and your impressions of it
yeah maybe we can catch up with uh
roughly the moment we left the game a
bit earlier we did see the Catalan
opening uh we saw an early Queen
exchange after some uh small tactics
here and there and I mean the critical
moment for me was already or at least
one of the key moments uh to magnus's
victory was putting the King on E3
really nice end game strategy there
using all of White's pieces extra space
in the center blacks Bishops not really
making a great impression
um so we left the game slightly after
this one a bit earlier but it was
intriguing to see how Magnus pressed the
advantage the evaluation bar saying it
was level but White's position was
definitely easier to play by far much
more fun having white here and B4 a
really instructive move not giving
ground not retreating not stepping back
with the Knight allowing an exchange
allowing the white Pawn structure to be
compromised as we saw in the game but
white doubled a pawns actually clamped
down on the queen side and now is the
moment the Magna stepped forward in the
center he wasn't rushing but whole idea
was to push even further in a moment and
now E5 another key move just making
Black's Bishop bad clamping down on
pawns black is just completely lacking
Pawn breaks like pieces very very
passive and uh this is another another
concept good night versus bad Bishop we
mentioned it earlier white tonight very
flexible to dance around on the dark
squares Black's Bishop just a terrible
piece locked in behind its own Central
pawns and Magnus broke through on the C
file and uh just on top the pressure
here
creating a square now for his King
really instructive Lawrence to take away
from the center
exactly this is a key move here to you
take C5 uh trying to get hold of this D4
Square which can be used by the king or
the Knight
um Magnus keeps the Rooks on as well not
fearful about black advancing the pawn
because it can become a weakness and now
another lovely little move the smooth A6
trying to soften up this C6 Square for
the Knight
um and rugby five using the pin and the
Knight finally jumps in and when he does
that of course the problem you've got
now is back is that your pawns are
loose everywhere I guess the move King
E7
uh would be met just by maybe King D3
just looking to round up this Pawn
Rook before next and so on
which is why Vincent tried to get active
but uh now Rook D6 comes and this is the
problem for Vincent is that he's not
able to get in the move Rook C2 check
so Rook D6 takes takes King D7 and The
Rook gets acted by Magnus lovely move
this as well look at five and D7
excellent little uh in between move
there also by Magnus because now he's
able to give check and finally black is
not able to survive the trade of Rooks
of course if you take this ball white
just takes on D3 and the these endings
are obviously losing for black with the
extra Pawn for white so King B5 King E3
and the King just marches up the board
they'll March all the way to E7 and that
will be all she wrote
yeah game Lawrence yeah it's brutal
stuff as you say but it looks so elegant
it looks so simple Madness didn't really
play any difficult moves he didn't play
any flashy moves but it shows he's in
the flow because that was good enough
just step by step slowly improving his
Pawn structure slowly improving his
pieces at the end one or two little
tactics as you mentioned pushing the
pawn forward to D7 for example finding
the right moment to trade the Knight for
the bishop but those types of things
arise from the really clear middle game
strategy that he had so
um yeah Magnus keeping it simple when he
needed to but that was mightily
effective I've got to say it's very very
impressive what he's doing and it's
going to be hard to see anyone stopping
him now Magnus says he said one point
clear and even a string of drawers these
last three rounds should still make him
the favorite to take the crown
uh meanwhile you have another game up
Lawrence
yeah absolutely yeah Napoleon she
defeated Evgeni Thomas
not quite in the mix he's on seven out
of ten a point and a half I think he's
just a bit too far at this stage but can
certainly compete for one of those top
prizes or a medal uh he played
tomashevsky the game was a Berlin very
well known sort of solid system uh White
gain some space king H1
okay and Knight G1
uh White
signals is intentions that he wants to
break with the move F4 and he does that
when he develops his Knight to E2
and he gets this position here which uh
you know if you look at this position at
opposite color Bishops you've ironed out
Black's pawns but that little bit of
initiative that you have along the file
in with your piece play gives you
something to claw onto here as white
takes takes Queen F3 which should be six
still looks like black should be solid
here
but um yeah after E5 it really doesn't
feel like Jana's got too much has to be
said D4
G5 well
I'm not sure how
necessary
this move is because your moving points
in front of your king you're weakening
your king
okay Jan brings his
H4 by yarn upon a sheep that's a classy
little move actually that's the move
that tomashevsky missed it's a bit of a
disguise move the point is that after G6
H3 you have to worry about some Bishop
G5 moves and you might just lose an
exchange and if you don't do anything as
as tomashevsky did in the game suddenly
the G5 Square becomes available for your
bishop and you can start weakening the
dark squares around the king here this
H4 move was really critical in this game
E6 gorgeous Queen sacrifice tactic
missed by Thomas chefsky
um and the point is that after Queen's
HD3 you can play e takes F7 check King
H7 and just
take the rub
uh you make a queen there is no uh no
Checkmate and after Rook ht5 Rook f8
call as a cucumber by yeah naponishi
point is this is just one check King
goes to G1 the queen does an amazing job
of protecting both rook and Pawn
and that's all she wrote Rook h8 is
coming next with the end of the game
yeah some beautiful tactics there
Lawrence E6 especially dagger through
the heart for tomashevsky and that
really does show the power of opposite
color Bishops that's one thing that I've
noticed Club Players tournament Players
they really underestimate opposite color
Bishops when there are Queens Rooks
heavy pieces on the board
um they simply give extra momentum to
the attacking player and uh it's all
about breaking through all about trying
to crash through on that complex that uh
you you have with the bishop and there
we saw naponishi already whip up a big
attack but finish it off in style and as
you said maybe not uh within grasp
Within Reach of Magnus there for first
place but in the premiere we see in the
standings he's in ninth he could still
get a medal some huge financial prizes
as well and more importantly this is
going to be a huge confidence boost for
him in the run-up to the classical World
Championship uh in early 2023 so
napoleonishi looking good and here
talking of the standings we do see the
top 10 in the open section Magnus now
stretching his lead on eight and a half
out of ten a huge score only dropping
three draws seven wins so far from
Carlson he is chased however as you
mentioned earlier by Daniel dubov
nordebec Abdul satorov ladislav atamev
and now Fabiano caruana and we're all
Keen to see that match up I think
Lawrence Carolina against Carlson uh a
rematch of the 2018 World Championship
Match was very very close uh I guess
you're good friends with both of them if
that does happen uh who would you take
as the favorite
tough one to say
um I think
if Magnus gets white
um
it's gonna be tougher Fabby but because
Magnus is a high rated seed he might get
black so Fabi with white the fact that
Fabia has put together a nice little run
serious Chances with the white pieces
serious serious chances I think it's
going to be critical that Fabiana gets
white if they do indeed play
and someone needs to stop that Rampage
by Magnus as was mentioned there in the
feature chat we do see the rest of the
top 20. there's a big gap though between
uh our generic icy down to mamajarov and
uh and first place Magnus is now two
points above this group so this group
now are purely fighting for those uh
Financial prizes still a lot at stake of
course we see some big names Anish Geary
for Ashok mama jarov still no sign of
Nakamura remember he has been bogged
down in all of those drawers uh
meanwhile let's go to the women's
section where it's also dramatic uh only
two rounds now remaining in the women's
tournament potential playoffs I think
very likely we will have playoffs now
for the title because there are five
players in joint first tanzong Yi and
goliachikina did uh battle it out to
that draw that we saw earlier humpy
canero and those two home favorites you
mentioned Lawrence zansaya Abdul Malik
and now dinares cassava another very
very strong Kazakhstan player a local
favorite she's very experienced as well
and she's worked her way up she's now on
a bit of a streak of Victories so those
two do you feel that Home Advantage
plays a factor uh will it play a factor
today Lawrence as we maybe see the round
10 match-ups
um
difficult difficult to say I don't think
so
I think they're just very good players
very experienced I think actually I'm
not sure there is a Home Advantage I
think there's a home disadvantage a lot
of the time spoken to Magnus about this
I've spoken to other top players where
play in your home country brings a lot
of extra pressure Kazakhstan doesn't get
major events all the time so this is a
big deal that they have this tournament
in uh in Kazakhstan and given that
especially jansaya with her chess
Academy and her political career uh a
lot of eyes are going to be on her and
I'm not sure that the extra pressure is
actually something that they Thrive off
of but then again each to their own some
players do some players don't I don't
know the particular circumstances for
these two players whether they enjoy
that I would say in my experience the
majority of players that have to play at
home tend not to like playing at home
and feel like the extra pressure is a
burden but we'll see because jansaya
she's got a really tough pairing here
black against Alexandre castinio who's
still in it uh you know a win here for
Alexandra kostenyuk puts her right in
the mix
um
yeah it's impossible to to even you know
you know it's impossible to say who's
who's Big favorite here because on board
one canara tanjonggi such a solid match
up there sidewalk us over is no slouch
with the white pieces so this is a
really really tough one to call
yeah it's five joint leaders and four
players just half a point back from them
so unless we see one player go two out
of two in the final two rounds from that
leading group I think we almost
guaranteed playoffs and uh that would be
a fitting way to end this because it has
been so close all the time uh ever since
maybe good Nina broke out in the first
four rounds uh after that we've seen the
pack emerge and
um yeah those top players
just not showing any weakness not
backing down at all and we do see the
playing Hall here this fantastic playing
haul which has uh hosted almost 300
players for the last few days we do see
a lot of movement there but we are
waiting for the players to sit down to
arrive to get ready for that final round
which will start in a few minutes
Lawrence
it will and we're gonna go for a quick
break before we uh come back uh to the
next round critical round in many
aspects uh don't go anywhere we're back
in just a few minutes for continued
coverage of this fee day world rapid
championships here on chess.com see you
soon
life is full of exciting events but it
is our first impressions that we
remember best your first diploma
your first job in a big company
Unforgettable emotions from the first
date the first expensive things you
bought when you got your first paycheck
and your first Investments with freedom
broker Freedom broker look at your
favorite brands from A New Perspective
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
World rapid chess championships it's
round 11 of 13 in the open section and
the penultimate round in the women's
section and on strength here with David
Hal and on screen you can see a key
matchup in this 11th round it is Daniel
dubov playing White against Fabiano
caruana no Carlson Carolina Clash just
yet it's the task of vladislive artemiev
to take down Magnus Carlson if this
tournament is going to get interesting
with a few rounds to go we've seen some
brilliant chests from both Daniel and
Fabiano in the first round of today both
in a rich vein of form
stringing a whole bunch of wins together
of course the big question is with
artemiev playing Carlson is it going to
be vladislav
Russian uh well very very unorthodox uh
super interesting uh Grandmaster is he
going to be the one to topple Magnus who
has just been Waltzing through this
field so far
um if Carlson wins this game it is all
she wrote for the tournament uh there's
just no way he's going to get caught and
as Anonymous nihilus says in the Super
Chat artemia has a good record against
Magnus yes he does
yes he does so it's going to be very
interesting it's going to be these two
key matches that
we're going to keep an eye on but we
can't rule out
the reigning rapid world champion Nordic
abdicator of also on seven and a half
points he plays Black against vidit so
we'll keep an eye on that one for sure
David uh should be an absolutely
Exquisite round it's going to be full of
ups and downs
uh yeah
I think there's uh there's gonna be a
lot of risk taking as well in this round
as the players do fight for those uh
huge prizes at stake still the title at
stake remember and uh we will start with
this Clash on board to Daniel dubov with
the white pieces against Fabiano caruana
as you mentioned dubov he's already
checkmated a few people this tournament
uh beating Gary in the last round
Fabiano is on a four-game winning streak
so uh could one of these two play
spoiler could Carolina continue that
streak win this game and get a shot at
Magnus in the penultimate round well
we'll be looking for those answers as uh
this game enters the Well Middle game
phase we do reach towards the end of the
opening now as Fabiano Retreats this
bishop not a move I'm that familiar with
I must say this is duboff's pet line do
both beat Magnus Carlson several times
actually on the meltwater Champions
chess tour last year from this opening
with this variation with white knight on
D2 he loves to fiancato both of his
Bishops very classical stuff later the
center tends to open up as we'll see in
a moment Kara one are now challenging
and it will also depend on karawana's
strategy how much risk does he want to
take does he just try to settle down as
black just try to get a balanced
position
it's very difficult against dubov to
kind of pick a strategy because he can
do everything and
he's so determined uh to come at you at
any given opportunity so this Clash I
think is going to be fascinating we will
of course give you all updates as uh the
Artemis against Carlson match progresses
meanwhile an exchange of Pawns white
dark Square Bishop now finding a nice
diagonal and uh black with maybe the
slightly better Pawn structure but white
with a clamp and very very active pieces
Lawrence a bit of a kind of slower start
to this one maybe as the players kind of
get over their nerves try to work out a
match strategy on the Fly uh what do you
think to the start of this game
yeah absolutely I mean but this is
typical Daniel style I would say more
than Fabiano Daniel has been playing
these kind of uh systems for for a very
long time and he's got quite a unique
feel about how to play these even here
after the move Queen C2 you know does
this create an immediate threat for
example let's say black plays A4 can you
think about Knight G5 and all of a
sudden is white winning because all
Bishop takes G2 you might have this
Vision Sook Bishop takes F6 and all of a
sudden you're threatening mate I don't
know it's this kind of thing that Daniel
is you know he's got so many different
ideas wouldn't surprise me in this
position just to see Fabiano play H6 and
say I don't want any any of this
nonsense
um
we'll see but I I I'm not
massively in love with the opening for
Fabi
um
I think you've got some practical issues
to solve here that said if Fabi is one
of the best practical and kind of
concrete players in the world he can
calculate uh better than anybody and he
does go H6 which which just does not
surprise me whatsoever
um Knight G5 is still player yes
I was just going to point that out
Lawrence uh yeah off the table just yet
Knight G5
um it is a double attack after all um
maybe we can show this on the board some
ideas of yes Bishop takes B7 uh as well
as these Queen H7 mate ideas so assuming
black captures on G2 the the big
difference here is that after Bishop
takes G2 Bishop takes F6 but doesn't
have to spend a move guarding against
Queen H7 you can take on G5 right after
a bishop exchange uh lots of pieces get
traded off but I don't think this is too
bad for black after Knight C6 uh Black's
Pawn structure there was actually uh
very flexible uh black had double G
pawns but those were actually quite well
placed so we didn't see any immediate
fireworks from dubov watch out as he
builds up for those tricks first he
improves the rook and Fabi has to
develop
do you bring out the knights to C6 for
example what do you do with black
Central Pawns
this position is very easy for white to
play you just kind of pile up in the
center often you see white later double
up Rooks on the D file against that
Central Pawn as black you could push
your D Pawn one square just solid like a
Hedgehog's type structure you could push
it two squares and go for a hanging Pawn
type of structure as they say and uh
that maybe is more committal or you just
leave the point where it is and try to
play with pieces but uh for black
certainly um as you mentioned it's not
100 clear which side of the board you
should be playing on whether it's the
center the queen side and I wouldn't be
surprised if Daniel does at some point
start pushing forward for example why
it's e-pawn could already pick herself
up uh go to E4
and we could see the attack begin a lot
of do Bob fans I'm seeing here in the
feature chat but uh Fabi yeah also a
very popular player and rightly so he's
just a great Ambassador for chess and uh
I just I'm itching to see him get a shot
at Magnus uh in this rapid tournament so
I'm expecting the move E4 I don't really
see
uh dubov hanging around maneuvering for
too much longer I think it's very much
in his style to be direct here uh it's
not just E4 gaming space in the center
because E4 in itself is actually a move
you don't really want to play you leave
some weak squares but uh it's more about
pushing that pawn to E5 as quickly as
possible and A3
I said I didn't see him waiting around
but A3 looks like a very loose move long
term now the white B3 Pawn
isn't going to be well defended and I
guess the only uh kind of positive to
this move is that Black's Knight can no
longer jump to attack the White Queen
but I've got to say I don't like that
one from duboff he played it very
quickly but uh maybe he's just trying to
kind of keep Fabby guessing on every
turn he's trying to keep his options
open and only later pounce with E4 I'm
sure Fabi is waiting for the moment when
dubov's gonna come at him and uh yeah
very restrained from dubov giving Fabi
the time as well to get his Queen off
the background connect the black Rooks
uh kg started this game I've got to say
and uh we will see those fireworks
happen later but not right now
um I really don't like that E3 move I've
got to say Lawrence I think a bit too
slow
yeah maybe a bit too commensal because
long term you give yourself this
backwards Pawn on B3 which could be a
Target so you weaken the structure
permanently
that said uh I don't think dubov is
thinking too much about endings at this
point
um I think he wants to try and get his
creative juices flowing the question is
how I I mean for example in this
position here you know he's guarded B4 I
think it's now time to call it D4 think
here the most prudent move is just to
play E3 uh just you know make sure that
there are no night jumps but no we now
see the real creative juices of Daniel
Duke of in full flow Knight to B1
this move is gonna suggest this yeah
yeah it's this movie is sorry yeah I was
gonna say this move is uh we we we we
see it in a bunch of openings with it's
been known as an idea for over 100 years
now
um the Knight reroutes itself back to
its optimal Square on C3 uh from which
of course now that there's a hole on B5
the Knight can jump in also makes it
more difficult for black to break in the
center for P5 because those hanging
pawns can be quite tender so it's up to
Fabi now to to find some uh
some kind of plan because he's close to
completing development so the question
is
how
how best to continue
here not completely not straightforward
to me
yeah and uh yeah it's not
straightforward at all Fabi has various
Maneuvers at his disposal okay he drops
the queen back I guess just preempting
any night jump to B5 he doesn't want to
allow that move with gain of tempo if
the white knight does jump forward to B5
now maybe then Fabi will take the
opportunity to start pushing forward
with the black Central pawns but
meanwhile Lawrence maybe we can take a
look at our board one Clash which is
just as fascinating just as important as
uhmf aims to take down Magnus Carlson
and it did actually begin as a BOGO
Indian just like we saw in the uh
caruana game as well but this is a
different branch of that opening and to
me it looks like black is solved most of
its opening problems he's traded off a
bunch of uh well a set of Bishops first
of all he's traded off a bunch of Pawns
and it's completely symmetrical the pawn
structure
that does not bode well for our Terminus
winning chances
especially since Black's light sky
Bishop which is the problem child in
these openings it has found a square on
D7 next move from Knight C6 is almost
automatically automatic you can pretty
much pre-move that move uh that night
jump and if Knight C6 happens Lawrence
I've seen this opening before I've seen
countless draws in this type of position
I don't really see what white can do how
can white make use of the tempo for
example Rook fd1 improving The Rook
Magnus wall pre-move Knight C6 getting
the night out the black Brooks come to
the center and equality I think Magnus
is happy for the draw here he's uh
banking on the fact that uh that would
be a decent result guide him slightly
closer to the Finishing Line uh I'll
tell me ever meanwhile didn't choose
Rook fd1 he simply retreated his Bishop
to E2 uh let's check that out what's the
idea there after Bush B2 Knight C6
again
I think he wants to pose to Bishop on F3
but doesn't really feel like too much
for example again after she said
bringing the Rooks to the center Rook
after d8 I don't see any major problems
here for Magnus I think he'll be over
the moon at the outcome of this opening
no major difficulties to deal with can
place sensibly and as you said uh a draw
here for Magnus is a really good I mean
a draw here for Magnus is a result he
will take because then he knows he's
going to be at least half a point clear
with the penultimate round having the
white pieces in the penultimate round
and he'll know that you know draw now
and a win with white in the next round
gives him the championship
so it's uh
it's a great situation for Magnus that's
for sure
yeah also check out the clock times
Lawrence I'll tell me I've spent a
bundle of time he's spent almost half
his time getting to this point and we're
only at move what 12 13.
um Magnus has barely paused For Thought
barely spent a second pre-moving as I
said Knight C6
um you play that against any move just
swapping off pieces your slightly
cramped as black trade off that strong
White Knight in the center and I've got
to say I'm slightly disappointed by
Artemis opening uh like you said he's
very unorthodox but he's normally very
very ambitious he takes huge risks in
the opening especially with white to
provoke the opponent to set the opponent
new challenges every turn that's what
guided him to Joint second place uh in
the world rapping Championship so far
but again is it the Magnus effect in
play players are a bit scared Magnus is
in top form and they're just not playing
their usual style against him they're
adapting they're playing on his
territory on his comfort zone
um as you mentioned Bishop F3 has been
played Magnus can choose Rook ac-8 here
Rook 58 one of the two black Rooks is
going to enter those open files and
problem solved I don't think you need to
calculate too much here as Magnus how
about Lawrence if Magnus draws his final
three games say this is a draw and uh
yes he gets his final three it would
require someone else of the chasing pack
to score two and a half out of their
final three just to catch him do you
think that's realistic is that what
Magnus is calculating in his head right
now
I don't think he's thinking too far
ahead like that I think I think Max I
mean I think
I think he realizes that a draw now is
just a massively good result for him so
that's what he's going to focus on just
making a draw now
and then see what happens later or at
least well yeah at least not losing now
of course if he manages to win this
position which looks you know even for
Magnus winning such a dry position looks
very very tough
um but if he manages to win I think
he'll be feeling very confident and
he'll be very happy with the draw and
you know he's got his position and I
will say
there has been a result
of very well disappointing result from a
viewer's perspective on board to dubov
caruana has actually ended in a draw
which is
I mean I'm disappointed by that there
are tons of pieces left on the board yes
the position might objectively be equal
but maybe these guys are thinking okay
Magnus has really just got a lock on
this event and uh there they are vying
for the big cash prizes in second third
fourth and so on
still
don't love it David don't love it at all
yeah um I'm disappointed as uh as you
are Lawrence I wanted to see drama I
wanted to see these two players going at
each other and it is very imbalanced the
position with that handshake with that
draw uh agreement they've basically
waved goodbye to any chance of the gold
medal uh dubov and Carolina
um this position that we see in front of
us it looks like dubov played the last
move he captured on D5 and duboff was
the one to offer the draw maybe that's
because he doesn't like his position
um after black recaptures on D5 I'm
assuming with the pawn he takes D5 black
has a nice Pawn Center black has great
potential with his pieces so I I kind of
understand dubov's uh thoughts but I
mean for Fabi to accept the draw yes a
draw with black is a decent result
against someone as strong as duboff but
you've got to play the tournament as
well as the board uh position and uh
dubov clearly didn't like his position
why else would he offer the draw and uh
therefore maybe playing on that uh yeah
I've got to say disappointed
and uh Magnus looking around look at
check him out on the camera he's looking
around he checked out he'd seen that
board two result now he was looking over
at board three he knows that a draw for
him Magnus will
I don't want to say clinch it but uh
will guide him very very close now to
that Finishing Line and um yeah in well
in terms of position as well Magnus he's
going to be over the moon he's going to
be ecstatic with how this round's
developed
he knows that if he gets to uh
the uh an ultimate round with a point
advantage two draws
is at least enough to take it to tie
breaks uh but he could theoretically
even win with just one draw
you know somebody has to get two out of
two in the final two games in order to
even overtake him so the flexibility of
his situation is just so much greater if
he manages to go a point clear with two
rounds to go
um
yeah a final note on that topic Lawrence
I've got to say I'm the biggest fan of
dubov and I love Carolina's play I love
both of them as chess players but the
chess gods do have a habit of punishing
players who take quick draws uh often
you lose your momentum Fabby was on a
four-game winning streak and he killed
his own Streak by agreeing to that draw
so
um yeah I'm slightly afraid that they
might punish for that in the next round
but meanwhile let's go back to uh maybe
the game we have on camera have there
been any developments at all uh Lawrence
this one's still looking very balanced
I'll tell me against Carson
yeah let's have a look I mean it's it's
not the most exciting match we've
commented on
so far
small tactics we should mention yeah
after Rook at the eight
so Bishop takes B7 not really available
black has moved such as Bishop C6 maybe
bishop B5 yeah Bishop C6 the double
attack and black wins material
yeah I've got to say I'm trying to get
excited about a position that doesn't
really deserve it Quincy for uh just
Rook ac-8 here looks very healthy
challenge
yeah white will put the queen on B3 now
I'm pretty sure and here I guess you can
do lots of things but surely just Bishop
C6 is
easy equality Bishop takes C6 Rook takes
c66
Pawn structures identical pieces are
identical there's there's just not much
to write home about here at all he goes
Queen E2 same thing applies I think
Magnus just I think you just always play
Bishop C6 here I don't see why you
wouldn't play that move
Magnus looking very comfortable if you
look at his body language
um you know obviously doesn't feel
uh uh in any danger at all because he's
not and yeah artemia down to four
minutes by the way I will point that out
I'll tell you down to four minutes
yeah and uh I don't think that will be
decisive it is such a balanced position
Magnus does Play Bishop C6 he's going
for the draw and I think we need uh some
respite from this uh this dull position
we need some excitement so maybe look
Lawrence we can check out the game of
mvl
um some dramatic stuff there uh really
crazy game with White's king
um very open
this is uh not the position we're seeing
in front of us right now
this is slightly further down the table
but here we go look at that white king I
mean this is the antidote to that
casting game where at least now we can
analyze some variations we can look for
some check mating patterns and well
surely there's a breakthrough for black
here it feels so scary for white but
maybe black doesn't have enough pieces
black has sacrificed a bishop two pawns
or just for one point sorry and uh
do you see anything here does black have
more than just a repetition of moves
like G4 check yeah I don't I don't see a
knockout blow here for mvl let's just
quickly have a look though at what
happens again here and around here
material is equal it was in this moment
move 23 where and we all played this
fantastic idea Bishop plays history I
mean he was kind of lining it up for a
while it seems giving up the uh Bishop
in order to launch him with the Knight
but fair play to ingitch he's found a
way to defend King H2 H5 the Knight
comes back to C3 and as the bar also
indicates I don't see a winning
concept here for black
um
it's close but
I don't see it and NBL one of the best
calculators chess has really ever seen
uh you know he's already spent a fair
amount of time on this move and I can
tell you if there was already Checkmate
he would have played it so Emil also
understanding that there is no
mate here
uh as the as the chemist said in the
featured chat just a moment ago it's
amazing the evaluation Bar says it's
equal here but that just indicates most
likely with best play NVR has to take a
repetition that could for example begin
with uh Knight F3 check okay he plays
Knight G4 instead and uh I'm assuming
that white takes that
oh it does feel very very dangerous but
I'm assuming white takes this Knight and
at some point black will play Knight F3
uh Knight back to H4 and uh we'll just
see a bit of a dance I don't think black
can check mate with just two attacking
pieces maybe King back to G1 is able as
well mvl hasn't had the best tournament
but injitch yeah he drew with Nakamura
as we saw in the previous round now most
likely saving the game as well against
Bashir the graph
to good results maybe we could just play
one variation uh King H1 was played
interesting looking H1 interesting
putting the king there very giving
allowing Knight to accept to check
very very provocative
maybe we wrote this one off
yeah I mean Knight F3 is the most
natural move what yeah has white God is
still actually Knight F3 comes with a
threat right uh sorry not Knight takes
F2 Lawrence Knight F3 setting this up
yeah and now Knight takes F2 is the
killer threat oh for example white does
nothing if white plays a foot Yeah Bang
and
yeah queen and I do turn out to be
enough the ideal attacking combo
yeah I didn't I didn't like this
decision by engine
after saying not a huge fan of this
whatsoever
yeah and like you said earlier mvl he's
so good at calculating these things he
plays Knight F3 after not that much
thoughts suddenly white has no defense I
think White's just put his King on a
very poor square and uh Queen G2 oh wow
I think we've always picked up his Queen
it doesn't stop the threat and we're
going to see a Checkmate in which
resigns
wow
wow
what a difference
goodness me just goes to show 2600 Grand
Masters
also have to work on their tactics when
I talk to my students I say tactics
every day minimum half an hour it's that
sort of shot that you can fall for
doesn't matter if you're 1500 or 2600
it can still happen
brutal finished there by NBL by the way
out in the corner of my eyes I'm
watching the games and I will say that a
relatively important game actually a
very important game is that of
uh Vincent Kamer who is crushing Jan
upanishi with the white pieces here if
we look at the position Vincent is
already in exchange up so something has
gone horribly wrong for Yan but now all
you have to do is play very logically
take on C5 to open up this diagonal for
the bishop and now you can just even
just protect this Pawn with Rook F2 E1
follow up with root takes C5 this
position is abysmal for Yan Napoli if
you play root takes E3 you can just take
on C5 now
because the queen protects the Rook
this function is not very wrong
yeah this just looks awful
last move Lawrence can I ask why black
didn't take on E3 black went back with
his Rook
I mean I'm struggling to understand uh
neponishi just giving up the exchange I
checked out this game a few moments ago
and I thought black was doing fine but
um yeah I mean I was maybe thinking
taking on E3 with the Rook but I guess
it doesn't change anything white is
after all the exchange up white is going
to take on C5
White's King Super safe Vincent about to
bounce back immediately after that
defeat uh by Carlson in the last round
I said Napoleon she he was on fire he
was uh picking up confidence ahead of
his world championship match but this
does not look like it's gone well and uh
maybe a case of playing a bit too
quickly black had a promising attack
earlier now white is super safe he plays
the variation you mentioned Lawrence
Rook fe1 keeping everything protected
and there's hanging pawns that we
mentioned on D5 and C5 that could have
Arisen in the duboff against carowana
game they're on the board here but those
pawns are
fatally weak and yeah I think we'll see
a result very shortly in this one no
chance really from Napoleon sheet to
create any counter play at all
blacks King yeah cut across on the dark
squares meanwhile
can we maybe check in on the Carlson
game wow it looks like Magnus has just
made a big mistake has Magnus Carlson
blundered and wow wow look at the camera
wow
Goodness Me
he's
shaking his head he cannot believe it
simple move F4 he's disgusted with
himself he cannot believe it I said
altimia could be a potential banana skin
for Magnus Carlson and Magnus now
the poker face is gone and Magnus losing
abuse because after F4 he's attacking
the Queen the only way you hold on to
the Knight is with Queen F5 and now G4
and simply the the Knight is gone and
Magnus is going to be playing on Raw
emotion now he plays Rook takes C3 and a
takes B3 and we have an end game where
well artemium is just an exchange up and
with the fragility of the queen side
pawns this is just not even close Rook
D7 and just like that the tournament
could be blown wide open Magnus Carlson
so rarely do you see him falter at the
last stage he Rai smile there by Magnus
okay he's gonna play on a little bit
here
um he's gonna but there is real no setup
I would say to hold everything just Rook
B7 here Rook A7 I think either either
move is good
so rare to see Magnus make this kind of
London
it's just a knight if black had a
another set of Rooks on the board maybe
some chance of holding uh Black's Knight
is glorious after all but it's the queen
Side Pawn Center you can't save them as
you mentioned Lawrence and look at
Magnus now he's distraught he's so angry
at himself but he had 12 minutes when he
made that blunder I'll tell me about one
minute Magnus had 12 against one I think
he relaxed too soon and let's go back
let's have an action replay of that
moment when he blundered uh let's check
out the move at fault it was here look
how balanced it is completely
symmetrical Pawn structure black if
anyone has the upper hand Black's Queen
very nicely placed in the center but
Knight E4
want to move putting a piece on a loose
square and F4
alternative seizing his opportunity
pouncing that's all you can do at the
top level uh you can't always Crush
everyone you have to just wait for the
mistakes and uh G4 as we mentioned led
to this end game and we do see the
handshake Magnus didn't fight on much
longer he did resign after his pawns
dropped and while suddenly I'll tell me
jumps up into the lead with Magnus
anything can happen now Magnus
he's blown at he's blown his lead can he
recover from this setback that's the
question now
while Lawrence nobody could have called
this right nobody could have expected
this
certainly not like that
uh after that opening I Magnus got his
dream position uh dream missile game
everything going smoothly Doom of
drawing on board two a draw is is good
enough and then just an oversight even
the world champion can blunder peace
tactics to move peace tactic two move
tactics it's uh it's astonishing it's
great for us because we now have an
incredibly exciting two more rounds
where
you know if Abdul saturov wins he even
joins the league I think we should
actually have a look at that game
uh that game actually looks quite peace
and in fact it looks as though vid it
might even have a serious Advantage
there but at the very least we're gonna
have
you know artimia and Carlson on eight
and a half and at the very least we can
have dubov caruana
one other on eight and maybe maybe more
for example
he's going to be on eight we already
know Vincent Kmart he's going to be on
eight and all of a sudden it's all the
hard work that has to be done again by
Magnus Carlson
um he'll be just gutted he's had a
Flawless tournament David so far he's
not been in any danger 10 Rounds
cruising through
but
it's chess
and that's nature of the Beast
exactly that's top top level chest for
you very rare to see any outright
blunders but when they do happen they
can change whole tournaments and we do
see in front of us this game this clash
between vidit and Abdul sotorov Vida is
on a bit of a hot streak um he's racked
up quite a few victories he was not
doing too well at the start of the
tournament I think he's won three of his
last four games for it and uh yeah he's
putting some pressure on as you say
Lawrence uh this Black Knight now going
back to E6 should sure up Black's
defenses it's level pawns level material
but the reason I think I prefer White's
position and uh you mentioned that you
slightly prefer white too it's because
black does have the only isolated Pawn
in the position it is the black A5 Pawn
it's not easy to attack but there are
possibilities for white to create a pass
Pawn on that Queen side a bit later
um that flank is worth it it should be
concentrating his uh Focus it's not
going to be easy for example to activate
the white king to get that get that
black knight black Rook their great
defensive squares but if anyone's having
the fun it is vidit and in terms of the
standings he really needs to take this
point or he will really want to take
this point at least he's on seven a win
would get him half a point behind the
lead Abdul satoroff
win isn't necessarily essential but uh
he will be within vicinity of the top
places if he can avoid defeat in this
one Knight G4 white wants to bring the
Knight back to E3 to attack like Central
Pawn I don't think it's too scary like
can uh sure up uh just protect that pawn
uh if he wants to with a move like C6 as
you highlight there and uh still roughly
in the balance but in a central game for
the standings with so much uh riding on
this one now
and uh maybe some other games we can see
well I I wanted to just check in with
the with the women's section as well
because we are at a critical stage there
in our in round 10.
um I want to go to the top wall because
it's getting very exciting should be
pointed out that kristenia against Abu
Malik was already a draw so uh jansaya
uh currently on seven and a half but of
course she will be joined by at least a
few other players this is a position I'm
picking or a tanjong Ki who do we like
here why does it pawn up but black is
very very active and the F21 is hanging
and look at the clocks it's 45 seconds
against four minutes and hampi canaro
very strong player very experienced
player she's been at the top of women's
chess for a long long time but recently
some of her results have been affected a
bit by time pressure I remember in the
candidates say a peace blunder which is
due to time pressure and and this
position it does look a bit scary for
white you are a pawn up any end games
for white will be advantageous because
you have the bishop versus Knights Queen
side majority but it's tactics like you
say Lawrence it's very specific ideas if
you take on B2 the safe approach or do
you take on F2 Knight takes F2 is
available it looks a bit risky exactly
into a pin but uh you're also going for
checkmate and I'm trying to do some
quick calculation here I don't really
see immediately what white should be
doing in reply
um you can't attack this knight any
further
um you can't really profit from the pin
White's Queen needs to fight a safe
square if you go to the wrong Square for
example
um let's say oh B1 okay b1's a terrible
square but uh then Knight H3 check could
be an idea in some variations
and uh after there's a capture Queen G5
check oh right yeah we need five
25 maybe even stronger uh Quincy five
check Rook takes B7 was my idea yeah I'm
trying to lovely Checkmate on the G2
Square
and yeah this one looks over so there's
certainly ideas against that white king
tanzongi does she go for it now great
tactician could be a turning point
um as super edg3 says it's going to
consume all her time because it is a
critical moment the top players know
when to spend their time I think if she
takes on F2 she has great chances but
she doesn't go for this or at least it
looks like she didn't from her hand
movement there it looks like she's
played a different move instead she
takes on B2 with her Queen
now the last king side is a is a bit
loose
can white profit from the F7 uh Square
being undefended now
maybe it's fine maybe it's still good
for black
the white F2 Pawn is also vulnerable the
white Bishop not ideally placed humpy
with 20 seconds
good move
Bishop B6 hitting this Knight and now
black doesn't quite have time
to stay in fact you could get a mass
liquidation here because Queen takes a
three for example and if white wants hum
uh humpy could just do something like
this and the game would end in a draw
very very quickly
that's also a truck yes yeah if black
gets ambitious over ambitious and takes
on F2 now with the Knight then white
simply steps back Queen F3 and
everything's covered the Black Knight is
hit and F7 uh White is checkmating so
yeah you're right Lawrence maybe now is
the moment to bail out for tanzongi to
go for that draw but
she'll be reluctant maybe she feels she
has chances I don't think you can take
too much risk now though it might
backfire
crucial moment let's wait to see what
this next move is
you think she'll take on A3
um
in the game position
probably
I think I think it's a it's a pretty uh
sort of uh logical move
up to the game yeah here we are basics
okay she's reaching out okay she changes
her mind
I think Queen takes A3 I'm I'm
struggling to see any other move for
black I've got to confess Lawrence I
don't think you can get away with
anything uh your knight is hanging don't
see any real safe squares no I think
you're too well centralized and and
sorry to interrupt but on board two
Dinara saroka server with a big chance
against Alexander goyaczkina his
position was under control for
koyatchkin and she had everything fine
but here white is just winning
this is incredible cam we just play the
move Knight E7 check David
the point being oh this is clever if
King h8 you've got the move Knight C6
no sorry that's not the move not is it
night
C8 maybe Knight C8
oh my goodness what a tactic
yeah hitting yeah
this looks fantastic for weight is she
gonna find it she's played Knight E7
check so crucial moment in this game as
well
I think Knight C6 is less accurate
because Queen E8 is not necessarily as
powerful a threat anymore after Knight
C6 maybe just Rook C7 for example and
black by the skin of her teeth will
cling on uh so Knight C8 is the key move
it could give Sato kasiva the lead in
the tournament and she plays it I think
wow the camera Knight C8 knockout blow
black can't save her Rook I think she
just has to take this Knight now give up
her Rook on A7 and try to defend that
miserable position or we saw a sudden
change of stance there from Guyana I
think she's realized what has just
happened and bold 42 saying is is saying
that a similar tactic was just missed in
the Hikaru game
pattern recognition guys and girls
that's that's the key here and Black's
weak back rank causes her to lose
material suddenly this is relatively
straightforward uh if White's Pawn the
C4 Pawn drops then black is back in the
game but black can't take that pawn on
C4 Lawrence because of the background
yet again and
one-way traffic now this is going to
spell the end surely white can just
March her Pawn forward uh let's see okay
Queen A4 threatening rookie eight really
nasty move uh black will try and set up
a blockade on the C5 square but you've
got to assume that sadhua cassava is
going to convert this Knight C8 great
move
great blow
and uh yeah and it's the same over this
is massive this is massive for the
tournament because if server casova does
convert this which of course she should
most of the time
uh
she jumps in the lead and could actually
be sole leader with one round to go the
local Superstar Dinara sadro kasova
could be causing upset of the tournament
by the way just in terms of of a pure
tournament upset beating boyajikina like
this and propelling yourself to be first
position
would be massive and all the support
behind her uh might might produce a
Kazakh uh world champion wouldn't they
love that
yeah uh Home Advantage maybe we'll have
to revise our opinions it does look like
it's inspiring her at least in this game
and uh meanwhile uh the humpy Canary
against Hanson you game still roughly in
the balance I slightly prefer humpy
Canary's uh chances there but okay that
one I think will fizzle out towards a
draw
um how about other games Lawrence maybe
in the open section do we switch back
there Queens come off in this game it
looks like cassava is about to win the
white king is going to March over to
that Queen side
um
foreign
I like what
uh norderbeck has done actually to get
this position he's kind of managed to
get some space sure he's still got some
fixed weaknesses this Pawn on A5 but
vidit's pieces aren't working amazingly
well and after Knight E3 a simple move
like Rook D7
uh I expect to be played
um I don't think you need to commit with
D4 because then you just give this C4
square away forever so Rook D7 is played
and there are lots of improving moves
here for black as well you can play G6
on the next move preventing any Knight
F5s
I do expect after of to hold this
position
I don't expect him to at least
I don't expect him to win it but you
know it's also the sort of position
where black has got the King on C6 if
you get overly ambitious here as white
suddenly black can get generate quite a
bit of uh initiative on the queen side
so I I have seen these positions won by
black Rook D1 I expect uh G6 to be
played here
uh by uh nodiobeck and Lord it's just
it's not just about the position itself
but it's the momentum and the last time
we were here we quite significantly
preferred white suddenly Max King is
active Black's Pawn structure has
improved Black's Justice activist
earlier white has literally done nothing
since we were last here five ten moves
ago uh Vivid just shuffling his pieces
back and forth and
um yeah Abdus is going to be smelling
blood in the water he has a Time
Advantage as well he's known to be super
quick super tricky and it's his type of
position vidit does not thrive in end
games in simplified positions that's one
thing I've learned from his uh from his
play he's a great tactician uh he's got
great understanding in general of
Dynamics but
um yeah it does feel like abdusatorov is
on the front foot slightly should be a
draw of course but uh all to play for in
this huge huge clash and uh I think
we're about to see a result as well in
uh the game that we left earlier uh
napoleonishi is
that's resigned um I don't think he has
any chance to save this game anymore
and uh yeah that's also going to be huge
meaning Vincent kymer is going to LEAP
up into that chasing pack just behind
Magnus Carlsen and vladislav artemiev
absolutely yeah this is getting more and
more interesting and yeah this one here
I don't think vidit is gonna try too
much
question is is a tour of quietly
optimistic here is he gonna try and
manufacture something here I personally
don't think you should but
can't fool the guy for trying
yeah you've got to take any chances to
come your way and he'll he'll press for
a while I think this game will go on uh
for a long time maybe we can check out
some of the other
um chasing pack to see whether anyone
else can leap up into contention uh
ahead of the penultimate round
um
maybe you Yang Yi against feathersev we
see those two also they're in the top 10
right now they could jump up to eight
points this one is a bit crazy
um weird material imbalance I've got to
say Rook uh against two pieces but
Black's King is very open as faramat
says in the future chat it's very close
now a win for either of these two a win
for a whole bunch of these players and
they're right back up there after Magnus
opened the door for them
King G1 will let us have bail out with a
draw a draw doesn't really suit either
of these two players uh black can give
checks with Queenie one Queen E5 no
retreating
what do you make of this how do you even
evaluate this one uh Lawrence
no idea
uh I would instinctively take black
because I mean I do have a Pawn on A3
and two pieces for a rook and if there's
no immediate mate then I prefer black
but I really couldn't say
um
you know objectively what is going on in
this position I I simply don't know
um
we'll see yeah yeah we'll see and
feather save does thrive in positions
with material imbalances so he is the
favorite oh especially after this last
move B4 now it's going to be extra hard
for white to get rid of those two black
Pawns it's just about whether black can
make progress Yang Yi in trouble
objectively
um which game should we go to now should
we stick here Lawrence is sir I think we
should okay just just just to confirm
DNR server episode did win her game in
the women's section she is sole leader
with one game left that's gonna be very
very exciting if she wins she wins the
tournament and I think cedrica Silva
um can
who who hasn't she played yet Lauren
yeah tell me you should mentioned after
that win has now won six on the bounce
six in a row and uh because she didn't
start too well she hasn't played too
many of the top seeds uh so we'll check
in on those pairings later but she's put
herself in Prime position
yeah she she employed The Accelerated
Swiss Gambit draw drew her first three
games
was on one and a half out of three and
has won seven in a row just unbelievable
stuff
all right
that's how you finish right
so that's what they're told
very impressive performance and uh
meanwhile a check here the white king
still surviving for now Black's Bishop
has snuck around to C4 Black's a pawn is
about to push will it cost white uh his
Rook you Angie coming back with the
queen I still believe that white has
some tricks up his sleeve because the
black king is so open but fedesaf really
closing the door here I think he might
well be about to jump up to eight points
right back in the mix
that's a classy move because you're
attacking the queen and the Rook
and yeah and the point is you can't even
go Queen Diego's after Bishop D5 you
threaten mate and the rook and there are
no checks it's not doing a glorious job
of holding everything together no I
believe that's all she wrote actually
Queen E4 is the final dagger in this
position
in the background of our picture there
we did see Napoli she just resigned
against Vincent kymer so that result
confirmed Vincent jumps up to eight
points there's gonna be a bunch of
players it's gonna be a traffic jam of
players up on eight points half a point
off the lead uh Lawrence what a
turnaround this round has been we
thought it was just kind of going to
inch towards the inevitable Carson
Victory and an inevitable gold medal
title but suddenly we'll have half a
dozen or more players capable uh of
winning this tournament and uh meanwhile
there are developments huge developments
in the game between vidit and and do
satorov I think we might have to jump
back there we're about to see FedEx win
that game but look at this white has a
past G Pawn
is this Pawn going to decide
has actually sort of yeah he's over
pressed or blundered or something
too many risks
wow and
suddenly white can just dropped back the
Knight to C4 as he has just done a visit
uh the white king is going to come at
some point that could be decisive
White's King is going to advance to help
that g Pawn Usher it forward and
remember Knights are terrible especially
against apons
I don't see Black's knight ever getting
active again that white a pawn is going
to completely paralyze one of those two
black pieces the king or Knight and uh
it's those trousers as we call them two
pawns on opposite flanks two past pawns
running up the board uh the A and G
Pawns in this case and
fit it wow this could be his fourth win
in five games
um putting on a streak I wrote him off I
said uh end games maybe not his strong
it's not his Forte compared to other
parts of his game but he's still
extremely strong of course uh in all
facets and uh suddenly that eight Pawn
is marching after satara fighting for
his life the evaluation about reacts
I think all he needs to do is add his
King into the equation
as soon as he advances the white king
there we go uh this should be it should
be cousin's back is paralyzed wow wow
wow wow wow
yeah this is just all she wrote
heartbreak for Abdul satorov
understanding that his tournament
is close to being dust
uh in terms of winning it and retaining
his title this was a must
at least he couldn't of course he
probably didn't expect Magnus to lose
but a loss ends it a draw kept him in it
and now he understands against somebody
as strong as with it Kenji 14 G6
nice technique the Knight is forced to
stay with the
a pawn you can waste Tempe the Rays of
an eyebrow there by abdresser turov okay
the Knight comes back to C6 now you can
just press A6 absolutely no reason why
you wouldn't push the a pawn here that
it does
yeah and these three
I was taught Lawrence when I was young
that if you're wondering how to evaluate
night end games you just imagine the
knights off the board and you ask
yourself what would happen if it was
just a pure King and porno game pure
King opponent game of course white is
winning that white apron would go
forward and promote and in reality the
two knights just cancel each other out
right White's night is stuck blocking
the black d-pawn blacks Knight to stop
blocking the white a pawn and therefore
white X report on the other flank the G
Pawn wins so I think that's just a good
way to evaluate night end games uh in
this case but it can just slowly uh head
with his King towards the queen side uh
there we go fit it great technique I
love that comment in the feature chat as
well by Japan night a few moments ago uh
everyone's talking about the young
Indian teenagers and it's the old man
vivit at Grand old age of what 27 who's
uh coming through uh yeah I mean
phenomenal player of course one of the
best opening theoreticians in the world
and I think he's going to get the win is
powerless now one final trick in the
position might be that but it can't
actually capture Black's Pawn whose
Knight before check would happen for
example after King G6 but I think he has
a plan here Lawrence if King G6 1955
check yeah
reflecting the weight of Black's Knight
and promoting the white a pawn okay the
black king goes back but
where's that King going
um this is the trick that vidit had set
up
and 95 anyway by vidit locking down the
Black Knight and we see a handshake that
it takes the win Abdul sotorov
shaking his head pressed too hard
yeah I'm just sort of pressing too hard
got it I'm just a tour of head in hands
devastating result for the young Uzbek
Superstar with that loss he is firmly
out of the running and all of a sudden
from nowhere
from absolutely nowhere vidit
who you know I had a very standard start
he was on Two and a Half out of three
then he drew against Shimano then he
lost with white against volodo merzin
putting him on three out of five he was
on three and a half out of six
then he put together a few wins four and
a half out of seven five out of eight
six out of nine and now seven out of ten
and now eight out of eleven he's won
three in a row if you would have said
vidit would be in with a gold medal
chance after six rounds I would have had
you
uh detained by the men in the white
coats
you he was on he was barely on a plus
score just goes to show once again
the power of momentum if you put
together three four wins in a row in
this tournament suddenly you're in the
mix vinit can actually win the whole
thing if and there are lots of
calculations we need to do but if vidit
plays Magnus and wins for example in the
next round he might even be out all on
his own all kinds of things can happen
uh wow what a route you know it's it's
really not disappointing
um and
it's it's
yeah it's now tough to cool
yeah I think we need a breather Lawrence
there's been so much uh to unpack from
this round so many turnarounds
um so many swings in the uh standing so
I think we'll take a break there and we
will be back in a few moments we'll
leave you with a view of the playing
haul and uh yeah we'll come back we'll
talk about the standings we'll go
through those big blunders those big
moments yet again but uh only one round
remaining remember in the women's
section and two rounds in the open
section all to play for we'll be back in
a few moments
life is full of exciting events but it
is our first impressions that we
remember best your first diploma
your first job in a big company
Unforgettable emotions from the first
date the first expensive things you
bought when you got your first paycheck
and your first Investments with freedom
broker Freedom broker look at your
favorite brands from A New Perspective
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
World rapid chess championships 2022
taking place in almati Kazakhstan It's
the final day in fact it's nearly the
final round well it is the final round
in the women's tournament in the open
section two more rounds to go we're
going to be covering of course all the
action that's going to be coming up in
just a jiffy before we go there
though a quick word uh if you have been
uh with jess.com for a long time or not
uh it doesn't matter because after a
long wait in fact I think it's been
around two years the pro chess league is
back the 2023 season begins with the
qualifying week starting February the
1st 16 teams advancing into the main
season
um and you know the protest League
something that I've commentated on a lot
I've never actually played it myself but
I can tell you all the best in the world
have participated for their local teams
including Magnus Carlson dingler and
napomnia Fabiano Hikaru mvl Anish and
the list goes on everybody's very
excited for the return of this league
and there's a hundred thousand dollars
in prize funds on the line so it's going
to be a serious event uh with some great
players make sure you use the code
exclamation mark PCL in the chat to
learn all about it
back to this tournament and well I can
tell you David we still have some games
in Play and on the screen now uh we see
uh well I can't make out who that is
do you know these players here
I think I'm real senseif is one of the
players
um with his back to us real Santa very
strong player well known as a coach of
the Russian teams of the Russian open
and women's teams
um I'll try and find out who he's
playing against as well this one looked
like a long grinder long end game where
Santa is playing against a grandmas from
Azerbaijan Bali uh with the white pieces
and wow it's over black blunders in a
drawn position and look at this Ria's
answer if he's calling the Arbiter he's
trying to ask about the 50 move rule
because oh wow he's forced to play one
more move if black plays one more move
the only legal move is to put your king
in the corner and you'll be checkmated
Rook takes Bishop you lose the game so
Riaz answer he's praying to the chess
Gods he's hoping that they've made 50
moves in this end game but I don't think
they have I think that uh White did win
the pawn more recently than 50 moves ago
and therefore white is going to win the
game game why not try something why not
test your luck but uh
yeah nowhere near nowhere near he's 20
moves 20 moves off so that that claim
will be refuted
and this this shows Lawrence that Rook
versus Bishop despite the fact it is a
draw and quite a straightforward draw uh
even the top players in the world can
lose it uh I think actually here real
Santa has the perfect defensive
formation uh he has his king
um actually maybe not the ideal perfect
defensive formation but he has his King
able to run but he somehow got it
trapped in the corner couldn't find a
way out and that's what happens in
wrapping and Blitz chess when the clock
ticks down the Mind goes out the window
and especially after a long long slog
after three days of play we saw it with
Magnus Carlson blunders do occur and uh
yeah it looks like this was one of the
final games of the 11th round
and uh meanwhile the two players wait
for the Arbiter to come back the
opportunity off to check on the
electronic boards on the electronic
score sheets
we're assuming it's going to be a white
wind
in this game when the Arbiter finally
does return
yeah
yeah go on David
I was going to say meanwhile maybe
Lawrence we can uh talk about the
standings and what's changed what we
have to look forward to in the final
moments uh the final rounds of the day
indeed well uh we can see the
leaderboard there Magnus Carlsen now
caught firmly by vladislav our Timmy
have two rounds to go what an amazing
Victory by artemia in a position where
you would put your house on Magnus not
losing he was safe he was Secure and he
just let his concentration slip for one
moment uh timia punished him and that
means that someone has been blown wide
open our Timmy of Carlson on Eighth and
a half then we've got a big group of
players on eight points dubov playing
some scintillating chess Kmart hanging
in there fedexev who had a great day one
and two Fabiano caruana also in the mix
and vidit who we just saw beating the
reigning Champion Andrew satorov which
effectively puts abdisator of out of the
running
he will not be defending his title we
will have a new world rapid Champion but
who will it be goodness me there are in
my opinion I think seven and a half is
just a bit too far away we can see a
bunch of strong players starring Abdu
sator of sarana magsudu Rapport and many
others but one point behind with two
rounds to go is normally not close
enough half a point sure if we can
envisage it but one point I don't think
will happen
um and uh well we can see uh the game
wrapping up uh Black's attempt at a 50
move rule claim unsuccessful
and I think that's the azri player
actually uh
um
David uh yeah gadam Bailey I believe I
got him by Lee yeah yeah exactly yeah
and he was awarded the win after
Consulting with the Arbiters there we
see some of the chief Arbiters of the
fide World rapper Championship I think
there's artists from around the world
and they do a great job so shout out to
them but uh that game wrapping up means
that the parents will soon be processed
we don't have them quite yet I'm sure
those players at the top of the
standings will be uh yeah we'll be
curious to know who they're facing uh in
the next round some last minute
preparations Magnus as well needs to
avoid the Tilt he needs to get that big
blunder out of his system needs to
forget because it was such a shock to
all of us here Lawrence I think that's
maybe the most shocking moment so far of
the tournament will he recover do you
feel
well I mean it's it's certainly shocking
because we you know our standards for
magnets so high and we expect him to
uh you know to never blunder basically
we're at a stage in in chess history now
where when we think of Magnus we just
think that he is Superman he doesn't
really make one move blunders uh and and
he has and
um it's great for us it's great for the
spectators because now because there was
a genuine possibility that had Magnus
drawn or won that game that the
tournament would be effective over
but now uh looks as though uh it you
know a good eight players could could
possibly win this thing and what's going
to be really interesting to see of
course is how Magnus reacts to this for
me one of his biggest strengths
is his bounce back ability the fact that
he's able to shake off a bad loss or a
bad game pretty quickly reminds me also
of Fabiano I think that's one of the
reason these two especially have been uh
sort of uh fighting for the top spot in
chess for years now their ability to
just forget
quickly not let it weigh on them
um so regardless of
who Magnus plays next if he is able to
just settle his nerves is still favorite
remember he's still favorite to take
down this whole thing but uh it's going
to be really interesting to see
what kind of parents we're gonna get
um
but it's certainly a lot closer than it
was one round ago I'm very very excited
yeah it is uh wide open and uh there
were plenty of uh games that we were
able to follow luckily in that last
round uh plenty of action but Lawrence
maybe we can check out uh the Finish to
one of the games by fan favorite Anish
giri and uh giri did pull it out of the
bag uh in that last game he's still not
completely out of the running after
taking a win uh in this last game if we
can pull up the board there
we can see uh the turnaround or How Gary
clinched that win eventually uh here
Gary had the black pieces it looks like
a relatively balanced end game on the
face of things level number reports
white has a queen side majority but
powerful End Game Play by Gary and uh
look at this white panicked here
under pressure but B5 a move of panic
and black was able to defend everything
nicely maybe White had to go passive but
uh Gary winning a pawn holding on to it
and uh B4
some nice tactics at the end there
undermining the white Bishop there in
that variation black gaining two pawns
and
all you need to do sometimes in winning
positions is to keep things simple
swapping off the Rooks Anish and the
black F Pawn One for the day here white
resigned because F3 F2 F1 horn pushing
is just inevitable and decisive
a nice win by a nation uh we'll get
those updated standings we'll get the
pairing soon but uh he is aiming to
enter the tournament on a high
plenty of these players could still put
together that last two-game winning
streak and it could really uh propel
them into those places remember it's not
just gold that we're looking at it's not
just the title it is a lot of money on
the line uh potentially year defining uh
money career defining money for some of
the younger players so lots to still
play for
no absolutely uh one of the the big
attractions of this tournament is is
it's just that uh as you said David uh
for some of these players they don't get
the opportunity to play for 30 40 50 60
000 one good sort and remember they
played two tournaments it's the rapid
and the blitz I remember I think last
year uh you know if we look at castenia
I think Christian may have even made
close to a hundred thousand dollars
which you know as uh as a professional
chess players for many years David a
hundred thousand is is something that is
very very much an exception unless you
are top five player in the world so it
is uh life-changing opportunities
at these tournaments at the rapid and
Blitz which is why uh it's so nice to
cover
um we don't have the pairings yet but we
will do on our return we're gonna go for
another very quick break when we will
have the pairings for the final round of
the Women's Championship the
pronouncement round of the Open
Championship
uh it's getting very very exciting
you should go absolutely nowhere maybe
you can go and get a drink but that's
about it see you in a few minutes
thanks
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
welcome back everybody to the final day
of the few day world rapid Chess
Championship open and women's section
before the break in the last round we
saw an absolute Thriller and it was
vladislav a timiev with the surprising
victory over Magnus Carlsen making
things extremely open going into the
final two rounds of the open section and
the inara sidewalker server The Local
Hero from Kazakhstan feeding for many
the big favorite guy meaning that she is
currently leading the women's section
with one round to go if she wins her
last round we will have a local world
champion immense pressure
and immense uh Pride on the line for her
let's have a look at the pairings though
for the penultimate round of the open
section and joined of course by like
David David what a mouth-watering
prospect we have at the top
yes this is what the fans have been
waiting for Carlson against caruana two
of the most
enduring top players over the last
decade of course they fought a world
championship match in 2018 against each
other as well
um carawana coming off at the back of
four straight wins he did draw the fine
uh the previous round against Daniel
duboff and he will have black against
Carlson so that is not an easy pairing
he's going to hope that Carlson having
proven he's human goes on tilt but
Carlson knows a win with white will
restore the natural Order of Things uh
at least that's what he will be aiming
for uh meanwhile on board two we do see
fedasev against the co-leader vladislav
artemiev an all Russian Clash both
players of the same of the same
generation as well so these two know
each each other inside out would be
fascinating to see what happens there
Vincent kymer on board three against
vidit both players in hot form Vincent
coming off the back of a really nice win
against napomiyeshi and vidit taking
down the reigning world champion World
rapid Champion Abdul sotorov so both
players confident in form and uh board
four another important Game Richard
reports rising up the table after a
difficult start he will be playing
Daniel dubov who's only half a point off
the lead so all of this group the top
four boards they will all be taking risk
or trying to win to position themselves
before that final round
Lawrence you mentioned earlier as well
there is a group of seven and a half who
aren't mathematically out of it yet you
still technically have chances but they
will need to win their final two games
if they want a medal and uh that group
does include Parham mag Zulu on board
five from Iran against the young
Christian of Duda polish uh phenomenon
Anish Guri we saw his last victory and
uh wrapping it up really nicely in an
end game in the previous round he's up
against Alexei serrana who's well known
for his speed chess prowess and Nihao
sarin the Indian player who really
disappointed yesterday and uh got
checkmated in brutal fashion by Daniel
dubov he's bounced back and he plays
Abdul sator of a fellow teenager Eric I
see as well the final player on seven
and a half he's up against it Jan
napomnishi uh I regressi also has the
black pieces so it's not gonna be easy
but uh Lawrence which parents catch you
right maybe we should do some
predictions at this crucial stage of the
tournament
well of course in terms of pure pairings
Carlson carawana uh is is up there but I
have to say
Carlson with white I've always found
Fabi has had difficulties against Magnus
with the black pieces and I think Magnus
will be actually reasonably happy with
this pairing
um so I'm gonna actually go for an
immediate bounce back victory for Magnus
even though he had that horror show uh
peace blunder in the previous game I
think he bounced back he bounces back
here and I also believe that Vladimir
frederosev is a problematic problematic
opponent for atomiev weird matchup
stylistically I'm actually going to go
for a feather say of win as well I'm
going for a double win on boards one and
two
um and I'm also going for a third white
win I'm going for a one two three three
white wins Vincent Kmart beating vidit
meaning that we're gonna have something
like a
um visit versus no sorry we're going to
have something like uh oh we've got
dubov in there as well Goodness Me do
both on eight points I can't even say
who's gonna play the last round because
I've forgotten who who's playing who but
I'm gonna say that Magnus is gonna be a
leading going into the into the last
round it's a bold prediction but I'm
standing by it
yeah it is 13 Rounds the open section it
is a marathon the players they'll be
relying on pure adrenaline at this point
and Magnus is well known for his stamina
uh for keeping up a very high level
later in tournaments and now we see the
pairings have been announced the players
checking their boards checking their
pairings checking opponents and they
will start to take their seats soon this
next round has been slightly delayed
because there's been a very long end
game in the women's section which only
just finished I believe rook and Bishop
versus Rook ending so it's still a while
before the uh penultimate round of the
open section and the final round of the
women's section as you mentioned
Lawrence we await pairings in that one
but uh yeah it looks like the players
with not that much at stake they're
looking very relaxed I think all eyes
will be on these top few boards uh in
the next round it's it's like what we
it's we couldn't have hoped for more
right
such a critical stage
absolutely brilliant and I will say that
I do believe I've got some info into the
pairings for the women's section and I
have to say this
this is if you're going to become world
champion
uh Dinara Sandra conserva you don't ask
for a better spot than that than this
she is going to be playing Black against
a very informed Indian player I am
Savita but she outrags her by 130 points
um yes Savita has had a great tournament
so far but Cedric kasova has avoided
playing Abdul Malik avoided playing
tanjong ji avoided playing hampi kinuru
and with a win against somebody she
heavily outrates on board one she could
put this tournament to bed what an
opportunity for sarwar kasova uh we
could get a Kazakh one series over wins
and Abdul Malik White against hubby
kinuru if she wins we could get a gold
silver what a a celebration that would
cause in uh in uh almati if we get that
and tanjong ji playing white again
of course there's going to be a lot of
uh you know we're gonna have to
calculate tie breaks and all kinds of
stuff
um to decide the medals but one thing's
for sure did Nara sadwa kasova you could
not ask for a better last round let's
just be brutally honest
for her situation we will be keeping a
close eye on that game and I have to say
this as well uh David
I am not sure that Kazakhstan has ever
had a world rapid champion
you tell me you might
I
I'm sorry they've had a world Blitz
Champion World Blitz but World rapid
Bibi Sarah won last year
World rapid I don't recall
yeah this could be huge for the country
the Dynamics in the women's section now
are very different from the open section
in the women's section she does have her
face in her own handsaver for all her
Rivals including her opponents Savita
they know they need to win on board two
or three everyone's going to be taking
risks they're going to be strapping it
out trying to get that full point at all
costs because they know that this is
their one shot at glory uh they want
those medals and why play it safe why go
for a draw when you know that someone
else is ahead and uh yeah sadhua cassava
I think she still starts his favorite in
this final round but the 15 year old
Savita she's gonna have something to say
she could play spoiler and remember if
she wins she might take gold herself so
both players going all out in this final
round and tie breaks are still a
possibility maybe we can remind our
viewers of the format there if tie
breaks do occur so for example if two
players are tied
the first place we will see a playoff of
two games Blitz Games with three minutes
on the clock each player gaining two
seconds increment after every move if
more than two players are tied if three
players are tied for first then it's a
sudden death knockout tournament that
would be dramatic that's almost never
been seen before especially at this uh
top level v-day have changed the rules
after a bit of controversy last year
with the playoffs where some players
were excluded so this would end in a
knockout tournament and it's not beyond
the Realms of possibility we could still
see three maybe even four players tie
for first place so I like this format
it's nice that the medals will be
decided on the board rather than by a
mathematical equation and that would
give us extra chess extra drama but um
this type of uh this tie break format
also relevant for the open section
we'll discuss the permutations there a
bit later before the final round over
there and uh meanwhile the players
taking that board Lawrence
do you think the nerves will be uh
tingling
ahead of this key round
well certainly it's uh it's that time
isn't it where you know it's make or
break for a lot of these players it's
not just the metal situation as well if
you go further down the back as you were
talking about tons of prizes all the way
down to I think 30 second position uh a
lot of players who have come to this
event have uh paid for some expenses out
of pocket I don't know exactly how it
works for everybody but uh you know it's
a big it's a big moment for a lot of
these players I know for sure uh it's
it's my dream to play this tournament
one day it's it's honestly the only
tournament I've never played that really
gets me excited uh because it's it's
that lottery ticket it's that chance of
of of causing the upsets um especially
in the blitz tournament where the
variance is even higher and as we see by
TBD and us a Hikaru not even in the top
20 yeah Hikaru Nakamura has just not
found his stride in this tournament but
rest assured he will reset tonight and
be back for the blitz tomorrow guns
blazing I expect a big performance from
Hikaru in the blitz tournament
Hikaru Lawrence has drawn seven games in
a row he's drawn nine out of his 11
games so far just unable to find that
Killer Instinct unable to put his
opponents uh yeah to take them down and
often that's the difference nakamura's
got promising positions just you know
unable to get on a roll and uh ahead of
this crucial round maybe in order to get
rid of some of the Nerfs the players are
having a little laugh there dubov making
a joke with karawana Karana leaving his
seat maybe not wanting to sit down not
wanting to allow Magnus to get that
psychological Edge by arriving late uh
just adjusting their pieces in the
background that Rapport against dubov a
clash of Two Fire Brands uh kaima and
vidit looking very calm on the right
side of your screen there but we are
waiting for the arrival of Magnus Carson
still recovering from that huge blunder
against artemiev and uh Carolina looks
ready to go
I can't wait I mean already the opening
I think will dictate a lot it will
illustrate a lot about magnus's mindset
heading into this game will Magnus go
for more off the openings just to play
himself back into form will he go very
direct and try to use all of his kind of
stored up opening preparation against
caruana there we see a picture with many
many Grandmasters now rapport dubov
and uh yeah I mean what what around this
is I mean I'm feeling a bit nervous
myself I must admit
uh just don't know what to expect at all
um there we see the chief Arbiter in the
foreground
we do the Armature learned oats in the
background taking fantastic snaps as per
usual
Fabiana caruana
getting ready for the biggest test of
his tournament there is no bigger
bang Magnus Carlson now Magnus and
Fabiana have recently had an online
match where Fabiano got destroyed
by Magnus that is not an exaggeration I
can't remember the exact score but it
was something like 24 6 or 26
5 also or something crazy on chess.com
uh it was a it was a devastating uh
defeat for Fabi he's now got chance at
Redemption is he gonna pull out the
unthinkable and beat Magnus we're
talking about Magnus he's got white
Magnus Fabi is a Fabby can beat anybody
on his day and Fabi can be anybody
in his kind of positions so
Magnus and coming with the water
yeah we do see the handshake I've got to
say credit to Fabiano very gentlemanly
he didn't start the clock when he could
have done he would have been well within
his rights to uh he was waiting for
Magnus to arrive and uh okay we do see
the first move of the game uh we'll get
into the board in a moment it does look
like a queen's Pawn opening from Carlson
and uh of course Fabiano ready uh that
won't be a surprise
and uh okay Magnus what has he played we
want to see the opening I think it's the
Catalan uh just as he's played
consistently uh throughout the past 12
months Magnus you mentioned that victory
in the speed Chess Championship uh
Lawrence I think Magnus won something
crazy like 18 games eight draws Fabiano
didn't even Land one single punch Fabi
didn't win any games in that match and
surely the psychological scars will be
there uh especially uh you know it's a
matter of Pride right as a chess player
that you do uh kind of you are capable
of occasionally beating your Rivals uh
Magnus has to start this one as the
favorites as we see one of the main
lines of the Catalan
and uh White I think will Castle on this
next move
well I probably will and I just want to
put a little bit of information uh in
for uh everybody in the open section
David was explaining before how if there
are three players tied first there's a
sudden death knockouts on in the women's
section it is only two
that will play off for the championship
so I guess they're gonna rank the
players as you normally would in a
normal Swiss uh by normal tie breaks
maybe some book holes or something like
that Progressive scores I'm not exactly
sure which uh tiebreak they're going to
use to do that and then if there are two
players tied uh sorry if there are more
than two players the top two players of
those tie break scores will have a blitz
playoff to decide the champion but we'll
cross that bridge if we need to of
course a very likely scenario so let's
see in this game though Carlson Carolina
Queen
so C1 this is a um
a funky little move white puts the queen
on C1 compared to the much more natural
Square on C2 and I vaguely remember
is it Harry Krishna who played this I
was commentating again
and there was some subtle reason why you
would put the queen on C1 compared to
the much more standard move Queen C2
David
remind me because my mind is blank why
are we playing queasy one into Queen C2
Laura so I must confess these subtleties
are Beyond me I've also seen Queen C1
recently if I'm not mistaken it might
have been Sam shankland or someone along
those lines uh but either way uh you're
right the queen of C1 does look a bit
oddly placed but she can occasionally
come out uh on the diagonal after a
bishop exchange to a square an active
square like F4 and uh there we go Fabi
reacts by pushing his Pawn to B6 let's
catch up with the play and sooner or
later Magnus will Castle he'll develop
his pieces white has a traditionally a
small advantage in these types of
positions just because he has an extra
Central Pawn after this trade reports in
the center but black is very flexible
it's almost reminiscent of the game
between dubov and Carona in the previous
round where often black will play his
Pawn to C5 he might end up with hanging
pawns which will be a target for white
pieces and Magnus will want to be ready
for that when it comes yeah these
openings they're very very subtle
there's all sorts of nuances that the
players will have studied they will be
familiar with
but Magnus will want to cause the first
surprise Fabi he knows his stuff inside
out he's one of the best opening
theoreticians as you know Lawrence
having been his manager and uh it's
going to be very difficult to take him
kind of out of those theoretical Waters
in out of book and uh Magnus okay he's
trying he's tried this queen C1 move
which does still look a bit odd that
White Queen not very happy on the Square
she stands as a threat in the position
White's E2 Pawn is attacked him
um as uh we were talking about earlier
that speed Chess Championship just a few
weeks ago when Magnus won uh 22-4 he was
undefeated but it was also in very tense
positions where he got most of his wins
Magnus it was always in these really
tense maneuvering type of positions
where Fabiano just couldn't keep up at
some point and the clock ended up
playing a huge Factor this is rapid
chess Fabi starts with much more time
than he did in the speed Chess
Championship but uh yeah that could be
relevant a bit later Magnus asks a
question of the black dark Square Bishop
if the black Bishop takes on D2 then I
guess magnus's idea is to take with the
queen unless he's in the mood to
sacrifice the pawn
for example
yeah 94 Queen C2 and
the game goes on it's just the game goes
on
yep
and uh if Fabi is in a more competitive
mood I was about to say he could keep
the dark Square Bishops on but nope he's
playing principal chess and wow there we
go he's willing to accept the hanging
pawns Lawrence if we see a capture uh on
C5 then those black pawns look exactly
identical to the previous game that
Carolina had against debuff
it still feels like white is risking
nothing but uh black has done his job of
equalizing very classical uh Chess By
books there's these two nothing too
unorthodox too surprising just so much
mutual respect
uh between these two you know Carolina
better than most Lawrence is he going to
be happy with this opening
um
I'm not entirely sure in general I'm not
a fan of this these hanging Pawns
uh I think that uh
you need a really fine touch to to be
able to keep the balance a lot of the
time and you need a little bit of time
to play precisely and I don't think and
the rapid format actually allows you to
do that
yeah Laura sorry to interrupt but yeah
you have to go to the Hans Neiman game
uh possible some dramatic stuff
happening at the beginning of that one
um I mean strange stuff has happened a
lot in the rapid portion uh of this
event so far but uh that's one of the
stranger openings I've seen and let's go
through from the start he's playing a
very promising Grandmaster from
Uzbekistan vocadov and it was the job of
London system Hans is an expert here
he's produced a very nice chessable
course on this opening E4 Pawn sacrifice
but
am I mistaken have things gone
a bit gotten a bit out of hand for him
Bishop takes C3
straightforward Elementary tactic
is this a sacrifice or is this a blunder
looks like a blunder because
Hans has resigned already it seems
sickened by his mistake and ironically
he's actually done a course for
chessable uh on this exact line
um so here the move Bishop B2 was was
definitely not in not in the course I
can't remember if it was a move like
Queen E3 uh I remember this line being
not particularly convincing for white
but yet there should be two aligned
Bishop takes C3 check is shocking
um we should explain maybe why that's
yeah a blunder what happens after B
takes C3 like you say shocking uh it's
just a straightforward tactic hitting
the king hitting the Rook like wins too
much material
yeah I mean this is the type of thing
that uh we've all blunted at some point
in our career it's just surprising that
it happens in such a critical round with
still a lot of money at stakehunts with
a couple of wins in the final two games
could have made a real dent on the
placings but after Bishop 5
black is about to win another Pawn
shocking stuff and we know Hans is a
very emotional player he's a very
um you know he's impulsive in many ways
and he was probably just so sickened
with the fact that he spent dozens of
hours literally on this position on this
opening it was part of his course and
for him to mess this up would have just
tilted him beyond recognition and he
just said you know what I've had enough
but you know even a quick resignation I
mean his position is objectively losing
for for white this is this is bad news
um yeah that's uh that's a big loss that
will that will mean that hands finishes
on some
relatively modest score misses out on
all the prizes and
um
you know puts you in a bad mood for the
rest of the day
yeah we've seen these players are human
they're fantastic all these world-class
Grandmasters but even Magnus blundis as
we saw in the previous round and there
Hans just getting his move order mixed
up in the opening we've all been there
and uh he will be aiming to bounce back
in the blitz section uh okay a
disappointing couple of games but uh
yeah we're back with Magnus against
Carolina uh Lawrence we are we are but
some breaking news on board one of the
women's section there has been a draw
sidewalker server making an early draw
taking the uh the risk-free route to uh
to almost certainly guaranteeing well I
say almost certainly it's not that we'll
we'll have to see what after the
calculations subtle crossover on eight
and a half
uh what that means is that is the second
word Abdul Malik and tanjong ji again
tanjong ji wins and there's a decisive
result on board two between Abu Malik
and kanuru it means there are three
players that will be on eight and a half
and as I mentioned a few moments ago
they will not have the same kind of
playoff as the open tournament only the
top two will then have a playoff and
we will know more about that when we do
uh depending on how they are ranked at
the end but I don't blame Dinara for
taking a quick draw because she is now
pretty much free rolling
um borrowing a complete a sort of uh
um maybe a bit of bad luck to not make
the
the playoff
I've got to say Lawrence I'm yeah
I'm surprised not just uh that Sedro
cassava the leader took the draw but her
opponent I know she's only 15 Savita but
this was her chance as well a win and
she would LeapFrog her opponents she
would be guaranteed first place or joint
first place herself so taking a quick
draw with white in the final round when
you still have a chance at Gold it's
very surprising um to me maybe we can
just show that final position to the
audience to show why it was agreed to
draw it did look very balanced maybe it
was just uh kind of subpar opening for
white that didn't allow her the winning
chances that she would have wanted but
yeah surprising stuff and also for
Saturday her tie breaks will not be so
good she did not start the tournament
well with four draws at the beginning
there so she's not even guaranteed a
spot in that playoff
um however remember the money on offer
the prizes are life-changing so uh we
can't fault the players too much and
this was the final position on board one
of the women's section and uh Queens are
off Pawn structure almost symmetrical
look at those d-pawns it's uh a bit of
an odd one there it's like nuts and
Crosses like tic-tac-toe somehow uh
those Pawns
and I guess without Knights the holes in
each side's position they aren't too
relevant so it is balanced it is an
equal position but uh yeah it's a Pity
we wanted to see more chess that does
however mean maybe tie breaks uh maybe
those playoffs a bit later we'll wait to
find out we'll update you with the other
buds in the women's section
as the results yeah
as I'm looking at the games uh still
plenty of play left in the tanjong
Reggie game actually tanjong ji is she
just winning let's just quickly go there
because I think it's it's worth going
there against Nina batsies really
looking at this position here
this looks Dreadful I mean look at these
pawns first and foremost have you seen
uglier Pawns in all your life
double pawns here tripled horns here
some double pawns over here for Nino but
the problem Nino's law is just that
Black's King is much more weak than
whites if I ever get this queen on this
diagonal here I'm just gonna make you
doesn't this just looks winning for
white to you
this looks over that black king has no
Defenders around it and the The Beauty
lyrics you mentioned those triple pawns
the White House on the G file the beauty
behind those is that white king I think
it's we're about to see it but white
king can safely hide on the H2 square or
anywhere on the H file because those
pawns keep white skin protected black
would love uh to retreat her Pawn from
G5 to G7 I think that would be the best
move for black if she could play it
right pulling back to G7 just to guard
her King but
this is another example of opposite
color Bishops in a middle game aiding
the side with the safer King aiding the
side who's going on the attack and yeah
just Shuffle the king out the way like
is threatening to push the D Pawn
forward with the Discover check so I
think she needs to take her time out get
her King to safety and long term as well
for the black king there's not going to
be any Refuge there
uh you can see on the body language as
well turns on you with white very calm
composed just calculating her way to
what is most likely going to be a
victory Nino looks a bit more nervous
and we've only played a few minutes both
sides have over 10 minutes still left on
their clock
but uh it's all gone wrong for black in
the opening
yeah this could be huge as well tanzongi
therefore would catch up with saddle
cassava in the lead
absolutely yes and uh
I again if there's two of them we know
that there's gonna be a blitz playoff if
there's three of them we need to see
exactly how they are rank we will of
course keep an eye on that but great
spot for Tan drong view let's go back to
round of or game of the round
Carlson Carolina we've had Mass
liquidations
and Fabi looks all right to me here
David
yeah it looks like black should be able
to secure a draw with some accurate play
this one is much more sedate much more
uh quiet than the previous games we've
just looked at it's roughly balanced in
terms of Pawn structure black does have
a weakness however on C5 which is
attackable white Rook will aim to slide
across the C1 if the Rooks come off the
board white is the only one who can win
that end game I think white has great
winning chances because the white Bishop
is superior to the Black Knight with
pawns on both flanks White's King also
has a clear path towards those
weaknesses on the queen side for black
however Fabi as long as he keeps the
Rooks on as long as he can go active
with his Knight maybe his Rook to the
second rack at some point he is doing
completely fine and uh he's also a very
accurate calculator Lawrence uh this is
the type of position the type of end
game you can calculate your way out of
uh okay he starts by attacking the white
Bishop forcing Magnus to lose time
either moving or protecting that Bishop
next move I think you can almost
pre-move his black The Rook is coming
down to D2
and
I don't foresee any troubles at all uh
White will be banking on the fact that
uh his a pawn as often in the Catalan
the white apron promotes on a light
Square guarded by White's Bishop but
that's very much a long-term Factor
Magnus there just picking up his King
lifting lifting it up a square and
Lawrence are we going to see this famous
end game of rook and four against rook
and three for example if black starts
with uh let's say Knight takes F3 let's
get rid of those pieces before it's too
late Rook D2
and uh Rook C1 by Magnus black does have
some issues on the back rank so white
will win a pawn however this is well
known to be a draw and I think Fabiano
will be quite confident about holding
this type of endgame
um
are you that confident because the white
king is already quite close no I mean
yeah I don't know I think maybe there's
slightly better ways of doing or getting
the same game at least okay he starts
with G6 uh I yeah I guess I've had too
many of those end games and I've always
failed to win with white so uh maybe I'm
a bit biased also facing Magnus it's not
going to be easy in that type of end
game it's a just illustrating one
variation there now maybe Fabi holding
on to the Knight one move longer is
going to prevent that end game from
happening Lawrence uh after white mooses
Rook across at least black can hold up
the inevitable liquidation of those
Queen type pawns by playing a move such
as C4 Maybe
but
those pawns long term are a bit weak I
would be afraid if I were a Fabby of
white chess sitting maybe a move such as
Rook C2 next by Magnus just holding on
after C4 just holding on uh to the
position not swapping down yet maybe
Rook C2 followed by Bishop E2
yes it should be a draw but uh as Anita
drinks says in the feature chat never
trust the eval bar on his Magnus it's
definitely white who's the only player
who can hope for winning chances
um yeah I'm not gonna say draw yet
although that is the most likely
yeah I think the move C4 is actually a
difficult move to play yeah and Fabi
does go for Rook D2 straight away uh
makes a lot of sense
um and on Rook text C5 is you don't have
to take on F3 you do have the move
Knight D3 here this move does exist and
Rook takes F2 is actually a big threat
and the pawn on B2 is also hanging of
course for Rook on C5 is hanging so you
can't even take on A5 if you give a
check on C8 I actually just go King G7
and
I think I take black here David just
because I'm doing a mopping up job
of the pawns on the second rank
yeah you're also threatening Knight E1
Lawrence uh so white really has to be
careful here oh
and uh yeah we do see Rook D2 played in
the game and has Magnus got a backup
plan here if Rook takes C5 doesn't work
uh after Rook D2
will he just play a move such as Bishop
E4 preventing the black knight from
jumping into the white Camp attacking
those pawns as you mentioned there white
actually is maybe on the back foot so
um I like that pun by and Magnus I know
really sorry let's just let's just get a
a full vision here Magnus he is
up in arms again second game in a row
he's saying oh my goodness how have I
got myself into another spot where
I'm kind of fighting
to to even equalize now as white
everything was going so smoothly but how
do you deal with Knight D3
and he's visibly upset with the
situation this is very very
uncommon to see
um wow it's the Tilt it's the Tilt
Lawrence he's still not fully recovered
from that previous game the big blunder
against Artemis and yes he should still
hold the draw it's still balanced but
you're right I mean I said white was
better but I don't think I had
calculated properly and Magnus certainly
relaxed a bit too soon uh maybe he knew
that this game was heading towards the
drawer he thought he could play Anything
But at the top level you have to be
super accurate and okay he just needs to
escape this game with the draw he's
still got eight minutes on the clock
plenty of time Magnus he needs to
compose himself mentally Fabiano great
Focus From Him great moves from him as
well and
yeah he's got to hope that Magnus just
keeps rushing and uh Rook D2
maybe we go for that variation Lawrence
I still think white was pretty safe well
yeah pretty safe uh reluctantly but
after Rook takes C5 okay I think we can
get away with Knight D3 a check maybe
now Rook C8 and
maybe you just moved the king uh for
white king G1 or maybe you move the
white Bishop I'm not sure where let's
play King G1 for example
I think we're heading down this
variation just to get the white king out
of uh any potential threats
okay root takes B2
it rotates B2 and now maybe I'll just go
after the a pawn uh Rook A8
yeah I mean well it's uh that yeah
yeah
hates that move oh okay that was a one
move blunder rugby one check here wins
oh yeah 1v1 and 91.
whoops so we have to be more accurate
than I was that but that does show the
difficulty of uh White's task so instead
of Rook A8 Magnus would have to find
some really
clever really sneaky moves just to
survive
wow
yeah I mean it still feels like it
should be a draw of the evaluation bar
confirms but it's certainly White
who has to be accurate
yeah can you imagine the a Fabiano
caruana Victory here
oh my goodness then who knows what would
go on with the tour and then we could
have a complete pile up on on nine
points but we'll cross that bridge still
a long way to go Magnus is not going to
give up so easily
yeah
imagine as well if Fabiano he played
what was it 26 games against Magnus in
the speed Chess Championship didn't win
a single one and uh now when the stakes
are even higher uh he's uh really
putting the pressure on impressive stuff
by carowana and Magnus does retreat his
King King G1 it looked like the best bet
because Knight E1 Rook takes F2 were
both huge huge threats but as you
mentioned Lawrence after Rook takes B2
Magnus has to avoid blundering
or it takes B2 it's not easy to find the
best move there for white maybe you have
to move the bishop out the way maybe we
can put this on the board Rook takes B2
and the white Bishop has to run before
that threat of of rugby one as you
mentioned maybe bishop D5
just by processing elimination I think
you can save this for white next you go
for the F7 Pawn or the A5 Pawn but yeah
you take black here if anything nuts are
so tricky
absolutely
absolutely
yeah and the the other battles as this
one rages on
um anything catching your right Lawrence
or any of the other chasing pack uh
putting some pressure on getting those
points
the Kmart video game is is particularly
interesting uh if we look at the current
position
uh wow yeah
at first when you first look at it you
think oh black is doing great but I'm
not sure that's the case when this
Knight on C4 lands on E3 and just kind
of holds the entire position together
um
who's better and why
I'm not
sure of the answer
you're right black has overextended
somewhat like looks like he's kind of uh
clamped down on the right position with
this black Pawn on D3 but maybe that's a
weakness long term white is threatening
a move such as Bishop takes F6 as well
oh wow it was actually white to play in
that position yeah Bishop takes F6
wrecking the black porn structure and I
think your move is coming next uh that
white knight is going to retreat to E3
swapping off one of those powerful black
bishops and uh yeah that white Bishop F1
is the only problem that white Bishop is
very stuck but Pawn structure everything
white Vincent looking like he's a
favorite now
and uh did it after his winning streak
suffering in this position it feels like
video has been taking chances fair play
to him he's taking risks because he
really wants to win he uh he's full of
confidence but after a move maybe we
could put this on the board Lawrence she
takes F6 and Knight E3 locking it down
I think that's the key move without
Knight E3 white is under some pressure
but uh this one forces simplifications
and very favorable for white
any exchanges will highlight the
weaknesses of Black's Pawns
yeah I mean drama everywhere like you
said we could see a bunch of players up
there on nine points heading into the
final round we could see a five player
playoff who knows anything still
possible and uh okay but it did take
back on F6 and we are expecting Knight
to E3
um
white with the advantage
meanwhile in the Magnus game things have
proceeded roughly along the lines that
we envisaged Fabiano though has won a
pawn and after kimchi one yeah this
variation
interesting stuff Knight takes F2 has
Magnus just given away this Pawn to try
and trap Black's Knight Black's Knight
doesn't have too many Escape squares
there's only one safe Square on H3 for
it to retreat to
Magnus how does he
utilize this uh momentary uh opportunity
maybe to trap the Black Knight
yeah but then you know it goes to H3 it
goes to G5 you recycle it and then all
of a sudden it's a pawn and you're like
Magnus hands on legs that is the Magnus
tell for oh boy
I'm gonna have to work really hard to
make a draw here
uh this is not what Magnus had in mind
before sitting down for this game let me
tell you that
Magnus yeah down on the clock down on
the position
down on momentum
yeah brutal going down on his luck
after well four by Magnus
he's like his luck is the greatest in
the world but he's certainly down
I mean the guy at anything the guy
touches turns to gold
that's real luck
um
uh no let's say H4 trying to cut this
Knight out mates
makes a lot of sense and this is what
mag has been trying this whole time oh
Lawrence sorry to interrupt there's been
a huge result in the women's section Yi
has finished her game yes and uh there
we see the players leaving the board
tanzong Yi it's guaranteed herself a
huge share of the prize money uh she's
one with white we saw that position
earlier with a big big attack the weird
porn structure and she did finish it off
in style and tanzongi joins uh sadhua
cassava in the lead so we will see a
playoff no matter what at this point in
the women's section A couple of players
could still uh have their say they could
join then it becomes a math equation but
yeah
clinching the win when it matters
that's what all the top players do that
is correct
top players tanjong view she's love
she's she's done such a good job of
cementing her place in the in the
absolute Elite of women's chess it's
it's really nice to see
so the question that now remains is if
there is a decisive result in canara
against Abdul Malik and what we can do
is we can have a quick look
at the uh the position
uh
here we go
uh looks as though
on the back foot ever so slightly
because white is possibly forced to take
back the bishop with the pawn
take with the queen uh The Rook takes
this pawn and if you take with the pawn
you've got this horrible structure now
on the king side and
white doesn't have anything close
to a raving attack so
big chance for a classical player like
hampi in this position
yeah and it looks like Abdul Malik did
take with the queen she couldn't stomach
there's horrible pawns that she would
have been uh left with if she had
recaptured with the G pawn and now as
you say humpy can just get greedy take
that c Pawn
you're getting closer to the white king
as well it does look like maybe humpy
will be the third player to join on
eight and a half in which case one of
those three would be unlucky and miss
out on the playoffs
we will find out a bit later on if that
does become relevant Abdul Malik
meanwhile going on The counter-attack
Rook 81 reminding humpy that her back
rank is not entirely secure yet so still
some work to be done I actually like
Abdul Malik's decision she's not taking
the long-term weaknesses she would
rather suffer a material deficit and at
least get some activity at least post
some difficult questions both sides low
on the clock in this one some drama
ahead
and uh meanwhile
yeah it looks like this is the final
crucial game these are the final players
who can jump up to share first prize
and uh in the open section Lawrence yes
yeah Magnus I think is equalizing is
holding the draw against Carolina I
think that H4 move
um kind of taking away the Black Knights
Escape Route was critical and now black
can't save his a pawn
a pawn will fall no matter what Black
Knight if it wants to get out it needs
to do that now but uh Magnus will start
trading things off
I think we'll see a draw most likely in
this game which does open the door to
the other players
certainly does and just keeping
obviously an eye on some of these other
games
are
Kmart still with a great position
against vidit Rapport beating dubov uh
well he's porn up in a rook ending with
zero losing chances so Rapport is gonna
Dent two Buffs last gasp hopes of
getting something because a complete
mess
um optically it looks good for black but
for whatever reason the computer likes
white
uh and we can go to that one Lawrence
it's very important artemia a co-leader
Felice of his countrymen uh trying to
stake his own claim but uh this is the
position on board two I'll tell me if he
takes the win as black he's gonna be the
big favorite with white in the final
round
um but the black queen is attacked does
she have to retreat if she does that
will give white a moment or two to
consolidate you think
I mean it's tempting right why can't he
play it actually
um he needs calculations
yeah we have to take
and now the
oh Rooks no no I mean takes B7 very
complicated Healers
what why why why is this equal
very very good question I mean we
continue
we can take on B7 at the very just
taking on p7 but B7 Rook B8
okay
one check
you can block yeah if you had to go to
H2 with the white king you might well
have got checkmated after Knight G4 so
uh you're lucky that you can block your
back Rank and white would be a pawn up
this is really well calculated uh well
calculated or very lucky from feder safe
we've got to say and uh okay I'll tell
me if doesn't take up the challenge he
doesn't call the bluff uh it didn't look
like a bluff but he doesn't embark on
any complications he just Retreats The
Black Queen maybe we can see the current
game position Lawrence yeah after Queen
back D6
and to me it looks balanced the computer
slightly prefers white maybe because
White's Bishop is superior to the black
Bishop Black's Bishop really stuck and
uh in terms of the pawn structure white
has a small Advantage because of that
clamp the white A5 Pawn doing a great
job
of taking away some key squares and uh
also 20 seconds now for artemiev that is
his Achilles heel we saw against Magnus
he had one minute against 12. he managed
to wriggle out of that one and land a
tactical blow but it's not easy with uh
less than one minute against three in
such a tense position
I do slightly favor white here I must
agree with the evaluation bar on this
occasion I just don't see how black can
uh cause any immediate trouble okay V8
defending the bishop I can amp up the
pressure with Rook B2 because that's why
it's Queen can move
well it's nights will start improving
soon
small Advantage but a stable Advantage
for fedasev on board and clock
you mentioned on board four Reports most
likely beating dubov a very tense end
game there
um or three Vincent climate with the
advantage against vidit maybe let's
stick with this one for a moment or two
longer yeah
I'm keeping an eye out on the on the
well we do actually have a result in the
Carlson game
that is officially a draw
okay Carolina bailed out with a
repetition of moves
we mentioned it was equal he managed to
give a few checks with his Knight and a
draw that only adds to the tension ahead
of the last round
do you think we'll see playoffs in both
the open and women's Lawrence I think so
now yeah I think I think there's just a
a fantastic chance
uh to to see both
um and I'm assuming that the Women's
Club is going to take place during the
men's last
round
or are they gonna hold the women's
playoff until
the men's playoff perhaps we can get
some
details on that from our lovely uh
from our lovely producer
yeah I do think that the William
I do think the women's playoff will take
place uh during the final round of the
open section otherwise the women will
yeah I think that's just been confirmed
to us now by our producer
um otherwise the women would have to
wait for a couple of hours and I don't
think anyone wants the what's the build
up of tension there I think uh it makes
sense to keep going while they're in the
tournament Hall while they're they're at
the venue meanwhile our tamif in camera
in shot right now he does drop back the
black queen to keep everything protected
and fair to save
always surprising us never playing the
move uh the most natural move always
kind of trying to
cause the opponent some Shock he puts
his Queen on A1 what is this defending
the white people but clumsy Square
clumsy swear but maybe he didn't have
anything that much better and he just
says you know Queen A1 I'll defend it oh
Timmy have almost down to zero time Rook
C2 I mean our Timmy of his play is he
playing on 10 seconds maybe we can get a
close-up of this clock because he might
just explain
okay we've got no clock no close-up but
according to the server he's playing on
almost no time
yeah I'll tell me if he's so calm look
at how he made his last move look how
he's about to make this move so calmly
he's only got a few seconds left and he
recruit Retreats his Knight to E8 but
the momentum is all in White's favor now
White's Knights are springing forward
blacks pieces are pretty much retreating
parking the bus on the back rank it's
like he's setting up ready for the next
game again
um white tonight can come forward to B3
white tonight can come forward the other
night can come into E5
is all about feather save right now I
think he could take this chance it's a
golden opportunity to jump into the
joint lead take down one of the
co-leaders
but then again FedEx he's down to one
minute as well and under clock pressure
it's unclear who the favorite will be
um yeah there's two night jumps Lawrence
I think they're both for attempting he
chooses to LEAP into the center forcing
against change and now Black's Knight on
E8 is stuck but TF gives up a pawn
temporarily white can take the pawn on
A6 with his Bishop wow that cool reply
rookie eight
yeah so
so quick so sharp I'll tell me over
there
seeing that he can abandon his pawn and
regain it
why tonight though I think is going to
start mobilizing now
it's time for that white knight to try
and reach the D4 Square it's dream
Outpost after Bishop D7 Knight E2
and let's get those moves on the board
and yeah still white in charge because
White's pieces are more active
yeah I still like open pieces yeah I
mean this this home for the night on D4
creates quite the impression and all the
endings are very sad for black as well
because all of Black's pawns are fixed
on light squares A6 permanent weakness
this structure can be eroded as well so
you know having played the white side
against it reminds me of a bad French
for black actually
yeah warrants sorry to interrupt a huge
result in the women's section humpy
Canary did not convert she did not get
the win that we expected Hampton area
has drawn against Abdul Malik and
therefore it's only two players up uh in
first place tanzongi and sadhua kasova
so actually Abdul Malik doing her
country uh doing her compatriot there a
favor
by holding humpy off uh in that really
difficult middle game uh saving the draw
hey we'll get a two-player playoff in
that case and I is that confirmed now is
it sadwell cassava and tanzong Yi for
the title
pretty sure
yeah great save by Abdul Malik
so uh a lot of happy Green Arrow fans we
see in the feature chat and she does end
the tournament on a draw and I think a
joint third place
meanwhile the Bishops are off yeah
you're talking about this game Sorry
Lawrence
no no no no I I was just saying that the
Bishop's offer actually definitely
benefits black uh that's number one I
think a lot of Peace treats he would
love to get the knights off the board as
well but why does one important look at
this uh you know uh the question is
Queen takes E5 doesn't
look flat but it is because Quincy King
f8 was there these guys playing just on
English yes yes not just not just King
f8 black was threatening mate in one
black was threat
excuse me excuse me
why is the one balancing on the
precipice here living life on the edge
uh white king under serious uh threats
yeah Queen H5 would have ended in
disaster so Knight F4 kicked away
now the black queen is blocked from
getting to H5 so white can gain some
time white can play a move such as
Knight D3 retreating where I can also
consider
um yeah maybe Landing the Knight on H5
no I mean for the safe what does he do
he Retreats the queen he's really
hitting that black Rook
I guess that's heating up
look at that white Pawn on A5 as well
will that decide the game eventually
uh I'll tell me of trying desperately to
keep active swapping off the Rooks he's
going for that white A5 Pawn the White
Knight also Under Fire
how does FedEx keep everything intact
The Rook the Knight both under threat
right now
yeah yeah oh Timmy have
extremely resourceful
one of his big strengths is just how
resourceful he truly is and I
yeah I understand yes Lawrence we have
another result confirmed Vincent kymer
we saw he had a big advantage against
Vida earlier and he did convert so
Vincent kymer joins the wow
yeah huge result and uh our team have
could still take the lead he's a pawn up
if he wins this end game but it's
looking difficult look at that black
king various attacking ideas against it
whites came safe as houses right now
it has some huge results for the
standings it looks like magazine who's
going to win he will be behind the lead
um beating Duda
yeah I have so much drama
tons of drama and Max sudlu
maxudlu suddenly could play spoiler who
knows because one of these guys somebody
like a magsudu or a rapport is going to
get an upload because Carlson has played
for the serve he's played our Timmy if
he's played kaimer uh he's played uh has
he played well vidit is out of the
question now
he's played uh Carolina of course so
Carlson is gonna get somebody like Max
sudlu in the last round again I don't
really feel as though magsudu is a great
opponent for Magnus he's he's artemi of
like he's tricky and he's he's uh
uncompromising and he's uh you know I I
don't think that's a great pairing for
Magnus if he does get magsudu of course
we don't know if he will let's stay with
this game yeah go on yep big moment
Lawrence I'll tell me I've has the
option if he wants of forcing a draw
immediately black can play Queenie one
check followed by Queen H4 check and
just repeat the position White's King
cannot Escape
he's not going for it though he wants to
win this game and uh White is a bit
stuck White Queen and Knight defend each
other they're trying to create some
Checkmate threats they're neutralized by
black Snipes and
I don't really see any productive moves
white you can watch a pawn for example
to G3 but that creates extra weaknesses
as well feather save he's hoping and
praying that he can just sit here and do
nothing and get the draw eventually but
hey he goes active with the White Queen
but this allows a knight exchange
feathers saith now on the defensive only
artemiev can win and remember he's
already won one Queen end game he beat
Eric icy earlier today with an extra
Pawn in a queen end game this one should
maybe be a draw with best play but it's
not going to be easy in Practical terms
we might be here all day seeing if I'll
tell him we've come grind it out he
might be the sole leader if he does win
this game or he will be the Soul Leader
uh and okay White's Queen needs to get
to the black king but Black's King is
super safe Lawrence saving chances here
is so unpleasant for white surely
um I would say
uh very very
difficult to hold with white objectively
four versus three the black king at the
Moon is safe the pawn on H6 doing a
great job of covering this G5 Square
um now objectively of course this
position should be a draw but as I say
with the lack of checks available to
White the fact that it's Black's move
feels as though there's way to make
inroads here
and I'll tell you about having one
uh you know a similar ending against
Arjun irrigation a couple rounds ago
um you do feel as though
he's he's got the momentum on his side
yep and uh fair to say I've tried
desperately to cling on Queen A7
defending White's weakness the E3 Pawn
from afar you also have to watch out for
transitions to King and Portland games
where black maybe even gives back the
extra Pawn just to get the coins off if
the black king can start entering the
position but uh yeah I'll tell me if
this is hit this is where he Revels this
is his comfort zone uh yeah he loves
these types of positions with minimal
risk and look at fair to say of hearing
over his shoulder
I think he's looking at the big screen I
think he's wondering about the 50 move
rule Which is far far from coming into
effect but he's just got to knuckle down
and survive he can't get distracted
White's task is so unpleasant and uh
already potential threats on the board
such as Queenie fortrek black can push
D4 white is very very much stuck at the
moment okay going Queen F6 trying to
counter but uh black will always guard
his own King as we see there Black's
Queen very agile and
where we've got to fasten our seat belts
this one is gonna go for the Long Haul
like finally pushing forward with H5
this is uh yeah this is what automobile
do he'll maneuver maneuver for 10 20
moves then he'll start pushing pawns
he'll just wants to gain a bit of time
on the clock as well feder Sev is the
one lower uh in that department
and G3 it feels like White's leaving too
much space behind his King now if the
black queen ever lands on F1 that's
checkmate
it just yeah it feels almost uh almost
losing for weight but maybe with such an
active Queen you can defend
it's not fun at all
King back to F2
yeah I'm expecting the black queen to
try and sneak in at some point fire H3
perhaps the black king can start
advancing maybe the black king can come
to G6 no more checks for white
and he does it
and he does it today
love this move David well done Queen h8
the
White Queen now looking for a bit of uh
action around the back
yeah and unfortunately unfortunately
thought I'd tell me if you can't play
King F5 because the White Queen comes
back to E5 uh with a check kicking you
back where you came from uh so I'll tell
me if instead retrace his Queen
is there a way out of the checks now
after the oh effects of the White Queen
maybe
uh king of six Queenie a king G7
yep the king can sidestep and no matter
where the White Queen checks from the
King will go the other way and um just
taking a look at the open section most
of the top boards have been resolved by
now uh We've mentioned most of the
results
what do you think Lawrence shall we
stick here this is bound to last for a
long time I think so well uh well yes I
mean we can we can have a look let's
just take a quick look to see if there's
any other really important results uh to
be honest the results below this board
have been uh favorable for
magsudu and some of the top guys because
we've seen a bunch of drawers Gary
Serrano draws sarin abdulsator of Jordan
the publishi Arjun draw MBL has won
again putting him on eight points
against bassim two little too late for
the French Grand Master manager of
beating so I guess in
so a bunch of top players are going to
be on eight but Carlson and Kmart
on nine and our Timmy have going to be
at least on nine remember if artimia
wins this he is clear first
and could easily get a down float to
somebody like a magsudu for example
um
so a win here is worth a huge amount of
equity in the tournament and that's why
um you know he should be taking his time
yeah wins with black like gold dust in
these events in general but especially
at such a late stage of the tournament
and I'll tell me to remember is do white
in that final round so a win here he'll
have white in the final game with a lead
in the tournament he would be a huge
favorite to get that gold medal to get
the title and uh he still has to come
past uh he still has to overcome
um feder saves defenses Queen E7 I'd
really like that move threatening not
just Queen takes E6 but also Queen E8
check various uh various checking motifs
can the black king Escape
it's not going to be easy by pushing
Black's Pawn forward to F6 he's taken
away some Escape squares for his own
King
you actually have to be slightly careful
here's black you can't get too ambitious
I don't think you can afford to match
your king forward or can you is the
black king coming to F5 no Artemis gives
another check
better save pauses before stepping
forward the white king
and
how is artemiev going to evade all these
checks okay he's lined up a sneaky
discover check he wants to push the
black pawn forward to D4 black queen
yeah would hit the white king so the
white king takes a step back
the key question is whether white later
can get that Perpetual track that's the
only way to draw the game I'll tell me
if there's no shutting the door on any
potential checks retreating the whole
way back
but now white surely just Waits
black is a bit stuck Black's Queen has
had to go passive to defend any checks
against her King
yeah this one Lawrence the more I look
at it the more I think it should end up
in a draw feather saves defended it
brilliantly really well really well so
far
brilliant defense about further south
yeah
you know the top players
the Carlsons the carowanas they will all
be looking at this game crossing their
fingers hoping that artemia doesn't win
um he's got a lot of fans right now fair
to save in his defensive efforts
yeah they've got to hope that he holds
because uh then Artemis is within
Striking Distance
and the black Queen's still not too
active on G8
I don't really see the winning plan for
black right now once Queen comes back
with a check
and stays active yeah great defensive
performance uh says the chemist on the
feature chat I agree that's what you
need to win prizes at this level you
can't just crush your opponents every
game better knuckle down
you've got to have a great defense as
well
yeah Lawrence absolutely
I mean it's breath of the stuff I
hesitate to ask for predictions in the
final round but yeah what you said well
that's some uh some huge pairings yeah
it's it's gonna a lot of it's gonna be
down to the pairings isn't it uh
especially if we're expecting a draw
here and I really see now no serious way
for black to uh to try something maybe
you can try and engineer some E5 or
something I don't know uh just something
different in the position but
um you know for me I'm going to reserve
judgment until I've seen the pairings I
think the parents are going to play a
huge role for this last round now
magsudu he is now you know that name in
the mix changes everything
um
you know we could get Kmart against Max
sudlu
uh or or Carlson against Mike sudler
um and Kmart against uh
uh Carolina or something like that so I
mean we're gonna you know
uh
I will be able to have a clearer idea
and E5 by the way was played it may have
seen managed to make some progress at
least
yep he needed to push at some point
black still doesn't have any passports
which are the uh they're like golden
nuggets uh out there uh in Queen
opponent games that's the currency that
you need to win uh in these types of
engages black doesn't have any so he
needs to create some and therefore you
push E5 but this does leave some weak
squares uh as you say Laura it's Queen
F5 came in attacking some pawns I'll
tell me if it's trying to bully for the
save now with the ghosts of a queen
exchange and feather save has to keep
the Queens on you can't allow those
Queens to come off but where do you go
with the White Queen he stepped in
think to the E6 Square judging by the
camera there we go black Central pawns
are much looser than they previously
were and Black's Queen is playing a
defensive role
um okay it gives a check first of all so
can the black queen keep the king safe
while ushering her pawns forward
it doesn't seem possible to me a black
gives some checks but doesn't feel
productive really white king happily uh
just don't go to F3 just don't go to F3
one trap one trap
how about that and actually this is
yes yeah current alerts no I mean it's
very relevant because now the white King
has to go passive so that's definitely
some kind of victory for black the
problem is how do you take advantage of
it
that's the hard part
yeah you have to be very careful where
you step there we see the white king
avoiding any potential horn captures
which end in a check why is threatening
Queen takes F6 after all which would
result in a perpetual and a draw so as
long as you don't allow the black queen
to take any of white pawns with check
you should still be okay you will force
black to go defensive eventually and uh
there we go the black king steps across
wow Lawrence he wants to March his King
in any checks and the black king is
coming
this is certainly not so easy maybe we
can show A variation such as
Queen GH or FTC five yeah Queen G8 or
queen E8 I was thinking and the black
king starts coming in you can't stop its
path either via E4 or G4 it is entering
and
hey as you mentioned ftc5 was played now
the black queen is going to try and
snake her way back
yes yes
Queen C1 Queen C2 Queen B2
gaining enough time on the clock
and this is
this could be a long game
it could be a 200 move game uh it could
be my favorite
if it was David Howell it would be I can
tell you that
I mean if this was me playing as black I
would never have pushed the pawns
forward until move 40 I would have
waited as long as possible but uh here
we go another check
the Viking has to move and there we go
black finds the right angle and black
takes that Central Pawn white however is
giving some checks now can I'll tell you
escape body language wise it does look
like a tummy of his paused
and not too happy there we go tapping
his hand it looks like white can just
continue insisting with the checks I
think we might be about to see a draw
and a handshake No Escape for the black
king Lawrence got there in the end fedes
keeps the tournament wide open
certainly does uh great defense there by
Vladimir
feder save uh just keeping things nice
and tight
with one round to go wow what a what a
round what what a tournament it's been
breathtaking stuff
and the situation is clear
three players leading the tournament on
nine out of 12 Carlson Kmart and are
Timmy have followed by a bunch on eight
and a half uh we have duboff feducev
Carolina and Max sudlu
so
we now have a situation where
uh depending on the pairings of course
we could have uh you know a you know you
know one we could can we actually have
two players online playing each other or
if they already all play each other
Kmart has played Carlson
and has not played our Timmy F so I'm
just trying to brainstorm things but why
should I do the work that's not my job
my job is to commentate on the games
with my good friend David Hal for you
lovely people what we're going to do is
we're going to take a much needed break
we'll be back in a few minutes when
we'll have pairings for the final round
of the open and we'll have more
information about the playoff in the
women's section are we going to have a
local hero in the form of Dinara or is
tanjongi going to spoil the party
only one way to find out we'll be back
in a few minutes don't go anywhere see
you soon
[Music]
I understand 18 seconds for a black so
not too much time there either Rook C7
a7's falling uh it is E4 he pushes the
pawn this is getting a little messy
takes a knight F1
3 King E4 91
. move you know oh my gosh 0.9 seconds
when that move was played wait
ing
but there was Checkmate in one for black
after Knight takes G3
oh my God that was there and instead he
played here and he's never losing oh my
God A7 wins for white oh my gosh
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
championships 2022 we've had an
incredible day so far in the open
section uh Magnus Carlson losing a
couple of rounds ago blue the field wide
open the tournament wide open now and
we're going to get into exactly what the
current state of affairs is in just a
moment meanwhile in the women's section
we have a playoff a blitz playoff for
the title Local Hero inara sarawaka
server is going to be playing against
tanjong ji they're going to be playing a
couple of Blitz Games uh to decide who
becomes World rapid Champion alongside
me of course as always is the one and
only David Howe David
um let's uh let's actually start with
the women's section uh massive massive
opportunity for a local uh hero win how
do you rate Denarius
chances against somebody as strong and
informs tangology
yeah it's going to be difficult for the
local favorite tanzong Yi just looking
phenomenal over the past 12 months over
the past couple of years really upping
uh her game one of the kind of standout
players of women's chess over the past
few years so it's not going to be easy
for sadhua kasova but the momentum is on
her side she did win what was it six
seven games in a row uh for a stretch
there so she comes in feeling confident
and with huge crowd behind her of course
uh maybe we can see the leaderboard of
the women's section and uh these are the
final standings after those 11 rounds we
see two players end up with eight and a
half points phenomenal score very high
score there followed by four players
Savita who did draw with Shadow
classified in the final round
winning her final round to catch up
there and uh Abdul Malik and Canary who
we saw had a really exciting game but
were unable to join the leaders so yeah
it is those two tanzogi
one of them is going to get gold one of
them's gonna get silver both of them are
going to get huge prize money so
congratulations to them already but uh
yeah Blitz potentially Armageddon chess
Lawrence
it's going to come down to one or two
moves here and there it's going to come
down to who holds their nerve better
both players banging form right now
yeah absolutely uh gonna be very very
curious to see how that plays out before
we go to the standings of the open
tournament just uh another announcement
uh do uh bear in mind guys that
registration is now open for the spring
2023 season of Collegiate chess the
Collegiate chess league if you're a
university student and you want to
represent your school in the best online
chess league for college students sign
up now don't miss your shot to make
history in the biggest CCL season to
date type in exclamation mark CCL in the
chat for more information registration
does close however on January 13th so
you've got a couple of weeks
um if you are uh really into your chest
and a student uh please do sign up for
that because that's an awesome little
league to be part of
now let's move over to the open section
David and have a look at the standings
we don't know the pairings just yet for
the final round
or do we we all or do we let's do the
standings first and then we do just have
the pairings now uh we can see
Magnus Carlson Vincent came up vladislav
our Timmy have all on nine points
closely followed by a group on eight and
a half double
and magsudu and
it is a good final round I believe for
Magnus Carlson David let's have a look
at the stair the pairings
yeah and uh it's those groups on nine
points and eight and a half points that
we're looking at in particular those are
the only uh players who can get into
that playoff potentially or who can get
into the medals and uh Magnus Carlson
gets the white pieces again a very nice
pairing there uh as you say Lawrence on
paper however Max Zulu very dangerous
and inform winning his last two or three
rounds in a row and uh Magnus magzudlo
we mentioned there another co-leader
artemiev gets black yet again against
caruana uh not the ideal powering car
Rohana and of course a fearsome uh rival
there a fearsome opponent and uh the
final leader Vincent climber also gets
black against fashion La Graven on paper
again these three top boards do favor
Magnus Carlson he's the only one who
gets the white pieces and he's playing
one of the lower rated players on this
score group
um it is dubov against feder save the
final two players on eight and a half
points both of them will need to go all
out for the win uh in order to catch up
and have a chance of gold to have a
chance of first place so Loris will be
focusing a lot on these top four boards
like you said Carson is a huge favorite
against Max Zulu but Max has had some
good results against Carlson in the past
they played each other over the board
just a couple of months ago in the
European Club cup and Max Zulu was
winning he let Magnus Escape but he had
him on the ropes and uh other than that
massive actually graph may be coming in
with some momentum could play the
spoiler role against Vincent kymer
anything's possible we could end up with
one player taking the gold we could end
up with five six players joints in first
place it's all of the grabs
I will say uh you know personally
speaking I think this is a terrible
pairing for Vincent Kmart I think he got
dealt a a rough pairing lag against an
inform now mvl who's finally getting
momentum rough pairing
um I don't think Fabiano will be too
displeased I think uh Fabiano has
actually got the kind of style that
artemia doesn't like I think artemia
prefers to plug into Magnus type style
and as you said max Zulu has had some
decent results against Magnus recently
but if you're Magnus Carlson you're
white you're playing magsudu you gather
yourself you you you compose yourself
and you say Okay white pieces let's put
maximum pressure on this guy because
look uh Fabiano is not an underdog in my
opinion to lose to artemiev and Kmart is
not a favorite to beat MBL so a win for
Magnus Carlson can actually give him in
the title still outright if uh you know
experience and form plays a part and we
can see here there is vladislav ah Timmy
have just one of the more unknown
quantities in Elite chess he's it's he's
he's a very strange player in many ways
not just the way he plays which is
totally unorthodox but just the fact
that he it doesn't seem like he's been a
regular fixture in absolute Elite chess
um just yet when we think of all the big
super tournaments uh when we think of
all the big invitationals he's not
featured enough for me I don't know
whether that's because he needs to play
more
I don't know maybe he's just a bit too
inconsistent
but one thing's for sure is that he's a
tricky tricky customer
big big opportunity though here for Fabi
Fabi is not going to be taking a quick
draw with the white pieces no chance he
could still win it a win here and if
magsulu doesn't lose and if MBO doesn't
lose suddenly he has a chance and Fabi
would absolutely love to win this
tournament
yeah and Lawrence just as the players
are getting started in the open we
should mention the women's tie break
will take place at the same time and
maybe we can quickly uh jump into the
tiebreak format there we go the two
players tanzongi against
two Blitz Games to start off with one
with white one with black for each
player they have three minutes on the
clock getting two seconds after every
move if the score is 1-1 after those two
games then it's straight to sudden death
straight to Armageddon chess and uh we
will find a winner at the end of that
and okay this is the playoff for the
work the world rapid title Women's World
rapper title starts off as an Amazonian
fast furious chess it's gonna be about
who can adapt to the new Pace who can
speed up it's no longer rapid it pretty
much got one third of the time that they
had in the earlier games today and uh it
looks like they have already started at
Breakneck speed and we mentioned tanzong
on paper the favorite but
ratings all of that goes out the window
when it's such high pressure situations
we see an early trade of Pawns in the
center this is still one of the modern
main lines of the nimso Indian both
players are very well prepared and said
customer looks very focused it would be
easy to get carried away with a
situation uh in your home country I'm
sure there's plenty of people out there
in the stands around the auditorium uh
cheering for her she's got to block that
all out and starting with black
a bit of an uphill struggle it's not
ideal usually you would want to maybe
start with white just to pick up some
momentum especially if you're switching
to a new time format
A6 Black slash move building up and
white can play Slowly just bring the
queen out bring the Rooks to the center
or White can blow open the center of the
board right now by pushing E4 and
Tanzania is hesitating
it's a matter of taste
and uh early days in this one but we
will get a glimpse into tanzongi's
intentions on this next move she jumps
into the center with her Knight another
very powerful move like it's 195 often a
thorn in Black side black needs to find
a solution if White NOW pushes their F
Pawn forward tanzongi has done so
already made attack for white if the
white Queens can swing over via F3 maybe
to H3 going towards that black king
White's G Pawn could throw itself
forward as well
early pressure on black I do think she
needs to maybe jump in Knight E4
something along these lines at some
point before it's too late before she
lacks counterplay Lawrence
yeah I totally agree I think you have to
do this because otherwise white has just
got a ready-made setup Rook F3 Rook H3
you played the bishop takes H7 check
suddenly becomes a threat uh and yeah
and she's played
there should be one I think this is also
a common idea in this position uh very
nice idea to relocate the bishop out to
H4 uh pin that nine that's an awkward
pin because suddenly you can't move too
many pieces so I absolutely love what
tanjongji is is doing here cd484 will be
played and now the question is will she
go Knight C6
and what is she going to do against
Bishop H4
and looking scary already Lawrence she
does
she does play Knight C6 but surely you
play Bishop H4 here do you maybe not
Knight takes D4 and you can't play
Bishop takes H7 check because there's a
bishop C5 at the end of all of it so
Bishop H4 Knight 64 Bishop H7 King H7
Queen takes D4 doesn't work on account
of Bishop C5 so uh Bishop F2 that's a
move you're happy to see as lack in this
position that's a little bit passive for
my liking but at the same time tanjong
XI just saying you know what I'm going
to keep things together she's got 30
seconds up on the clock you've got to
play faster if you didn't arousova uh
this is not what you want to do uh she
plays 97 typical move
typical move
the map is rotating her yeah Bishop H4
as you say Lawrence uh okay Queen F3
first I like this even more because
black was basically uh indicating that
her plan was to jump in with the Knight
to E4 white setup looks perfect but the
only hole is the E4 Square now how is
black going to release the tension okay
she is insisting it's all a battle
revolving ramble Square now if the black
Bishop can capture this White Knight on
C3 is chances of planting a knight into
E4 and if you don't achieve that white
is just gonna slowly build up and as you
said white has that ready-made attack
white has very aggressive intentions
towards the black king you need to swap
off pieces you need to lessen the
pressure and I was going to say a moment
ago it's very easy to play Black uh to
play wait sorry in these positions but
suddenly at least sadio cassava has a
plan and Knight G6
that feels a bit fishy to me it looks a
bit odd to uh plant the night on this
Square I think you need it to be
consistent I think you needed to go and
capture that white knight plant your
knight and E4 swap off pieces in this
manner if the white dark Square Bishop
just moves off H4 where it's attacked
you don't really want to ever capture
that White Knight on E5 that white
knight is too strong it will be replaced
by a very powerful Pawn if it's ever
captured and okay tanzanite what has she
spotted she captures that black knight
strategically this favors black but uh
can oh I did I didn't like now going
forward yes I didn't like h6366 I
thought she had to go f takes G6 there
to give some additional protection
because it looked as though F5 was
really in the works and that is what
tanjong ji has played F5 GFI but after
Queen takes F5 this looks like a
potential blowout on the queen on the
king side Bishop E7 desperately trying
to defend and a decent defensive try
where is the where is the move here for
white
you didn't work I don't think you need
to knock out blow just bring that rook
in the corner that sleeping giant into
the game Rook ae1 just add another piece
into the mix whoa
what has happened here are we behind in
the position
looks like a few moose
have been played is this correct surely
not
it is
it's gonna be a draw
okay our picture hasn't caught up yet
with the game that we're seeing on the
PGN uh on us on the digital board in
front of us White's King did Shuffle
into the corner both players down around
30 seconds
Lawrence
yeah yeah
um it looks like the relay is wrong and
let's keep with the board that we're
seeing right now in front of us the
physical board we can only trust our
eyes here and uh Knight E4 by black
trying to swap off pieces desperately
and uh will we see that variation unfold
suddenly a Trader Bishops a trade of
knights on the cards the more pieces
that disappear the better blacks
position becomes in 10 seconds on the
clock for tanzongi does take a pawn and
what will we see now Bishop takes Bishop
black is a piece up I think this
variation we saw a moment ago is about
to unfold why tonight is pinned she has
to drop back with the check
like King could just move here this is
very complicated stuff still black
facing a scary attack but she's a piece
up maybe two pieces up if she takes this
Knight the game will end in a Perpetual
track repetition and a draw and there we
go the king moves the Queen and King are
going to do a little dance
threefold repetition Dolores we are
seeing a draw in the first Blitz game of
the playoffs
I think
the opening was a bit dodgy white
definitely had a ton of initiative at
some point
and so uh a a very very good uh result
for Saturday
and Lawrence now there will be a short
break in this playoff let's go to the
open section let's catch up with the
final round of uh the open rapid World
Championship uh there we see in the
picture Magnus Carson against Parham mag
Zulu the young Iranian player and uh we
have a very complex open Sicilian and
this game started as a sicilian Magnus
really going direct when Magnus plays
this type of variation which comes with
risk it shows that he's all out he's all
in now to try and win and uh Black's
pawns advancing towards the white king
but White's King looks pretty safe
Black's King stuck in the center I
wouldn't be surprised here Loris if
White's a dark Square Bishop Retreats at
some point white will aim for a pawn
storm on the king side and um I've seen
Magnus win win several games in this
type of scenario this was of course a
favorite type of Pawn structure of Bobby
Fischer Gary Kasparov with both colors
and uh he'll need to channel them now
Magnus in order to win this crucial game
Parham meanwhile playing a very
provocative setup because remember is
black he has ambitious intentions as
well if he wins he gets a share
potentially of first prize
and who would you pick here Lawrence and
why level material but uh very well
white all day I always felt like these
particular setups were back black are
just they don't have the teeth uh
required King is still in the center
uh you know it's
uh yeah Knight G3 for example plays
itself
and you know these two pawns don't
create a massive impression for me I
don't feel like black has got the
concentration of pieces required on the
queen side to make this really uh a a
dangerous looking attack I take white
here all day of the week
yep I'm inclined to agree I didn't have
too much experience in this type of Pawn
structure in general but it does feel
like White's position is very
straightforward to play white king
doesn't look like it has too many
Defenders around it but like has no
attacking forces either on the queen
side so okay Parham activates the queen
very logical potentially eyeing up
White's undefended Knight there on the
diagonal on G3 you've always got to
watch out by uh watch out for Pawn
Breaks by black in the center now I'm
expecting Magnus to maybe push a couple
of Pawns maybe bring his lights go ahead
Bishop to a better Square
it's really heating up and you can tell
by the players clock times they're both
familiar with this type of middle game
but the uh the decisive moments are
still ahead
um Lawrence this one we think the white
has a pleasant position uh computers
tend to like this position as well for
white but a lot of life ahead how about
the other crucial matchups yeah with our
leaders let's do a quick scan because uh
everyone fighting for gold here
is a relatively
uh sort of slow uh Spanish but one where
Fabiano has already got a seven minute
time advantage on so our Timmy of taking
unnecessary amounts of time in my
opinion to get to a position like this
which Fabiano is going to be extremely
uh confident in any way having played
lots of this not really much to report
the position is pretty level nonetheless
I don't love it in the mvl
uh Vincent came our game we have a very
theoretical position in a D3 Spanish a
bit of a return of the Spanish maybe
we'll start seeing that a bit more as
the Italians started to take over but in
this particular position uh position
that mvl has had tons of time for
instance Kmart knows all about this but
this night on D5
gives what a little something to work
with a little bit of a space advantage
on the wing uh obviously occupying the
center here I think that uh MBL is going
to be more than
more than happy
uh with with his position here
Yeah you mentioned carawana having a lot
of experience in the Spanish uh mvl is
perhaps the uh kind of elite player who
has the most experience with the Spanish
opening the Royal Lopez uh I've seen him
have if not this exact position very
similar plenty of times before and yeah
every time mvl gets this type of bind
where it's up to Black uh to kind of
decide which simplifications to go for
how to break out every time I see it mvl
seems to win he calculates his way to
Victory and the pressure is certainly on
Vincent you've got a bunch of uh
possible exchanges right now you could
eliminate the white knight in the center
with your Bishop with your knight
calculations required but
um yeah it just this is you know this is
uh bread and butter for mvl he's used to
this type of position meanwhile let's go
to the women's uh playoff the second
Blitz game there Dinara sador cassava
with white this time uh maybe let's try
and get the board up as well or so we
can follow along
come up
and uh okay it looks like a London
system wow and uh copycat Chess By
tanzong Yi also bringing the black
Bishop out
um it's coincidence maybe but I was
looking at this variation last night for
white uh White has a few moves you can
push the pawn to C4 which leads to some
complications or you can play Bishop D3
a much more safe option and uh now look
at this bishop takes B1
the chest gods are having a laugh here
because I was looking at this yesterday
Bishop B4 check next is coming for black
yes
doesn't know what she's doing now white
could be in big trouble you can take wow
it's fine for white if not more but you
need to know your stuff
I vaguely remember taking with the queen
Sheck and going King D1 is that right
Yep this is what matters
yeah it's also a line is it okay yeah
and now Black's most ambitious is to
take this Pawn on C4 grab the pawn while
White's King is out in no man's land in
the center
Bishop D6 if I remember is Black's
second best move there are some ideas of
trapping this black dark Squad Bishop so
it should Retreat oh right that's that's
interesting sometimes you've got and she
does take okay so now
Queen A4 check Knight
c695 looks like a fairly tempting thing
and that has been played in 95 is
begging to be played here and it's
played
and Lawrence yesterday I was looking at
this and I was looking at Knight D5 for
black I was also looking at A5 for black
um I have a very young student in there
this is kind of their main opening
repertoire but
um yeah who knows their stuff better it
looks like sadhua katava has recovered
from the early surprise going for it the
main idea here is for example after a
move like A5 for black after white plays
Knight takes C6 black doesn't
automatically recapture a black plays
Queen to D7 and uh yeah it gets even
more messy temporary pain sacrifice but
there's a PIN to the White Queen look at
that white King on YouTube though
Lawrence this is one of those don't try
it at home type of openings right well
it is but if you can unravel and
exchange a few pieces you're okay the
king can sometimes just uh sneak out it
can either you know sometimes you can
even go crazy and put it on F3 and it's
not ridiculous there if the Queens are
off the board at least uh but you know
Sarah kiss over now with a good 30
seconds advantage on the clock and and
uh you know it looks as though tanjong
ji was not as uh prepared as perhaps
thought
yeah she she chose this variation so she
really should know the details I love
that in the feature chat a moment ago by
Virgil it does look like a bomb Cloud it
looks like white has messed up the bomb
Cloud opening slightly but this is a
much better version than Mainline bunk
Cloud Theory clearly white has pressure
on the C6 Square white has the bishop
pair long term horn Center as well so
okay A5 one of the main moves played but
after a long think look at the clock
Lawrence two minutes Against One
if Sarah customer can keep up the pace
here then she is doing pretty well
Knight takes C6 will be met by Queen D7
as we indicated most likely you don't
want to even consider taking this Knight
back because you will be left in a
terrible end game for black you have to
play Queen D7
and there we go
pin that white knight
and hey continue continuing the pace I
love this from Saturday the speed
black Bishop coming back now
Bishop D6
yeah
now you can do a lot of things with
white here
um but
I guess
taking is actually principle what about
the move G3 is that ridiculous
view too
yeah G3 often is played in this
variation and I'm not sure about this
exact position but uh G3 looks very nice
you protect your Bishop it should be two
coming
I think she should go for it she should
make a decision soon put pressure on the
clock
and okay the longer she thinks the more
complicated this is going to become if
you trade Bishops off now then I think
any hint or any hope of Advantage
disappears she takes the pawn on C4 uh
also one of the main moves if I remember
or one of the top computer suggestions
at least and now tanzani contemplating
whether to trade off Bishops if you
don't trade the Bishops if you just take
whites Knight then black has the
inferior Pawn structure and might suffer
long term
but uh not a bad move either
he's got to decide 28 seconds
and what we're going to do David
is is we're going to go to full screen
for the moment because there is a slight
delay for fair play regulations between
the relay of the video and the moves
coming in so in order to keep it tense
fair and exciting for the crowd so that
uh there's no uh moves coming in before
the video and so on and so forth we're
going to just go to full screen and
enjoy the position as it is uh well Sam
Jonesy managed to install an ion D5 Rook
ht1 will be played probably slightly
better for white but feels manageable
for black somehow still
yeah although you need to be quick you
need to be energetic as black because
Black's doubled C pawns are falling
White's Queen will start grabbing some
pawns soon okay the Black Knight
Retreats feels like the black Brooks are
not activated yet white king can always
slide back to the first round safety I
think Saturday
she didn't need to do this she could
have just no time out
now Black's Queen is active yeah I hated
Queen C6
really didn't like that move
but Lawrence maybe we can force the
Queens off the board if the White Queen
offers up a trade like Queen sees five
Queen C3 white Bishop is attacking that
black rook in the corner really nice
move there really classic
look at the clock as well Lawrence 12
seconds for black really bad position
really bad end game white has the better
minor piece the better Pawn structure
yep better Pawn structure better minor
piece for White full control for dinner
kasova she is 14 seconds away from being
World rapid Champion can she do it has
she got the has she got the nervous
system come on dinari you've got to play
quicker this is not the moment to go for
a 20-second think not this position A4 I
like fixing the structure let's go she's
okay great but she needs to keep the
pace Now find on the clock come on you
play B3 play these moves automatically
it's all right you put the bishop on B5
next The Rook on C6 and so on Knight D5
trying her best but now you can take it
and go Rook C5
yeah and she does it all because she
sticks well Rook C6 is also good here
Rook C6 played
good move King B7 good move
that King is coming though and white
does have a weakness on B3 and she
chooses to go back she's just lost a
move for free
black has the better Pawn structure now
black has a past Pawn in the center that
black d-pawn detected nicely
it's all going wrong for Saturday on the
clock and on the board Lawrence a rook
trade not good news White's Pawn
structure is inferior now White's double
death pawns they're irrelevant they're
the same as one Pawn one second
she has to move one second
he's getting bowled over
oh she's living life on the edge
she can barely make my house physically
here and she's blunted no she hasn't oh
B3 is winning oh my God winning King a
poor man game we're about to see a new
world champion
and there we go a handshake
hopeless position there for white and uh
heartbreak for the local fans over there
in Kazakhstan tanzongi takes the gold
medal
wow
what a fight
with the big victory with the black
pieces she had a horrible Mill game at
some point but Dinara she just hesitated
and she just couldn't find the energy
uh to to to to to go through and win and
slowly her position started to get worse
and worse and at some point once that
porn structure Consolidated David uh it
was all tanjongji
but it is time to refocus and uh we have
drama on the board here as well Magnus
Carlson up against Parham mag Zulu and
the position has changed it's evolved
slightly and it looks like it's in
White's favor evaluation bar loving
magnus's position uh there's Council
play of course black will try a
counter-attack against the white king
but look how far Advanced White's attack
is that black king is feeling the Heat
and uh Parham trying to swap off pieces
Magnus could just say no or he could
continue with the attack he keeps
throwing pawns towards that black king
White Knight can leap in uh towards it
as well and hit a Trader Bishops it
looks like from Carson but looks like
one-way traffic Lawrence do you see any
defense if Magnus just keeps his cool
just pushes his Pawn forward to H5 looks
straightforward White's attack
yeah this attack plays itself and this
is what I was saying before I I disliked
uh Black's opening because I think he's
too slow and we're going to see that now
Magnus gonna lay down the hammer and
remember guys let's just take a quick
reminder let's remind each other what
the situation is going into this last
round Carlson Kamer our Timmy have all
on nine points if Carlson beats magsudu
and Kmart and artemiova are unable to
win and in my opinion they're both
underdogs in their respective matches
then Carlson will win the tournament
outright despite having a traumatic past
few rounds losing to our teamiev uh with
it with a just a an uncharacteristic
peace blunder in a very safe position
not beating Fabiana karawana with the
white pieces in fact at some point he
was even potentially a little bit worse
um so this is a massive massive spot for
Magnus he's a bit down on the clock it's
all right though six minutes again seven
minutes 56 he just needs to hold his
concentration and a win here will be
massive now looking at the other games
Fabiano is much better against artemiev
mvl though is he worse against Kmart
surely Vincent Cameo win would be out of
the question uh could we get a younger
world champion than we did last year is
that even feasible is that is that
reasonable it could be it could be I
think uh Kmart is slightly older now
than Abdus was last year so the answer
is no but uh Vincent kymer definitely uh
staking his claim he's not out of the
equation yet uh vashilograph against
kaima we will come to but maybe we can
show why we're so in love with magnus's
position he's got five minutes he's low
on the clock against almost eight
minutes for Max Zulu but what if white
just keeps things simple it is a race
after all Kings on opposite flanks it's
about who can break through to the to
the uh enemy Monarch first and just H5
push that point forward to H5 it looks
Crystal Clear what is Magnus uh
calculating here maybe he's going deeper
scratching beneath the surface it looks
like H5 followed by pushing the pawn
forward to G6 the next move is going to
wrench open a line on that King side
black will struggle to defend there
don't think black is in time if black
tries to copy and plays haunt A4 white
breaks through first G6 and white arise
one move before black does and uh
that's all she wrote that is the end of
the game White's Queen is going to crash
through
I can't see the way that magazine can
hold here
oh brutal Lawrence
this is one track meeting idea
for example there are many of them as
well
so H5 here just that extra half move as
David is saying Bishop B5 Now by magsulu
but hold on a second I've got an idea
can you nah you don't have to take on H7
here I wanted to make it work for the
crowd it might still be good actually
Bishop takes H7 King takes H7 and now
not Queen takes of some but either G6 or
H6 I'm not sure which one I would go
with probably G6 I would go just follow
with the checks and isn't this just
crushing and he's played it
he sacrifices Bishops
this is he's a spin on the Greek gift
the Greek gift sacrifice is always
Bishop takes H7 luring the enemy King
out and I mean that variation you showed
looks I mean just looks killer it looks
winning for white and uh that's what the
top chess players do they've drilled it
into themselves from years and years of
training they look at checks and
captures first the most forceful moves
forcing the opponent's replies narrowing
the path and like you said one check
Bishop takes H7 second check G6 this
black king is not surviving all the
files are opening up the king is all on
its own and game over and maybe Max Zulu
has to just bite the bullet and run away
with his King but Magnus then will have
just grabbed a very very important Pawn
he's still pushing forward and uh yeah
has remained confidence says in the
feature chat never trust degree gift in
this case the Greek gift simply looks
winning uh I'm loving that as well by
Yasser fangirl Lawrence Trent Wilson
you're channeling Magnus there Lawrence
fantastic move Adventure yeah this
attack Place itself you've mentioned it
I don't see any reply no defense here
no I'm thinking f8 I can just play H6
even promote that H Pawn
yeah and the important point is G6 does
not block the transmission because you
can just take on G6 thanks to the pin
all right this is this is about as dead
as it comes uh Magnus just double
checking triple checking and I you know
I felt it prior to this round I really
did that this was a bad pairing for
magsudu and a bad pairing for the other
guys online
um Magnus has had parham's number uh a
few times I remember uh and yeah this is
just brutal and Parham in the tank
trying to manufacture a way where he can
at least put up a little bit of
resistance but there is just nothing to
be done really because on King h8 let's
say King h8 which is a another move here
um you could even just take on F7 again
here pretty quickly threading mate on G8
the C2 Pawn is well over protected and
once more I move like King takes G6
186h7 is just going to run into H6
followed by
hg7 Checkmate on the next move and
there's literally nothing you can do to
stop it it is toast for my Suitland
and Lauren some quick updates on the
other key matchups it looks like
artemiev is worse on board two Carolina
has the advantage there Carolina not one
of the leaders but in the chasing pack
so that would be a great result for
Carlson if Artemis cannot win his game
Vincent climber however
looking balanced I've got to say maybe
with a small Advantage so Magnus can't
celebrate just yet okay Max Zulu bites
the bullet he takes the gifted piece
that Greek gift of a bishop and he takes
this Pawn to where is the killer blow
Magnus plays Queen F7 while so calm not
even going for the obvious capture on G6
not tricking the black king into coming
out further I think that would have been
winning too but Queen F7 closes the net
takes away the Escape Square on G8 for
Black's king and you can see in his body
language Magnus he knows Checkmate is
coming if G5 then it's the same idea
that you mentioned Loris if black tries
to block this H file H6 again comes and
it's inevitable the H file will open
decisively
no defense this is uh just a classic
attack this belongs in end game uh sorry
not end game attacking manuals uh for
the open Sicilian it just
it's brutal when Checkmate happens
like this heartbreak as well for Mike
Zulu who's fought so well this
tournament who's launched a bit of a
streak there in the second half
magnet's just too good in this game
Queen F7 the killer blue
and uh he's looking good for the gold
medal after a bit of a traumatic start
to today
Queen F7 yeah
okay he does go G5 H6 and he's gonna
give out his hand here Magnus Carlson at
least in a playoff for the rapid World
Championships he's defeated Parham
maxoodlu but everything defends now on
the other games going on Fabiana carvana
has got a great position against our
Timmy of look at this he's a pawn up
control on the board this is a disaster
for our Timmy f as I said I think Fabi
is a bad opponent for our Timmy of and
Vincent Kamer you said it was slightly
equally it looks like that as well like
mbl's so tough to be oof
c4b4 makes a lot of sense Vincent trying
to create a possible but hold on a
second born to F4 exploiting the back
rank you can't take that pawn
um because you will get back rank mated
and
so you're supposed to play actually the
next move here does not look intuitive
at all here to me because Knight D7 runs
into some Bishop A4 stuff so hold on a
second from being slightly better is
Kmart now slightly worse
it's getting very complicated there
Lawrence and we did see Magnus just walk
in front of the camera there he was
checking out his main Rivals games it
must be a nice situation to be in
winning quickly relaxing in case there's
a playoff but he will have taken a look
at this one he knows that fascia lagrov
is fantastic in these types of positions
he trusts in Maxim to do him a favor now
Magnus and like you say Vincent is under
pressure uh maybe Vincent can play E4
okay there we go he has bypassed the
white F Pawn and what is happening here
G5 by Vince
throwing a pawn forward now there's no
background Checkmate Lawrence suddenly
online
he takes D3 uh just opens oh my goodness
the difference is black is suddenly
winning because the King has an escape
Square on G7 white cannot take the black
Rook with his Queen now just loses
material G5 genius
what a move G5 and now he can play after
D4 he can play gf4 and land a knight on
E5 if he ever gets a knight on E5 it's
toast for white strategically speaking
yeah
like there's so many past pawns dark
Square blockade will render White's
Bishop irrelevant amazing genius move
there by Vincent Magnus is watching
these two he knows it's changing on
every turn can white throw a spanner in
the works though can white play a move
such as E5 just to avoid any blockade he
goes for it I think Maxine Fashion's
graph there we go he does Fight Fire
with Fire not backing down his Queen was
attacked who cares counter-attack
against the black queen and I think we
will see a trade down into an end game
what is the pawn count it's five points
against Five Pawns whose minor piece is
better whose pawns are better
who knows at this point it is pure chaos
but the evaluation bar does say that uh
it is still within the Realms of
equality and
fireworks Lords uh the players are not
uh disappointing in this round both of
these two want to win of course but
after that little series of Genius moves
by both sides it looks like it might
Peter out towards equality I don't see
how white keeps his further Advanced of
the two double D pawns intact I think
that will drop Black's epon will also
fall still a lot to play for of course
equality does not mean a draw it just
means that uh chances are level and with
best play that would be the most likely
result
who do you favor here
um I'm still struggling I think I would
pick black if anyone but yeah ever so
ever so slightly but I've got no real
feel for this position whatsoever
knowing my my intuition is is
not serving me at all here
um it's a calculating type of end game
uh it's not a standard not one of those
where you just understand things
instantly it's all about pure
calculation concrete moves Vincent tries
to get the black Rook active nice trap
uh if Rook takes E3 right now for whites
then the black Rook is going to come
down Rook A1 check and I think F2 Knight
G4 wins the game for black
setting traps Vincent he knows he needs
to win to catch up with Magnus
still so tense and what's happening
onboard two Lawrence this is board three
one of the leaders climber yeah
before the round
is he holding against Carolina
well
he's with he's regained the pawn at
least
it's not a mouse slip
it looks like it should be but it's not
a mouse lip uh no matter which black uh
which black captured the white Rook the
other Rook would have fallen and now
heroin is broken through to the
background there's all sorts of mating
ideas Knight F6 check is a monster
threat right now if black doesn't guard
against it okay Black's Rook Retreats it
Lawrence where's The Knockout it must be
here how about Bishop takes G7 G7 no oh
It Feels So Close uh maybe black can
play Rook takes E8 here and survive it's
uh by the skin of the teeth for black
but
um where is The Knockout karawana is
gonna be
well he's got three minutes I was gonna
say he's gonna spend all of his
remaining time on this one moment his
Spidey senses will be telling him
there's a winning blow 95 is also very
tempting for white here
packing the F7 what about
uh
so many attempting moose Lawrence oh I
think
I have an idea
okay I have an idea
so if I go Knight six H6 check
foreign
yeah no the bar said no so I wanted to
go Queen G4 but it doesn't
oh actually enough there's a nice
variation there Lawrence 1966 Queen
takes H6 uh by black and after the White
Queen captures black flicks in the uh
the intermediate move Rook D1 check next
move takes the White Queen saves the day
and wins a piece and uh hey
Rook d8 played Carolina the only move
I've seen so far that seems promising is
95 just trying to cash in on the week F7
square is that an attempt Lawrence
Knight E5 I can't see a defense for the
black there I've got to say uh
and he slayed it he's played it he's
played it takes Rook now Queen takes F7
check white comes out of Pawn up with a
raging attack
massive favor to Magnus Carlson and
meanwhile I'm keeping an eye on the mvl
Vincent game because that is still a
three result game by the way
um well although I am stunning to like
Vincent's position more F6 Queen F7 King
H7 on the board this looks close it
looks like you're you shouldn't be
surviving this with black under normal
circumstances how about just Knight G4
wow very calm cool collected yeah
capturing on F6 next move winning the
black queen or giving Checkmate that
looks decisive maybe as well Knight D7
same idea Lawrence there and uh Carolina
has just played it uh yeah really nice
finesse nice Finishing Touch and like
has to give up his Rook for that strong
White Knight checkmates coming Black's
Bishop yeah is dropping that black
knight is offside you can't defend and
tell me I've just playing out of inertia
as you say Checkmate is inevitable and
we see the handshake artemiev is out of
the running for first prize marijuana
playing the role of spoiler
and that means we've only got one game
left relevant for this tournament
Rook A7 this is the position it's three
pawns against four pawns but black has
got a very Advanced pass B Pawn
and I would still take black in a real
game I guess because
I have this Pawn but at the same time
MBL he's such a tricky customer tricky
Defender
king of two on the board
what do we think here
black has very uh various tempting moves
you can give a check get the black's
Rook active with Tempo that looks like
the uh most natural uh there we go
Vincent plays it uh if black had pushed
his beep on White's Rook is ready to
swing over to B8 behind I don't think
you should get uh too impatient and push
black speed Pawn that is a long-term
trump card uh keep it up your sleeve for
later Vincent grabs a pawn back
meanwhile establishing uh
re-establishing material equality and
and vl's banking everything on White H
Pawn Knights remember ask ad stopping
these H pawns a pawns but with Rooks on
the board Lawrence I agree it looks like
Black's play is easier I would be
tempted to give another check uh from
black with the Rook maybe the black king
can start entering the center later the
black Rook on its own can't do the can't
do the business Black's Knight is
perfectly placed on an outpost as a
blockader
climate must be the favorite also one
minute up on the clock but such high
stakes and he can't afford a slip
otherwise mvl will hold this one you
mentioned three result game loans it
feels like Vincent has this uh well he
has uh all the aces here
I don't think black should lose unless
you take massive risks he gives a check
white Retreats with this King
maximum is great at these types of end
games where it's pure calculation so
you're right it's gonna be difficult to
break through his defenses but maybe
bring the king I don't see anything else
Black's Knight is frozen you don't want
to push the B Pawn too far yet
you could slide behind White's H porn
with the BlackRock Rook H3 but I I would
be tempted to bring the king uh just add
an extra spice to the equation
yeah I love this video
I love this plan David bringing that
King getting it on some dark Squares Out
The Way
Rook H Street
doesn't change things too much I would
still be tempted to uh push the black
king forward now
yeah at least he's kind of uh stopped
White's rook in its tracks White's Rook
is in front of its Pawn therefore
passive
you want Rooks behind ideally although
mvl is just two moves away from putting
that white Pawn on H7 and then the Rook
will be free the pawn on H7 will be
defended by white Bishop
yeah suddenly
yeah Vincent has some work to do some
calculation to be done great ending to
the tournament says job ahead in the
future chat I agree so tense
Magnus is going to be watching this one
as well
um hoping that Maxim can do him a favor
B3 is now the moment can white not just
go after this Pawn
White's Rook is gonna go to B8 Vincent
is that a sign of nerves how's he going
to keep his Pawn alive Lawrence that was
his main uh main advantage I think he
wants to put I think he wants to go B2 I
think this is his idea and say that this
Pawn is immune because on Rook takes B2
you have Rook H2 check
but it does feel a little premature to
say the least and I just want to remind
everybody of course Vincent Kmart is
playing in order to be able to play a
playoff for the world rapid Championship
a win is the only acceptable result here
for Vincent Kamer Rook B8 has been
played by mvl he will go B2 and now the
question is
ah he's also saying that for example on
a move like King D2 I can just take on
H5 because this ending here after Rook
B2 Rook H2 King C3 trade is a really bad
ending for white and I agree this has to
be losing you just bring the king in uh
something like this a very simple you're
gonna March CF Pawn the Knight it's
glorious and this is a fairly simple
winning end game
is it gonna be fairy tale time for
Vincent Kmart playing for the world
rapid championship against Magnus
Carlsen I see no moves for MBL wow
Lawrence look at the camera he has gone
for this end game Vincent kymer could be
about to force the playoffs the Rooks
are off the board Black's King is Coming
Black's Knight dominates the white
Bishop White's Bishop is a terrible
piece flex f Pawn is going to start
marching soon we could well see a
playoff for the world title I mean he's
playing for money he's playing for the
gold medal he's paying for a title
everything now Vincent this is the
highlight of his career this one game
can he finish it off that black king is
so strong white is almost Frozen that
black king can come even further yeah
how is he gonna defend this it's one way
traffic right now look at the evaluation
bar it's collapsed for mvl it's all gone
wrong for instance pushing that B Pawn
turned out to be a genius stroke and
just bring the king in you can save that
F Pawn for later
and uh Maxi Russian Grove he's also
running out of moves White's Bishop is
completely stuck defending pawns you
cannot move it white it's just gonna
have to yo-yo with his King D2 E2 D2 E2
he's just got to wait and uh Vincent
here he can even go into three check
yeah exactly throw that pawn forward
reflect the white king away
kingdom is forced
and in this position this is where you
need the touch
maybe you could just go F2 anyway
because King U2 F1 equals Queen
is winning and if you play a move like
Bishop F1 now you can play
Knight takes C4 check and the point is
that takes takes in the other variations
uh White was able to play D6 but he's
too slow because of F2 so F3 checkers
it's just winning right I mean I don't
even see even the modicum of Hope for
MPL
response
he's feeling
he's feeling the nerves now Vincent
kymer biggest game of his career so far
does he play F3 is he going to go for it
right now is he going to step back with
his Knight I don't think he should miss
this moment if you don't seize your
opportunity in life in chess then the
moment might pass if he moves the knight
at least Maxine gets some hope so F3
he's got to play it under 20 seconds now
is this the moment Vincent kinda Vincent
the time is just winning 10 seconds he
plays does it F2 and he's going for this
version
he could just take on C4 but then King
E2 and then Knight E3 perhaps
Knight E3 is no 93 D6 excuse me
some calculation to be done can white
survive this now oh Vincent I think he's
let it slip suddenly
he only has a pool now
oh no what did he do
maybe it wasn't correct going for it oh
my goodness wow suddenly white special
is going to give itself up for Black's
porn this should now be a draw maybe F3
F3 must have been right but F2 maybe he
could have backed it up with a check
first and knight move
he's getting his Bishop out he's getting
ready to cover the Black Point advance
surely a drawn out Lawrence
has to break so close for Vincent oh my
goodness
and and Vincent now
oh got it he's absolutely devastated
what the body language
and there's just no way
he was one accurate move away it was the
nerves it was the clock as well he was
down under 10 seconds like you said
Lawrence
when the clock ticks down the brain goes
out the window especially with such high
stakes and Magnus Carlson now watching
this game must feel confident black
simply can't Advance his Pawn there's no
way to get it past the vision of that
white Bishop actually the graph keeps
his Bishop on the long diagonal and we
will see a handshake a draw any moment
the world title is going to Norway it is
going to Magnus Carlson
but what a fight Vince has put up
Lawrence what a player he is going to be
what a player he already is
yeah and interestingly the engine here
is giving uh minus seven or minus eight
it's saying for example you move the
Knight let's say the bishop moves
somewhere
let's say Bishop to F1
you then move the king or not like this
in a moment we have just seen the
handshake it is confirmed Magnus Carlson
is the world rapid Champion 2022
Bachelor of saves his own skin but also
ensures uh the destiny of the title look
at this Vincent maybe just finding out
where he went wrong discussing his
missed win we'll look at that in a
moment but
what a game it was there until the very
end and I think we saw Magnus Carlson as
well puffing out his cheeks as he walked
away relieved
what a day it's been so many twists and
turns
Lauren some yeah it's just been so
dramatic
it has been
it's been traumatic heartfelt
condolences to Vincent he fought
valiantly
uh for the whole day to get himself even
in the position he's had a brilliant
tournament let's be honest uh but it is
the goat himself Magnus Carlson adding
another world championship
belt to his roster this time a world
rapid uh World Championship not his
first
uh but he's absolutely delighted to
reclaim that title after botching it
against Abdul saturov last year
and Magnus
as he said on many occasions to the
press to his fans he believes that this
particular tournament is an extremely
relevant and important Tournament of
relevant title the world rapid
Championship he'll be absolutely
delighted relief is the word used David
I think I would Echo that sentiment he's
had a tough day the loss against
artemiev the bad position against
karuana and then to kind of be gifted uh
an easier Victory against maxulu and
then for all of the other results to go
in his favor he needed two results to go
in his favor and he even had to sweat
that one at the end but his boy MBL came
through for him and uh we see Magnus
Carlsen regaining the world rapid crown
and he'll be gunning for the world Blitz
Crown as well which will start tomorrow
and of course we need to give another
shout out to tan
for her wonderful performance in the
women's section also to Dinara
sadokasova it could have gone either way
tan just had the better nerves she just
didn't hesitate as much
um and that meant that tan took home the
title there too so a happy Magnus
Carlsen
yeah we see some behind the scenes
footage of the auditorium backstage
Magnus greeted by the adoring fans by
some journalists he looked happy he gave
a very brief interview there uh but uh
yeah bigger challenges ahead of course
the world Blitz as you mentioned there
Lawrence but step one for Magnus has
been accomplished fair play to Vincent
climber all of the top uh all of the
Prize winners all of the top finishers
they put their heart into this they
performed admirably some fantastic chess
throughout these last three days there's
still some action in the world rapid
championships since the games still
going on uh in the open section we do
however have our two world champions
Magnus Carlson and tanzongi and uh this
is I think one of the final games going
Buddha with white against Amin tapatabai
from Iran
black looks like he's going for
checkmate white king not entirely safe
but white does have an extra Bishop so
this should be winning for Duda but what
is the finishing touch both sides around
20 seconds are we going to end this
tournament on a high where we see
another decisive result really
complicated end game that's been the
theme of the last three days
and uh okay dude brings his Rook the
whole way around getting ready to check
the black king if it ever steps onto the
third rank
this looks like a win for white uh a win
for Duda here and uh yeah Lawrence is uh
feels weird analyzing now after all the
drama of that uh that most recent end
game between kaima and vashilograph but
now we will stick with this one till the
end and confirm the standings a bit
later on uh white king now is free of
its Jail uh of its prison on the first
Rank and
dude that is gonna clinch this any
moment now
we see Tabata by heading hands he knows
he's let it slip no more checkmates and
therefore black is lost
yeah easy win now
easy easy easy win for yeah I'm just off
uh he's gonna go T6 this is more than
sufficient
uh a rook and yeah let's use H3 it's
going to play a little bit on inertia
here
but uh this is
uh probably uh he's probably just gonna
resign at some point because also it's
just
there's only
you know so much fight one can have
the position is secure he's probably
just going to run over to Queen side
slowly Infiltrate The King via uh
uh by the queen side King G5
Rook D6 he's going to put the Rook on D3
he's got all the time in the world he
can even exchange a pair of Pawns to
make his job easier
and gutted to batter by you can see
just got it
uh with this position lying on on pure
inertia
he's had a good uh he's had a good
tournament he's about to buy he really
took down Nakamura but uh there we go it
ends on this note Duda does taking a win
and uh that's important for the prizes
remember so much at stake and uh doozer
does get a slice of the prize money I
believe with that win
massive slice I mean dude Duda was on
seven and a half that Rockets him to
eight and a half and that was the final
game and
well
Let's uh let's now just have a quick
view of
the players the playing Hall we've seen
three days of brilliant rapid chess it's
not over we've got the Blitz World
Championships as well over the next two
days so we're not going anywhere but we
should give another uh
uh shout out really uh and owed to the
winners of these tournaments firstly to
Magnus Carlson for winning the world
rapid championships it was topsy-turvy
on the last day but he got the job done
sanjongji showing the better nerves well
done to her for winning uh the women's
Magnus Carlson netting sixty thousand
dollars for tanjong ji it's forty
thousand dollars in uh in the women's uh
should be pointed out that of course
Dinara having lost the playoff gets the
silver medal still a very proud moment
for her and I I'm not a hundred percent
sure on third but I believe according to
the standings I have that it is the
young Indian Savita who may have stolen
the third place position I will get
double confirmation on that regardless
she's at a great tournament moment
getting third place bronze twenty
thousand dollars absolutely huge and in
the open section well we've been talking
about it it is the world champion for
the moment the world number one the
greatest of all time Madness Carlson
winning uh and a very disappointed
Vincent Kamer who uh shares second and
third with Fabi Fabiana carwana we're
not sure who gets the silver and bronze
yet we'll have further clarification a
bit later on
we come back same time same place
tomorrow for the blitz uh it's gonna be
wild and wacky uh we have even more
rounds per day uh do make sure that you
come back tomorrow because the blitz is
for many people at least their favorite
uh event of of this particular schedule
and uh also just bear in mind that uh we
have uh another
promotion or initiative going on at
chess.com which is that if you are a
streamer looking to grow your audience
and reach the dizzying heights of the
likes of Hikaru Nakamura Gotham chess
the boater sisters
the chess.com Community streamer program
brings your stream to the world's
biggest chess platform chess.com with
new features that will be in your
presence in the community all you have
to do is connect your Twitch account to
your account on chess.com set your
Twitch category to chess and start
streaming use the code exclamation mark
streaming start streaming in chat for
all the details
Fabi uh sorry a big event I called you
Fabi David uh it's been uh it's been
emotional but uh I don't think you can
have too many complaints with the
overall winning winners
nope uh they deserved it in the end we
always say the cream does rise to the
top in the end Magnus came uh came in
first place he deserved it despite that
one move blunder we saw earlier today
and likewise in the women's section
tanzong Yi she was the most consistent
she held her nerve better in that
playoff and uh she therefore deserves
her title as you say Lawrence it's been
a roller coaster ride the level of Chess
has been so high so entertaining every
player taking risks in every round and
I'm pretty sure that's going to continue
in the blitz where we will look forward
to Hikaru Nakamura staking more of a
claim he's guaranteed to be one of the
top dogs there uh of course Carolina
riding off that high coming joint second
in the end on that winning streak he's
gonna be there too Magnus is going to
have his work cut out and 21 rounds of
Blitz in the open section over two days
it's gonna be fast and furious as you
mentioned and I can't wait to get
started tomorrow it's gonna be a long
day but a really exciting day that's
guaranteed
yep and of course we have the Women's
World Blitz as well uh are we gonna get
uh tanjong ji is she going to win uh two
titles that would be unbelievable Magnus
Carlson is he going to win two titles I
can tell you this he would want nothing
more than to win the World Blitz title
that is a title very very dear to his
heart
is going to be it from us uh thank you
so much for everybody who tuned in who
stayed with us throughout the duration
wherever you're from thank you for your
support and thank you for your kind
words thank you also to of course the
production team everybody at chess.com
for making this possible we're not done
though tomorrow
the world Blitz championships who is
going to win is mvl going to defend his
crown
we'll soon find out
see you all tomorrow 1am Pacific Time 10
a sorry one a bigger one in his 1am
Pacific Time 10 a.m Central European
Time I'm Laura shent and from David hell
it's been an absolute pleasure see you
all tomorrow for the Wildlife
championships
bye everyone life is full of exciting
events but it is our first impressions
that we remember best your first diploma
your first job in a big company
Unforgettable emotions from the first
date the first expensive things you
bought when you got your first paycheck
and your first Investments with freedom
broker Freedom broker look at your
favorite brands from A New Perspective
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]